AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO COVID
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS BE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL WAS
SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
CENTER MELENDEZ WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
AND THIS WILL GREATLY AID. IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT A MUTE BFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. AND R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU ONCE YOU ARE DONE. ONE ONCE
RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WI ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS.
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE- IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I ONE OUNCE IT
NOW. THAT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TOTAL
COMFORT SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ON THAT
WEBSITE YOU CAN ALSO CONTACT US
THROUGH EMAIL IF YOU DON'T GET
A CHANCE TO MAKE YOUR VOICE
HEARD. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR CLEARLY
AND AVOID AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AGAIN WE ASK YOU TO
MEET YOUR DEVICES IF YOU'RE
WATCHING IT REMOTELY. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISTRICT OF
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING THEM. OR HAVE THEIR-
LINE DISCONNECTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
RESPECT. AND PATIENCE. TO THE
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL RELATING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. I WILL NOT THAT ALL
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA WILL BE UP
FOR DISCUSSION BUT WE WILL NOT
BE VOTING ON ANY ITEMS TODAY.
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING AFTER ALL
ITEMS HAVE BEEN HURT. FIRST UP
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH-
FIRST AGENDA ITEM THE BUDGET
SUMMARY AND CASELOAD
UTILIZATION. WE WOULD WELCOME.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED CARE
HI NANCY PARCHMAN THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I'D
LIKE TO THINK OF THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA TODAY.
ALSO LIKE TO THANK- COMMITTEE
STAFFER A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
AND INFORMATIVE AGENDA THAT WAS
PREPARED FOR OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY I'M I'M JOINED TODAY BY-
WITH CARLA CASTANEDA RYAN
WINFIELD YOUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTORS EACH HURTING YEAH WHO
IS THE CHIEF OF DATA ANALYTICS
AND STRATEGY AND JIM KNIGHT WHO
IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AND
TOGETHER WILL BE RESPONDING TO
THE QUESTIONS- IN THE AGENDA
AND ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE- SO I WANT TO START
WITH- ISSUE ONE AND- CARLA
CASTANEDA IT WLL BE JOINING
ME. AND RESPONDING TO THAT THE
QUESTIONS HERE- THE FIRST-
QUESTION WILL BE ADDRESSED BY
CARLA- BUT I'M GOING TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY. TO QUESTIONS TWO AND
THREE. SO AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA- AND CERTAINLY I CONCERN
OF THE DIP. WITH PARTICULAR AT
OUR K. WE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN OUR START THAT DAY
HAVE ANY OF. IN OUR PROJECT TO
BUDGET. SO I'LL JUST GO AHEAD
OF HER YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW.
FOR CURRENT YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OUR CASELOAD WE HAVE
AN UPDATED PROJECTION OF. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETEEN
CONSUMERS. WHICH IS ACTUALLY
REFLECTING A DECREASE FROM OUR
ENACTED ON CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
OF EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR INDIVIDUALS- WHEN
WE LOOK TO A PROJECTION FOR
BUDGET YEAR- WHAT WE DID IN OUR
PROJECTION FOR CASELOAD IN OUR
ESTIMATE IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
WANTED TO RETAIN. OUR TREND
WITH THE INTENT IS TO BE ABLE
TO RECOVER WITHIN THE EARLY
START PROGRAM PRIMARILY FOR AND
TAKEN ALL TALK ABOUT THAT NOW A
MOMENT. SO FOR BUDGET YOU'RE A
CASELOAD ESTIMATE IS THAT-
ESTIMATED AT. THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE INDIVIDUALS.
WHICH REFLECTS NET INCREASE.
OVER OUR- UPDATED- CURRENT YEAR
OF JUST OVER TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THIS
REPRESENTS AN OVERALL 8%
INCREASE ON JUST TO GIVE YOU A
REFERENCE FOR DISPLAY WERE
ABOUT 425% AS OUR CASELOAD-
GROSS. A AND BASIS- OF NOTES-
PRIMARILY WE ARE- RECORD. OF
AFFAIR OUT OF THAT THAT. IN OUR
REALLY STARTING. SO FROM OUR
YEAR FTA TO OUR YEAR. ARE
PROJECTING AN INCREASE FOR ON
OUR RELEASED START FROM AT
NIGHT. FIVE AND ONE WHICH IS
20% OVER- OUR CURRENT YEAR. SO
WHY WOULD WE BE I'M DOING A PER.
AND NOT ME IT TO YOUR CASE LOW
ESTIMATES- ONE WHICH IS- IN THE
AREA WHICH WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE- DILIGENT AND
HYPER. ON OUR STAGE CASE-
PRIMARY ALSO WAS SOME OF THE
INTO AND LETTER SERVICE. UNDER
TWO ISSUES ARE REALLY. OUR
EARLY. ON ONE IS THE DOOR IF
YOU WILL- THANK YOU THAT ARE
KIND INTO THE PROGRAM WE SEE
I'D BE VERY AT THE PEAK BACKING
APRIL OF TWENTY TO. OF OUR
EARLY START- AND DRY CORAL TO
STAY AT ORDER COATED- AND WE
CAN KIND OF MAKE SOME OF. AS TO
WHY WAS SENT THEM- IT IT TO BE
THAT- THERE IS A D. AND- TO
THEIR- WELL- WELL BABY CHECK-
PEDIATRICIAN. I'M NOT BEING IN
IN AND- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
AREAS IN WHICH ARE TYPICALLY
ARE FOR TO OUR REFERRALS FOR
EARLY STARTS ARE- CERTAINLY
DOES IS VERY CAN. TO AND WE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PRO. THAT THE
RESULTS THEY ARE DOLLARS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEIR- TO ADDRESS
THESE THEIR- THAT'S THE WHY WE
DID NOT MAKING A- TO THE OPRY
DOLLAR THAT NOR WE WOULD GO
CORPS INSIDE. WITH A DECREASE
OR IN. OF A CASE- SO WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT ADDRESSING SOME
THE ISSUE WITH- EARLY START
LIKE I SAY THE FRONT DOOR BY
ALSO TRANSIT. FROM EARLIEST IN-
AND- FROM THE START WITH-
REALLY ADDRESS THAT CHOI FINE-
WE'RE FOR IN THAT DEVELOPER
SERVICE THIS. WE HAVE MANY
NETWORK PARTNERS THAT ARE
REALLY- FOCUSED ON- ASSURING
ACCESS TO- REALLY START FOR
THOSE KIDS THAT ARE AT RISK FOR
DEVELOPING THE DISABILITY. YEAH
WE WORKED WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
PARTICULARLY THEIR INTERAGENCY.
COORDINATING COUNCIL. I FOCUS
ON WHAT ARE THE- FOR THAI BY
WHAT IT OPERATE. BRIDGE AND
OUTREACH TO- PEDIA. TO RAISE
THE AWARENESS THAT WE ARE. I'M
REALLY THINK THIS CIGNA- AND
REFERRAL. WE ALSO- THE SEARCH
GENERAL WHO- GRACE OFF TO DO.
PUBLIC SERVICE AND- ON BOTH IN
ENGLISH AND WILL BE IN SPANISH
CLOSED CAPTION. ON THAT WILL BE
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE THIS WEEK
RAISING THIS ISSUE- IT
DEFINITELY WE ALSO HAVE A FOCUS
ON WORKGROUP- THAT IS COMPRISED
OF ADVOCATES WITHIN OUR SYSTEM
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON EARLY START SERVICES.
MEMBERS CLINICAL STAFF AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEN ALSO
THE UNIVERSITY FOR EXPLAINS-
BEING A TO FOCUS- THESE ISSUES
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW TO ADDRESS THEM
BEING RESPONSIVE- AND NUMBER-
DURING THIS TO. OF AS FAR AS
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE FOR THOSE-
OF THE KIDS THAT WERE MOVING
FROM EARLY START AT AGE THREE-
EITHER- UNTIL IT ACTUALLY.
PROGRAM THROUGH THE PA SCHOOL
OR UNTIL MATTER SERVICES- WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT MANY SYSTEMS ARE
REALLY FACED THESE CHALLENGES
AND CERTAINLY EDUCATION WAS
ONE- AND THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
BRING ON THE KID'S- DURING THAT
TIME TO CRITICALLY EARLY ON AND.
AND THE PANDEMIC. SO WE ISSUED
A DIRECT- EARLY- JUNE- WE'RE
UNDER THE AGE. ORDER IS GAVE- I
SAW TO WAY CERTAIN- DIFFERENT
THAT WE WAIT TO THAT TIME WAS
TO. HAVE A- THAT WE DID NOT AND
EARLIEST SERVICE FOR THE
CHILDREN. THAT WERE NOT TO
AGILE. SERVICES AT THE AGE OF
THREE. THE REGIONAL CENTERS-
WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE THOSE
SERVICES FOR THESE KIDS. THIS
IS BEEN EXTENDED THROUGH APRIL
OF THIS- CURRENT YEAR AND WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO EVALUATE WE
ARE DEFINITELY SEE AN INCREASE
IN OUR INTAKE FOR CHILDREN.
WE'RE ALSO SEEING A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN TRANSITIONING TO
EDUCATION SERVICES. SO MANY OF
THOSE STRATEGIES ARE CERTAINLY
WORKING BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
EFFORTS. BECAUSE WE DEALT DO
YOU KNOW THAT I'M RECOVERY IN
THIS PARTICULAR AREA IS GOING
TO TAKE US. A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME AND ON THE LONGER THAT WE-
THE LADY SERVICES TWO KIDS THE
HIGHER RISK THEY ARE GOING TO
BE- FOR LONGER TERM. NEEDS
WITHIN OUR SYSTEMS WILL
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT FOCUS
AND PRIORITY. SO I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND HANDED OFF TO CARLA
CASTANEDA TO PROVIDE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF. THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DISCUSSING IT UP THANK YOU-
BECAUSE THE OTHER DEPARTMENT OR
LITTLE SERVICES ARE CURRENTLY
BUDGET IS TO GROW THRILLED AND
FROM INTERACTIVE BUDGET NINETY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT
POINT NINE BILLION GENERAL.
THAT INCREASES IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TO POINT FIVE BILLION SIX
POINT FIVE RANGE OF FUND YOU'RE
A HIGHLIGHTS THE BREAK OF
EXPENDITURES REGIONAL CENTERS
OPERATED AND BORDERS. THE
INCREASE IN FUNDING SUPPORT
PROJECTION FOR ROAD UTILISING.
AS WERE AS- TO. FOR WITH. AND
IT JUST I DON'T THAT ARE ACT
AND DELIVERY OF SIR. BURKE
NINETEEN NEXT. IN CURRENT YEAR
WERE HUNDRED AND FORMALLY. OF
ABOUT TWO FIFTY TWO POINT FOUR
CHEN FUND MANAGERS AGREED TO
FOR THE FOR YEAR. IN THE BUDGET
YEAR INTERESTED IN INK BECAUSE
RELATED TO CORPORATE CORPORATE
HALF YEAR THAT'S ABOUT TO COME
AND SIXTY POINT ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION CHEN
FUND. WITH EXPANDED WERE TO
THEIR RECENT TRENDS BY THE END
OF THE YEAR. THESE ARE SOME ON
THE WILL BE RIVER WITH REVISION
GIVEN OF THE A LOT AND MAINTAIN
ENJOY THE OVERALL IS VERY IT
RESPONSE TO. ADDITIONAL ITEM TO
BE TO LATER THE YEAR CHEN OUR
NEXT ARCHER OF RATES AND THE
YOU KNOW HOW. SYSTEM UNTIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AS WELL ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR. AND ARE GOING FOR
EMERGING FRIDAY REYES AND WE'RE-
THIS. ADDITION CREASE AND FOLDS
BY TWO. REFLECT ONGOING FOR
REGIONAL QUEER MUSIC FOR STATE
LAW I. T. JUST US. AS WELL AS
ON COSTS RELATED TO- AFTER YOU
FOR TRAINING ARTIST. AND THE
FULL EMPLOYMENT OF EVERYTHING
ENACTED DIVERSION PROGRAM- AT
THE TRANSFERRING THEY GIVE.
DIRECTOR MEN ALREADY- THE VERY
SORT OF OPTIMISTIC GROWTH
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS SPILLED INTO THEIR BUDGET
AND YOU GENDER ALSO INCLUDE
SOME ADDITIONAL. ABOUT THAT SO
I'M NOT GOING TO GO OVER ALL OF
THOSE EXCEPT THE ONE THING I
WOULD KNOW IS THE ASSUMPTION
ABOUT. HIS SLOW GROWTH AMONG
INFANTS AND TODDLERS AND EARLY
START PROGRAM. IS THAT 21% IS
ACTUALLY. HALF AT LEAST DOUBLE
THAT OF ANY YEAR IN THE PAST
TWO DECADES SO IT IS A VERY
OPTIMISTIC GROWTH ASSUMPTIONS.
OUR OFFICE IS POINT IS NOT
THAT- YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE
BETTER FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
INFANTS AND TODDLERS IF THEY
WERE ABLE TO COME INTO THE
SYSTEM AND RECEIVE THE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES THAT CAN
REALLY HELP WITH LATER LIFE
OUTCOMES AND IN FACT IF THEY
ARE IF THEY WERE TO RECEIVE
THESE SERVICES THAT CAN NOT
ONLY HELP- THEM ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS BUT ALSO. IT
FROM A PHYSICAL PERSPECTIVE IT
CAN MEAN THAT THEY REQUIRE
FEWER SERVICES OR OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LIFESPAN WHICH
ALSO TRANSLATES INTO LOWER COST
FOR THE STATE- POINT REALLY IS
THAT THESE ASSUMPTIONS IF THE
IF THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO-
TO GET MORE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS BACK INTO THE SYSTEM.
ARE NOT AS SUCCESSFUL AS THEY
HOPE IT COULD MEAN THAT COSTS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR- ARE
OVERSTATED AND WE TOOK A LOOK
AT HISTORICAL TRENDS IN
CASELOAD GROWTH AND CONSIDERED.
BOTH THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS THE OF THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF RE OPENING
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT COSTS IN
THE BUDGET COULD BE OVERSTATED
IN THE BDGET YEAR BY AS MUCH
AS TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND OR MORE. HOWEVER
WE DO NOT RECOMMEND A DOWNWARD
DOWNWARD REVISION AT THIS TIME
INSTEAD WE RECOMMEND WAITING
UNTIL THE MAY REVISION WHEN WE
HAVE- MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
ACTUAL CASELOAD ON A MONTH TO
MONTH BASIS AND WE KNOW MORE
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S OWN
ASSUMPTIONS. I'M AND WE WILL BE
HAPPY TO FURTHER ADVISED AT
THAT TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FINANCED
ANYTHING. HE CHAIR STEVEN PAUL
BERMAN FINANCE WE HAVE NOT
ADDITIONAL TO ADD. OKAY YOU
VERY MUCH- AND DIRECTOR CAN YOU
CAN YOU SPEAK TO YOUR
OPTIMISTIC GOOD NUMBERS. AND
THE ADDRESS LMAO. YES MADAM
CHAIR AND- WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS OPTIMISTIC BUT WHEN WE
ARE LOOKING AT RECOVERY- BY
HAVING A REGIONAL CENTERS AND
WE TALKED TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER DIRECTORS- BECAUSE WE
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD OF. DOING
THE ASSESSMENTS AND BRING IN
INDIVIDUALS ON- I'M IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND WANTED
TO SEE IF THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO- AND I HANDLE THAT WORKLOAD-
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF BRINGING KIDS ON
FOR SERVICES SKINNER THAN
LATER. ON AND IT REALLY HAS
BEEN MORE OF THIS ALL HANDS ON
DECK TO STATE THAT WE IT'S NOT
A MATTER OF CAN WE OR SHOULD WE
AS A MATTER WE NEED TO DO THIS-
SO THEY STARTED TO DO SOME OF
THE RECOVERY NOW- AND SO WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT BEING ABLE TO
BUILD. UP THE INTAKES AND
BRINGING KIDS ON. YOU MUST HAVE
A- COMMENT ABOUT WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE OF NAY
REVISED IS STILL HOW WE'RE
DOING IN OUR RECOVERY BE ABLE
TO HAVE. A BETTER- KIND OF
CLARITY AND TO BE- PROJECTIONS
OR BUDGET YEAR- THANK BECAUSE
IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT AREA WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE- TO
CLINICIANS TO DO THE
ASSESSMENTS THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR EARLY START- STAFF
BECAUSE IF WE WERE TO REDUCE
THAT- OPERATIONS DOLLARS TO
REGIONAL CENTRES MAY BE PUT IN
A PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE TO.
REDUCE THE STAFF THAT ARE
WORKING AN EARLY START AND THEN
SHOULD WE ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
BRING MY KIDS ON. THAN WHAT
THEY HAD THE EFFECTIVE
COORDINATION FOR SERVICES OR
WOULD WE THEN BE- REPLACING ONE
PROBLEM WITH ANOTHER- SO THAT'S
THAT WAS I'M TO THE POINT OF
HOW WE TOOK THIS APPROACH- IN
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET OKAY. CAN
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
SINCE I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE AND GETTING KIDS
AND IS SOONER IS BETTER AND
THAT THE DROP OFF HAS BEEN
BECAUSE KIDS ARE BORN. THE
DOCTOR BUT CAN YOU TALK ABOUT A
NINETY YOU SEE YOU WERE THERE
DOING A- PUTTING SOME STUFF ON
THE WEBSITE BUT HOW ARE WE GO.
OUT MORE. AND I. THESE KIDS
BECAUSE OUGHT WE KNOW IF THE
COST WILL GET LARGER IF THEY
YOU KNOW THEY DO GET INTO. SOON
ENOUGH IN THEN TRY TO. INTO AN
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THAT IS ALSO
RIGHT GOING THROUGH ITS OWN
STRUGGLES TRYING TO RE OPEN. SO
WHAT ARE WE DOING PROACTIVELY
TO MAKE SURE THE KIDS AND
FAMILIES ARE RECEIVING SERVICES
HAS BEEN A FOR EVERY CHILD AT
HOME NOT RECEIVING SERVICES.
THAT'S EXTRA STRESS ON A FAMILY
THAT IS ALSO TRYING TO COPE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- AND THAT'S WHERE THE
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING WITH
THE- ICC WHICH- IS- REALLY A
GROUP OF PROFESSIONALS AS THE
INTERAGENCY COORDINATING
COUNCIL- AND THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. THEIR PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE WITHIN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD.
DEVELOPMENT AND EARLY START
PROGRAMS- TO REALLY LOOKING
NICE THAT'S TO WHAT IT DOES
STRATEGIES- CHILD FIND HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE AREAS INTO HOW WE
COULD REALLY DO THAT OUT OF
REACH- AND AGAIN IT'S- KIND OF
A MULTI SYSTEM APPROACH-
THERE'S BEEN AND EVEN UNDER
THE- ICC THEY'VE BEEN
DISTRIBUTING COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND FIRES IN INFO
GRAPHICS WE HAVE A BROCHURE
THAT'S GONE OUT IT'S GOING OUT
MULTIPLE LANGUAGE. IS ALSO
ADMITTED THAT THAT PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IS
GOING TO BE RELEASED- THIS WEEK
IN ADDRESSING THAT- WE ALSO
HAD- THE ICC I BELIEVE AND I
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE CLARITY ON THAT- BUT THEY-
CAN'T. REALLY TOOK A LOOK AT A
PLAN TO DO PROACTIVE OUTREACH
BUT ALSO TO OUR REACH WITHIN
YOU KNOW HEALTH PLANS BUT THEN
ALSO LOOKING AT- WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE- KINDA EDUCATION AND-
OUTREACH TO PEDIATRICIANS- SO
WE HAD REACHED OUT TO THE
ASSOCIATION'S TO ALSO BE ABLE
TO RAISE AWARENESS WITHIN
PEDIATRICIANS. OF WE ALSO OOK
A LOOK AT HOW DO WE DO AVERAGE
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE- WE ARE
VERY VERY CONCERNED THAT THOSE
THAT COULD BE GREATEST IMPACTED
OUR OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHICH WILL GREATER. IMPACT A
DISPARITY- OF THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO CONTINUE TO- HAVE AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE AS PART IN
IN THIS AREA. SO IT MORE LIKE I
SAID WE HAVE THIS FOCUS GROUP
THAT HAS ALSO REVIEWING KIND OF
THE- KIDS THAT- WE NEED TO DO
SO OUR REGION PROACTIVE
APPROACH SO IT'S NOT. I OFTEN
SAY THAT IN MANY OF THESE
EFFORTS IT CAN'T JUST BE ONE
EVENTS WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT ARE THEY
EFFECTIVE AND IF THEY'RE NOT
EFFECTIVE. WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO TO
DOUBLE DOWN. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING OUTREACH. AND I'M
SURE I'M SURE BANKS AND DIAPER
ARE ON YOUR FULLER OF. THAT YOU
DO- AND THEN ALWAYS A THINK
JUST. LOOK AHEAD DO WE PLAN FOR
THIS LONG TERM AS I DIED THIS
THAT IS YOU KNOW THIS IS GOING
TO. POPULATION TO GROW HOW ARE
WE MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
REACHING THEM. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND MAINTAINING-
STRUCTURE IN SUPPORT. AS PEOPLE
MOVE ON TO THE MELINDA'S. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- EACH COACH
JOHN. WHAT I HAD EXPECTED NOT
AND YOU WONDER. SO THE REFERRAL
ARE BECOMING LEARN FROM DOT
VISITS. SO YOU SENATOR AND- AND
HOLIDAYS YOU PART OF AUDIO UP
AS THE I CAN IT IS REALLY LOOK
AT WHERE OUR REFERRALS COMING
FROM- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS IN WHICH OUR
REFERRALS DO COME FROM
OFTENTIMES- DON'T COME FROM THE
NECK YOU FROM THE HOSPITAL- WE
WILL GET THEM FROM POSITIONS-
WE ALSO GET. THAT FROM FIRST
FIVE WILL GET THEM FROM TWO ONE
ONE- THERE'S NEVER A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS- JOURNEYED FROM
UT BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WORK WITH OUR LIVE NEXT
COMMUNITY WITH OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AT. VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
THAT OUR REACH IS WHERE WE GET
THOSE REFERRALS. WE DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE CERTAIN-
POPULATIONS THAT WE HAVE- UNDER
REPRESENTED IN OUR EARLY START
PROGRAM- WE KNOW THAT ARE
NATIVE AMERICAN AND OUR ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ARE PARTICULARLY
UNDERREPRESENTED AN EARLY START
AND THOSE ARE SOME AREAS IN
WHICH- WE NEED TO- CONTINUE
THOUGH THAT THIS STRATEGY IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES HOW TO
BEST- DO THAT OUTRAGE TO. MAKE
SURE THEY WERE BRINGING THEM IN
SOONER THAN LATER BECAUSE IT IS
SO CRITICAL TO HAVE THAT EARLY.
INTERVENTION VERY EARLY ON.
RIGHT OKAY I'M IT SO. HAS BEEN
A SLOW. OF ROOF. OR TO SLOWING.
YOU KNOW INTENTION TO. ENTERING
THIS IS- BERMAN YEAH I THINK
YOU GREAT QUESTION- IT I'M
GOING TO IT MORE NOT JUST AS
EVERY AND WHEN IT IT IT
ACTUALLY WASN'T- BACK IN A- IF
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WE HAVE-
SEND AND GRAPHIC THAT WILL.
KIND OF OUR EARLIEST CASES- AND
COMING MARCH AND APRIL IT
LITERALLY TAKES A NOSE DIVE-
AND THAT'S WHERE WE CAN SAY
WITH PRETTY CERTAIN-
RELIABILITY THAT IS VERY MUCH
TIED TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IN A PANDEMIC- ANNUALLY
WELL WE'RE OUR GROWTH AN EARLY
START. HOW SLOWED DOWN SOME.
OVER HE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE- GROWTH
ANNUALLY AND OUR EARLY START
PROGRAM BUT AS- MISS PEDICAB
NOTED THAT- WE ARE DEFINITELY
SHOWING. OF MUCH GREATER
PERCENTAGE AS A RESULT OF
TRYING TO GET THIS RECOVERY-
BUT WE DO SEE ANNUALLY A GROWTH
ANYWAY- BUT LIKE I SAID BACK IN
MARCH AND APRIL WE HAD THIS
THIS CLASS OF- REALLY START
PARTICIPATION- THAT WAS
IMPACTED AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU. THIRTY I THANK THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
CERTAINLY IS A DEVELOPMENTAL
PEDIATRICIAN AND- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE MEDICAID SERVICES
REPORTED BETWEEN MARCH AND MAY-
THERE'S BEEN A FALL OFF OF
ALMOST 50% I THINK FORTY FIVE
FORTY EIGHT OR SOMETHING
PERCENT AND WELL CHILD VISITS
SO WE'RE TALKING ALMOST HALF
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHERE LAS
SCREENING HAPPENS- OREGON
REPORTED THAT THROUGH OCTOBER
THAT THERE IS A 28% DROP. AND
AGAIN- CATCHY YOUNG CHILDREN-
GETTING- THERE WELL CHILD
VISITS AS WELL- AT EIGHT EVERY
SHEET THAT I IT IS ONLY
UNDERSTAND THAT- AND- THAT- YOU
GET REFERRALS MANY DIFFERENT
PLACES BUT OFTENTIMES I THINK
THE- THAT'S HOW MUCH OF YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY IF A CERTAIN
PARENTS MAY BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS IF THERE-
PRETTY- I GUESS- MARK CAN TO
OTHER BY FOR MORE SUBTLE THINGS-
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO SCREW
TO THE SCREENING TOOLS WE USE
IN A PR OFFICE OR PERHAPS A
CHILD CARE SITE WE HAPPEN TO
KNOW ALSO HERE IN THIS. THAT
CHILD IS FALLING AS WELL SO THE
PROFESSION WHO ARE MORE FOCUSED
ON DEVELOPMENT- THE FAMILIES
AREN'T THE COUNTERING AS MUCH-
WHETHER BECAUSE THEY HAVE LESS
CHILD CARE NOTHING TARGET ARE
NOT SEEN PEDIATRICIANS AS WELL
AND- APPRECIATE THE OUTRAGE I
DON'T THINK THAT THE TEACHERS
IS DOING LESS SCREENING NOW IN
TERMS OF THE PATIENTS THEY
ACTUALLY DO YOU SEE SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THAT- AND
THIS IS IN SOME SENSES- BLAINE
IT'S NOT ON YOUR LAP AND LAYING
THIS ON BUT IS THERE A- WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION. I MEAN THIS
REALLY TO ME FOR EXAMPLE FIRST
OF ALL A WEEK ARE YOU GETTING
DATA FROM THAT CAL AS FAR AS
HOW MANY MEDICARE OLD KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING THEIR WELL
CHILD VISITS SO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW MANY ARE GOING
THROUGH SOME CITING DATA FROM
THE NATIONAL OR ANOTHER STATE
BUT WE HAVE THE TO HEAR IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S BEEN SHARED
WITH YOU IN TERMS OF- NUMBER
WELL CHILD VISITS START
HAPPENING- IT'S DURING THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THAT MAY AP
PART OF. GOING ON- AND- SO I
THINK THAT THE IMPORT SO THAT'S
THE MEDICAL FOLKS I. SO I DON'T
KNOW THE SHIRLEY LIKE THAT WITH
YOU- I. CERTAIN TWO A PIECE.
BUT YOU KNOW I THE AT THE TIME
ON HOW MUCH REACH IT. HEALTH
AWAY SPREAD WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S
TO SEE A- HOW MANY PEOPLE SEE
IT. I AS END I'M SURE YOU'RE
PAGES VERY POP. BUT I THINK-
YOU KNOW WITHIN A TO GAIN TO
GENERAL HOT. IT'S GONNA NEED A
LOT SPREAD BUT I GUESS THE
OTHER THING IS THAT. I DON'T
KNOW SAY THAT WE NEED PUBLIC
CAN. DURING PEOPLE TO BRING
THEIR KIDS TO THE DOCTOR OFFICE
BECAUSE WE SEEM TO FALL OFF NOT
ONLY OF COURSE. OF VISITS YOU
SEEN FALL OFF AND IN GREAT TEAM
IS. AND OF COURSE WHAT WE DON'T
TALK AS MUCH ABOUT IS THAT
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING. SO SO
I GUESS. THAT HAS. IS YOUR
DEPARTMENT GETTING DATA WHEN IT
COMES TO SOMETHING LIKE EARLY
START FROM OF LET'S SAY A MEDIC
CAL PROGRAM IS TO HOW MANY
VISITS- THEY'RE DOING COMPARED
TO PRE- COVE. YOU'LL COVER IN
TERMS OF HELPING YOU WITH YOUR
PROJECTIONS. AND ALSO IS THERE
A SENSE THERE AND THOUGHT ABOUT
DOING SOME SORT OF MORE PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GO SEE TO PEDIATRICIANS WHY
YOU'RE FROM PEDIATRICIANS IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE COMING IN.
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF
BECAUSE OF IT. AND EVEN THOUGH
MANY PEDIATRICIANS OFFICE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD- AND- AND ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE SAFE FROM
BECAUSE OF IT THEY HAVE
SEPARATE YOU KNOW WELLS VISITS
SEPARATE FROM. VISITS THE DAYS
EVEN VETS A LOT. AND SO FORTH
ALTHOUGH I SHOULD ALSO POINT TO
YOU HEIGHT OF THE- HELLO OF
PRACTICE IS ONE THING. FROM TO
BUT- BUT- SO IS AYE SIR SEE
THIS IS A CALL. THING THAT AND
I. I'M BRING IT UP TO YOU
YOU'RE AT THE END OF THE
REFERRAL. BUT IT REALLY IS
ABOUT SUPPORT PRIME CARE
PRACTICE. US AT THAT DON'T WORK
FINANCE TROUBLES. THE THAT THE
PANDEMIC. AND I KNOW WE'RE
DOING SO ASSIST AND OTHER OF
THINGS CALVING DATA HOW MUCH
DEVELOP. SCREENINGS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING. IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
NUMBER OF WELL CHILD VISITS
ITSELF FOR THE HAVING WOULD SAY
PUT. THE MEDICAL PROGRAM AT
LEAST WE SHOULD UPDATE ON THAT
FROM THE STATE. AND THEN. WE
USING THAT TO BE ABLE ALL TO BE
SURE. THAT REFERRALS ARE.
THROUGH TO- TO- EARLY START
WHICH I THINK THAT. SHINS LEAST.
NOT SAY THEY CAN DO A- JOB CREE
COVE IT BUT- I. THINK THEY-
STUFF- THEY STOP DOING THAT AS-
AS MUCH. THEY'RE JUST. THAT
JUST NOT TO THE KIDS AND FIRST
PLAY. BECAUSE PEOPLE SO CONCERN.
SO YOU SPEAK TO THAT WHETHER
THERE'S A MULTI AGENCY. EFFORT
TO LOOK AT THIS. YEAH THANK YOU
DOCTOR. AND ALWAYS A PRE. THAT
AS A PPO- I. IDEALLY LIKE I
MAIN OF OUR- WELL I WILL
PREFACE WAS SAYING. THAT IT
DOES IT NEVER FOR LIKE WE'RE-
ANOTHER- BECAUSE I HAVE A
PRETTY. CASH FOR STARTS- BUT I
TOTALLY AGREE. YOU KNOW IT IS
NOT ONCE. FITS ALL RIGHT NOW
AND HOW WE DO OUR OUT REACH FOR
EARLY START- TO THE COMMUNITY-
AND- SO WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING MULTIPLE
THINGS. AND WE DID WORK WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
ISSUED. A DIRECTIVE TO THEM
SAYING THAT THEY CAN'T DO
THEIR- IN TAKES REMOTE. AT
THEIR ASSESSMENTS CAN ALL BE
REMOTE YEAH WE DON'T NEED TO
HAVE IN PERSON SO WE CAN. MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NOT THAT
BERRIER- THEN ALSO WORKING WITH
OUR COMMUNITY SUCH AS THE ICC
AND OTHERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING AND DEVELOPING VERY
BROAD OUTREACH MATERIALS. TO
THE EARLY START. COMMUNITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
BROCHURES IN THOSE FLYERS THAT
WERE DOING THAT ARE IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES THAT ARE IN. PLAIN
LANGUAGE FOR FAMILIES TO GET
THEIR HANDS ON TO SAY HEY. YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS
THESE ARE THE THINGS TO. BE
AWARE OF YOU KNOW CONTACT YOUR
HEALTH PROVIDER. CONTACT YOUR
REGIONAL CENTER- WE ALL HAVE A-
OTHER ANALYSTS ARE WE'VE GOT. A
NUMBER DIFFERENT NEED PER. BUT
WE LIKE A SAID CAN TO. THOSE
ADDITIONAL. IN WHICH- WE CAN DO
MORE I HAVE TO. SIT TO KNOW THE
I AM- WE MAY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE JUST
ASKING ABOUT WITH. ON
HEALTHCARE SERVICES- ON MEDI
CAL IS TO GOES WELL BABY CHECKS
IF NOT- I THINK THAT'S- A
REALLY GOOD FOLLOW UP- PRESS
TWO AND LEAN INTO AND GET THAT
INFORMATION- AND THEN ALSO. USE
THAT TO HELP US FIGURE OUT SOME
NEXT STEPS AN ADDITIONAL
STRATEGIES- BECAUSE IT IT THIS
IS A- IN ISSUE THAT WERE
OWNING- AND THEN WE WANT TO USE
ALL OF OUR SYSTEM PARTNERS
WHETHER IT'S OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT. OR OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO. ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
IT'S JUST WAY TOO CRITICAL
MASS. YEAH I MEAN I THINK AGAIN
IT'S AND THAT IT THAT IT I
THANK YOU. CERTAINLY FROM
READING THE REPORTS- YOUR
AGENCIES DOING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS TO TRY JUSTICE
ISSUE I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THIS IS ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT ACROSS THE SILOS. I SHOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT MEDIC HOW THE
MEDI CAL PROGRAM THE ONLY OF
COURSE WE HAVE TO LEADERSHIP OF
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM ITSELF
THERE'S ALSO ADVISE YOU COULD
BE ON CHILDREN. YOU MIGHT ALSO
WANT TO HAVE TO ASK YOU KNOW
MAYBE YOU CAN URGE THEM TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW WE PULL ALL
THIS STUFF TOGETHER AND- AND
TRAFFIC BUT OTHER AGENCIES AS
WELL SOCIAL SERVICES ON THE
CHILD CARE SIDE RIGHT- IT
CETERA- SO WE CAN. THINK ABOUT
THIS AGAIN MULTI AGENCY
APPROACH TO TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS AND CERTAINLY AS YOU
POINTED OUT IS THAT. IF WE
DON'T CATCH THEM AN EARLY START.
FROM DOESN'T AWAY- WE CAN. THE
PAR THAT YOU QUE BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING SPECIAL A- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PLAY CATCH UP SO
DATA SO THOSE EXPENSES. GROW IF
WE DON'T GET THE KIDS IN NOW.
AND- EARLY START- AND- SO
HOPEFULLY AGAIN NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A FORCE- S-
AGENTS. PAINFUL THAN THIS BUT I
DO THIS JUST A MULTI. APPROACH
I ALSO JUST WANT TO QUICKLY
MENTION CERTAINLY AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
LAST YOU KNOW THAT THAT THAT
LACK OF REFERRALS A RELEASE
THAT THE DECREASE ENROLLMENT
OF- ASIAN- CHILDREN- I. GUESS
BIG QUESTION THERE IS THAT-
LANGUAGE ACCESSIBILITY IS
USUALLY ONE OF THE BIGGER
BARRIERS- SO IF THE SERVICES
ARE DEVELOPED IN LANGUAGE AND-
A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE DO YOU
KNOW THEY DO ENGLISH TO SPANISH
AND CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR LATINO COMMUNITY.
STANDS IS A LEVEL. THAT NOW
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT. MY AND
ELAINE AVAILABILITY SO- IF YOU
CAN JUST BRIEF- AND- AND- ON-
LANGUAGE ACTS. FOR PARTICULARLY-
ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER- A CLIENT.
YEAH THANK YOU DR PANDA AND
MUCH OF THAT OUTRAGE- IN EARLY
START STRAIGHT IS LOOKING KIND
OF LANGUAGE- WE HAD HEARD THAT
SOME OF THAT YOU. IS THE
DIFFERENT DIALECTS THAT- MADE
MADE FACE A BEING TO- REACH TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT CAN ASSIST
US IN THAT- SO THERE'S THIS IS
AN AREA THAT WE REALLY NEED TO-
DEVELOP ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES
THE OTHER IS THEN ALSO USING
THE TRUSTED COMMUNITIES TO DO
THE OUTRAGE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WE HAD HEARD- THAT THERE'S EVEN
SOME KIND OF CULTURAL- BARRIERS
AND- THAT WE NEED TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF AND BRING- THOSE
TRUSTED- INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN.
DO THAT OUR REACH TO HELP DOES
COME TO THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS A RESOURCE TO HELP
THEIR CHILD- AND SO WE DO NEED
TO NOT ONLY ADDRESS THE
LANGUAGE- KIND OF BARRIERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE CAPTURING
THE MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES AND DIALECTS- BUT
THEN ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE USING THOSE TRUSTED
RESOURCES AND COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE A SAFE SPACE FOR
THAT CONVERSATION AS WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT RECOGNITION-
THERE IS UNFORTUNATELY A HIGH
LEVEL STATEMENT TERMS OF
ACCESSING. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND I KNOW YOU
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES BUT
OFTENTIMES OVER FOR DICK CAL
COMMUNITY THAT THEY DON'T MISS
A DISTINGUISHED BETWEEN THE TWO
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY MAYBE
ALSO HAVE A STIGMA ATTACHED TO
THAT AS WELL FOR THE FAMILY.
AND MAY NOT SEEK THOSE SERVICES
THANK. YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. OKAY OF SO
MOVING ON. ISSUE NUMBER. TWO
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE BRIAN
MITCHELL DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I
WILL BE COVERING QUESTIONS TWO
THREE AND FOUR ON PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA. SPECIFICALLY WHAT
CHALLENGES THE DEPARTMENT HAS
FACED- HOW THE DEPARTMENT
ISSUED DIRECTIVES HAVE ASSISTED
WITH THE PANDEMIC THE
CHALLENGES THAT REMAIN AS WELL
AS SOME OF THE POLICY DECISIONS
GOING FORWARD AND AS WELL AS
THE- THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND HOW THAT HAS
BEEN USEFUL DURING THE
PANDEMIC. ALSO FIRST ELECTED TO
START OFF BY- JUST EXPRESSING
THAT-BEING PROACTIVE IN OUR
APPROACH WITH OUR COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS LISTENING VERY CLOSELY
TO OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF-
THE NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SEEN HAS BEEN REALLY CRITICAL
IN THE DEPARTMENT BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THOSE NEEDS- VERY
EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC WE
BEGAN TO COLLECT DATA ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COCAINE AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS WERE HOSPITALIZED.
AND FOLKS YOU UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY AND THROUGH THAT
COLLECTION AND WE HAD HELPED US
TO SEE WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE-
YES HAD MANY MANY STAY MEETINGS
WHEN WE HAVE TAKE INTO INPUT
FROM ARCHITECTURE EASE IN WITH
SERVER YEAH MEMBERS TO SERVE
PROVIDERS. AND REALLY THE CORE
AND OUR ISSUE HAS BEEN PEOPLE
SAFE AND PUTTING PARKS THE
WEEKEND AND- WHAT. IT IS
POSSIBLE TO STATE TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE PROTECTION. ARE IN
PLACE TO BRING TO THE- I'M FROM
THINGS THAT WE DONE HAVE BEEN
WITH IT MACINNES OF OUR TWO.
ALLOW TO CLICK. YOU SEE THE
INCIDENTS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND SO SAFETY
HAS ONLY BEEN ARE HARDCORE-
CERN AND REALLY GET SORT OF
WHITE HAS UNDERGIRDED
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT- WE ALSO
HAVE SEEN A CHALLENGE AND I
RESPONDED TO ACCESS TO SERVICE-
BUT IF INDIVIDUALS DECIDE AND-
LIKE THE BENCH FOR THEIR FAMILY
HOME AND ALSO INCREASE YOUR
DAIS THIS IS HOW WE RECOGNIZED
THAT IT WAS A TWELVE DIFFICULT
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS
SERVICES IN PERSON OF COURSE
AND SO WE NEED A FEW- ASSIST
WITH OUR SERVICE PROVISION IN
THE COMMUNITY. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO BE MORE
FLEXIBLE IN THE WAY THAT THIS
IS A PROVIDED AND- AND
DIRECTIVE HAD BEEN ISSUED BY
OUR FACTOR THAT HAVE ASSISTED
WITH WITH. THAT COMPLEX BILLY-
HAS BEEN A- ISSUE WITH AND ARE
SPACE THEM- AS YOU ACT IT WOULD
COVER THE FIRST ACT. STAFF WORK
WITH THE END OF THAT WE SERVE-
DIFFERENTLY. YOU COULD GOING
FAMILY. AND SO WE HAD TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY- WITH TRADITIONAL
CENTER COMBAT ARE SERVICE
WRITERS ON HE SHE'S AROUND
STAFFING. AND ALSO WITH REGARDS
TO OUR- DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE BEING.
VERY ATTENDED TO THEIR NEEDS
RESPONDING TO ISSUE SEPARATE
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT AND IN
DOING THAT WE- I WORK CLOSELY
WITH TO BE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO REACH OUT TO HIM TO SUBMIT
INFORMATION AND PPP. TO THE
DIVERSE. AND WE'VE ENSURED THAT
OUR DIRECTIVE OUR. ROOM THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE AND FINALLY. ALL
AVAILABLE ON OUR AND GAS- FOR.
BOB FRIEDMAN TALKED ABOUT
EXTENSION OF THE EARLY START
SERVICES BEYOND AGE THREE AS
ONE OF THE FLEXIBILITIES THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO GRANT ASSIST
WITH INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING
SERVICES ANOTHER FLEXIBILITY
THAT WE RECOGNIZED EARLY ON
THAT WAS NEEDED WAS A
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY SO FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE RECEIVING
LAUGHTER ACT SERVICES POST AGE
THIRTY. IF A REGIONAL CENTER
NEEDED TO DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
AND DUE TO THE PENDING THAT
THEY COULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ALL THE NECESSARY RECORDS WHAT
DO IN PERSON ASSESSMENTS THAT
THEY HAD A FAIRLY- IDEA THAT
THE PERSON WAS ELIGIBLE TO MAKE
MAKE THE PRESUMPTIVE OF
ELIGIBLE UNTIL THEY COULD MAKE
A FINAL DETERMINATION SO THAT
WAS ONE WAY THAT WE RESPONDED
BY ENSURING THAT PEOPLE.
RECEIVED- MY- WHEN REGARDS TO
SOME OF THE STATE BEING. AND
BECAME. I'M A RECOGNIZE THAT-
ARE SUPPORTERS SPACE PROVIDERS
YEAH- GETTING. AND PROVIDING
FOR OUR LISTENERS TO INDIVIDUAL
AND THAT REALLY TAKES A TOLL ON
THEM OVER TIME YOU KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING. LACK OF
SPACE. THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE A
ONE OR TWO PEOPLE DEAD TO
PERSON SO DEVELOP- I TO FOUR
HOUR SUPPORT THE SERVICES
QUARANTINE GREAT- SO THERE
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WE DONE
THROUGH. THE DIRECT INSTEAD
BEEN REACHED. AND THROUGH INTO
FROM ARCHIE- HAVE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL. WE ALSO IMPLEMENTED-
DIFFERS A PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES WE INITIATED THE USE
OF THREE DIFFERENT SERVICES
INDEPENDENT THINKING SKILLS.
SUPPORTED HIM THANK THAT AND-
PERSONAL ASSISTANT SELF THOSE
THREE SERVICES IN A PANDEMIC
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE TO
PARTICIPATE DIRECTOR SERVICE.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY IS AT DIFFERENT
REGIONAL CENTERS WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING ADJUSTMENT
CORRECTIVE SERVICES DIFFERENTLY
AND SO G. D. S. RESPONDED TO
THAT ISSUE. I ELEPHANT IN
HOLDING STATEWIDE TRAINING BOTH
FOR REGIONAL CENTER STAFF BUT
ALSO FOR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
HELP THEM KNOW ABOUT
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES
AND WE HELP THOSE. CAN BOTH
ENGLISH AND IN SPANISH. THOSE
ARE ON SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
ARE- HAS SHE RESPONDED TO THE
CHALLENGE. OF COURSE SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT REMAIN IS
THAT WE NEED TO BE VIGILANT ACT
AND DEFENSIVE FORCE CONTINUES A
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO BE AT RISK
OF SUFFERING YOU TO BE CAPTAIN
OF THE SENATE CHARGE FORTY. IN
TO THIS- THE IF THERE POINT OR
TAX AND- MAKING SURE THAT-
VACCINATION ARE AVAILABLE TO BE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO NEED ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
AND REGISTRY FOR APPOINTMENTS
OR GETTING TO A SITE FOR
VACCINATION. I MEAN ISSUED A
DIRECTIVE ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH-
REGIONAL CENTERS TO CONTACT ALL
INDIVIDUAL SIXTY FIVE OR OVER.
THEIR VACCINATION STATUS AND
ALSO GIVEN GUIDANCE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCED THAT-
REGARDING VACCINATIONS AVAIL
ABLE AS OF MARCH FIFTY. SO
THOSE THE VACCINATION IS
DEFINITELY A WE HAVE A WAY TO
TRACK- CONSUMER VACCINATIONS. A
WE WERE LOOKING AT THAT DATA
FREQUENTLY AND WHAT WE CAN TO
ASSIST REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
WORKING WITH THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I'M ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS HAS TO DO WITH-
PUBLICITA STATIONS GOING
FORWARD APPLE AND- LISTEN TO
OUR COMMUNITY THURMOND REALLY
THREE AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE
EXPRESSED AND- ASSISTANCE LONG
TERM DEBT HAS BEEN HELPFUL
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FIRST IS
THE A LONG TERM EXTENSION OF
THE PARTISAN DIRECTED SERVICES
THAT I SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER. I'M
IN SO I'M WE HAVE OUR DRAFTING
REGULATIONS AND THOSE WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN THE SPRING TO
INCLUDE PART SB SERVICES
ONGOING- WITH POSSIBLE- HEARD.
ABOUT THE- HOW REMOTE SERVICE
IS A VERY HELPFUL HE ENGAGED IN
THAT PEOPLE GET. IN THE HOME
THE FIRST FOURTEEN- IF THERE
ARE WAYS WE CAN EXPAND OUR MAKE
PERMANENT JUST BECAUSE OUR
FEDERAL LABOR. LET BE FOR ABOUT
THE EXTENSION OF THE EARLY
START SERVICES AND HOW THAT HAS
BEEN REALLY HELPFUL IN
SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S UNCLEAR
IF A PERSON. IS ELIGIBLE THAT-
THEY NEED TO CONTINUE T
RESEARCH THE EARLY START
SERVICES. ARE AND TELL- THEY
RECEIVE SCHOOL SERVICES OF THE
PRASADA GAP WILL SERVICE. AND
LASTLY I WILL COVER THE
ORGANIZATION THE- TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WE WILL.
REORGANISE OF OUR DEPARTMENT.
AND I WILL SAY THAT IF IT
HADN'T BEEN FOR THE
ORGANIZATION WE COULD NOT HAVE
THE AND- AS RESPONSIBLE. AND
CERTAINLY NOT AS QUICKLY
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY DURING THIS TIME-
THIS INTO PARTICULAR AREAS OF
OUR DEPARTMENT WE OFFER
SECURITY OPERATIONS WHERE WE
HAVE SEVENTY LIAISON TEAMS. S.
B. OF THE- STAFF EACH TEAM
COVER THREE REGIONAL CENTERS
EACH AND THESE LIAISON TEENS
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL AND I'M
TAKING CALLS FROM THE UNITY. OF
THE NETWORK TO EXPLAIN
DIRECTIVES TO FAMILIES TO HELP
RESOLVE HI. FAMILY AND CONSUMER
ISSUES AND JUST REALLY PROVIDED
A LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BOTH TO REGIONAL CENTERS AS
WELL AS TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
WE NOTE THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
HUNDRED AND 24% INCREASE IN
CONTACT FROM THE TO THE V.
202-019-2020 AS A SUPPORTER OF
THE STAFF THAT WE HAD
AVAILABLE- WE TRACK ALL THE
CALLS AND EMAILS CORRESPONDENCE
WE RECEIVED. AN INFORMATION HAS
BEEN VERY USEFUL IN THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION OR
GUIDANCE AS WELL AS FAQS THAT
WE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE BASED
ON THE POLICIES. ISSUED
RECENTLY. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ENGAGE MORE FREE WITH SO. AND
ITS ON ALL THE CHEATING WHO GET
HERE FOR AND ISSUES THAT ARE.
HAPPY WITH SUCH THEY'RE ALL WE.
THE OTHER WITH A PART WHERE WE
WENT THROUGH WE WERE. YES YOU
OFFICE OF WHITE SERVICES AND
OFFICE BEEN A REALLY CRITICAL-
I MENTIONED EARLIER THE THAT
COLLECT REGIONAL CENTERS ON
INDIVIDUAL FOR TEST OTHER. AND
ARE STAFF HAVE BEEN TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH OFTENTIMES LARGE
CONCRETE SETTINGS WHERE
INFECTIONS HAVE BROKEN OUT AND
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
DAVID. PROVIDED A LOT OF
TRAINING AND PREVENTION FOR THE
SPREAD OF THE NINETEEN SO- IN
CLOSING THESE TWO AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT- HAVE ABSOLUTELY
ASSISTED US IN THE RESPONSIVE
TO THE PANDEMIC. AND TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IN A VERY
POSITIVE. WAY THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU VERY. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. EVEN POPCORN FINANCE.
HELLO. THANK YOU THIS IS SONYA
PATRICK AGAIN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WE JUST HAD A COUPLE OF
POINTS TO MAKE ABOUT THE DDS
DIRECTIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED DURING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC- YOU KNOW WE WOULDN'T
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN TRYING TO
REALLY BALANCE- SIMULTANEOUS
PRESSURES THERE'S THE- OF
PRESSURE TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO STAY HEALTHY SAFE. ENGAGED
AND AVOID CRISES- AND THE
SIMULTANEOUS PRESSURE OF TRYING
TO SUSTAIN THE NETWORK OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND THEIR
STAFF SOME OF WHOM MAY FEEL-
YOU HAVE BURNED OUT OR OVER
WORKED AS MR. WINFIELD ALLUDED
TO AND- SOME OF WHOM MAY FEEL
THEY NEED MORE WORK ACTUALLY AT
THIS TIME- THE DIRECTIVES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ISSUED HAVE
REALLY HELPED- SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND REGIONAL CENTERS
RESPOND IN A FLEXIBLE WAY TO
THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES-
BUT IT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN WITH
OUT. OF CHALLENGES- WE HAVE
HEARD FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE
DIRECTED AT SOME OF THE
DIRECTIVES MAY NOT BE.
IMPLEMENTED IN AN ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WAY ACROSS THE
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS-
FOR A COUPLE OF THEM THAT THERE
MIGHT BE SORT OF A LACK OF
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT THE
DIRECTIVE IS TRYING TO DO- OR
HOW TO HOW TO REALLY IMPLEMENT
THAT DIRECTIVE. AND THEN- THE
POINT I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON AT
THE MOMENT IS THAT THE DURATION
OF THE FLEXIBILITIES- MOST OF
THEM BEING IN PLACE FOR THIRTY
DAYS AT A TIME. HAS WE'VE HEARD
THAT THIS IS CREATED- A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY DURING WHAT IS
ALREADY AN UNCERTAIN TIME- AND
THIS IS COUPLED WITH ALSO
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT A POSSIBLE
SUSPENSION OF- SUPPLEMENTAL
PROVIDER RATES WHICH WILL
REALLY WE WILL ADDRESS IN THE
NEXT ISSUE- AT THE HEARING
TODAY. AND THE GENERAL LACK OF
INFORMATION ABOUT READ REFORM
GOING FORWARD. SO WHAT ONE
THING THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST IS
THAT IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER WHICH DIRECTIVES AND
FLEXIBILITIES- MIGHT BE
EXTENDED AT LEAST THROUGH THE
END OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AYE MR WINFIELD-
NOTED THAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS ALREADY CONSIDERING SORT OF
A LONG TERM- USE OF SOME OF
THESE DIRECTIVES BUT- I'M SORT
OF GETTING AWAY FROM THAT
THIRTY DAY AT A TIME- A RENEWAL
MAY BE HELPFUL TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDER. COMMUNITY AND WE ALSO
JUST SUGGESTED THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S EVEN APPLICATION OF
THESE DIRECTIVES ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WE MOVE
ON TO. MISTER ROGAN ANY
RESPONSE THAT MR WINFIELD. YES
THE DEPARTMENT IS AWARE THAT-
THE THIRTY DAY EXTENSION SOME
HAVE BEEN- DIFFICULT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY- WITH THE EXECUTIVE
THE DIRECTORS THAT ARE ISSUED
OUT OF THE DIRECTOR THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. WE ARE LIMITED
TO THIRTY DAYS AND SO WE TRIED
TO- GET THOSE EXTENSIONS OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE HISTORY AT
30 DEGREES JUST POSSIBLE AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO REFINE THAT
PROCESS- THE DIRECTORS THAT ARE
ISSUED UNDER OUR DIRECTOR'S
AUTHORITY. FROM THE CHIEF
INSTRUCTIONS CODE FOR CONSUMER
RIGHTS AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
THOSE DO NOT HAVE A THIRTY DAY.
EXPIRATION AND SO THOSE ARE ARE
MORE LONG TERM- AND IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. DEL VALLE- WE
CAN THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT WE'VE PROVIDE TO THE
COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TRIED TO- JUST HELP PEOPLE TO.
UNDERSTAND THAT- AS LONG AS IT
HAD TO MAKE IS WITH US THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO REASSESS AND
GAUGE IN REVERSE TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY TO ASSIST IN THE
VISION OF SERVICE. SO WE HAVE
CERTAINLY HEARD THAT COMES. AND
THE AND WE'VE HEARD BEFORE BUT
THE ISSUE OF- DIFFERENCES
ACROSS THE REGIONAL CENTERS CAN
YOU SPEAK TO YOUR ABILITY YOUR-
I GUESS YOUR ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO.
YES ONE ZERO AGE SO WE'RE NOT
ALL JUST BUNDLING IN
BUREAUCRACIES. I APOLOGIZE YES-
AND SO AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE
HAD THAT STATEWIDE TRAININGS ON
ARTISTS AND DIRECTED SERVICES-
AND- ISSUING I THINK RECALLING
ASK QUESTIONS AND WHEN THERE
ARE PARTICULAR ISSUES THAT- WE
ARE MADE AWARE OF WE COME REACH
OUT TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
REGIONAL CENTER- BUT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT. OUR SYSTEM IS
UNIQUE AND THAT- IN THE- I MEAN
FLEXIBILITY IS ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL IS VERY HELPFUL FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS BUT IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
WE SERVE AND FAMILIES SO- WE
ARE ASSESSING THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STATEWIDE TRAINING.
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE- IN
ADDITION- WE ARE DEVELOPING.
INFORMATIONAL PACKET- THAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO. ALL
INDIVIDUALS FOR GENERALLY
STARTING LANOLIN ACTS SERVICES-
SO EVERYONE WILL HAVE THE SAME
INFORMATION WHEN THE INTO THE
REGION CENTER SYSTEM SO ARE
SOME WAYS THAT WE ARE WORKING
TO. SUPPORT THESE ACTIONS. OKAY
IT THANK YOU FOR. I'M SORRY FOR
THIS THE SECOND WHO SAID WHO'S
TALKED. POSTING THINGS ON YOUR
WEBSITE. HOW MUCH TRAFFIC DO
YOU GET ON YOUR WEBSITE.
ACTUALLY WE GET A LOT OF. IN
PART I'M VERY EXTENSIBLE AND
HAVE TRANSLATED ITEMS INTO MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE EVEN AUDIO IN
ASL- AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE IN
FAMILIES SO WE FREQUENTLY HERE-
FROM FOLKS THAT ARE WEBSITE HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY HELPFUL IN
THE STATE ON THE AT THE
INFORMATION USEFUL. OKAY BEFORE
YOU MOVE ON TO MICHY TRUE
THOUGH I WOULD LIKE TO INSURE
THAT WE HEAR FROM ATHLETES ARE
BEING ON QUESTION NUMBER ONE
THE CHIANG MAI DID NOT COVER.
SHE TO. OKAY. APOLOGIES THAT WE
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTIONS A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF ORDER IN THE AGENDA
TODAY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FEATURE FRANCO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SHEETS FOR DATA
ANALYTICS AND STRATEGY THERE-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS
DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA DOES
INCLUDE TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND TWENTY ONE POSITIONS
DEDICATED TO EMERGENCY PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY- WE PROPOSE THAT THESE
RESOURCES BEING DEDICATED OF
COURSE DIRECTLY TO- SERVING
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL. AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
IT USED TO COME. THE STATE
EMERGENCY. CAPACITY OVERALL- WE
ARE COORDINATING WITH- REGIONAL
CENTERS ABOUT HOW BEST TO
UTILIZE THESE RESOURCES WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MEANS AND
PRACTICES ACROSS THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY VERY- JUST AS
DISASTERS- THEMSELVES VERY FROM
WILDFIRES AND FLOOD THREATS AND
POWER SHUT OFFS. AND OTHER
THINGS LIKE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- WE- WE KNOW AND I
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS THE NEEDS OF
OUR POPULATION ARE OFTEN VERY
UNIQUE FROM THAT OF OTHER
POPULATIONS. AND WE SEE A BIG
NEED TO REFRESH PRIOR EFFORTS
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND AWARE TO SHELTER AND
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO HELP SHELTER
AND FEED- TO DO THAT NECESSARY
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. A
COMMUNICATION MEMBERS TALKED A
LOT ALREADY ABOUT THE EFFORTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND REGIONAL
CENTERS TO DO IT IN AND
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE MANNERS WELL I AM
STILL MAINTAIN THAT CONNECTION
IN THE OVERALL STATE EMERGENCY
FRAMEWORK- WE KNOW THAT EACH
REGIONAL CENTER HAS A DIFFERENT
CAPACITY- AND A DIFFERENT SE
OFEXPERIENCES ALREADY HAND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO FACTORED THOSE
THAT ADDITIONAL BENEFIT INTO
OUR PLANNING AS WELL. WELL WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
TASKS- THAT WE WOULD PROPOSE
FOR THESE RESOURCES WELL WE
KNOW THAT NO ONE PERSON CAN DO
IT ALL AND BE THE MAGICIAN ARE
UNNECESSARY. AND SOME MUTUAL
AID AND SUPPORT IS ALSO A
FEATURE OF OUR PLANNING AND
CONVERSATION. THE ADVANCE
PLANNING THAT WE CAN DO TO
ADVANCE EDUCATION OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVING A PRE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS ALSO
THAT WE'RE NOT MAKING COLD
CALLS IN THE HEAT OF A MOMENT
DEVELOPING TRAINING AND
EXPERTISE THOSE AS A BASELINE
SPECIALIZATION. HAVING A
DEDICATED FROM POINT PERSON WHO
DOESN'T HAVE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE'VE LEARNED- IN
UTILIZATION. OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. SYNALLOY ANOTHER. AND%
THAT IS REALLY THE KEY TO ROUTE
RID THE REST OF OUR- AND
PROTECTING SINCE. ALSO I HAVE
THIS SHORT OVERVIEW AND IT TO
WHAT'S THE BOTTOM OF PAGE OF
YOUR AGENDA TODAY. A LITTLE
INSIGHT INTO THE COLLABORATIVE
WORK WE'RE DOING THIS REGIONAL
CENTERS WILL OF COURSE BE
INVOLVING OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
BEYOND THEM. POSE APPROVED WE
THINK THERE'S A LOT. OF THOUGHT
AND EXPERIENCE THAT CAN BE
APPLIED TO HOW THESE RESOURCES
ARE CAN BE IMPLEMENTED AND
UTILIZED. AND TO HELP US OF
THOSE PLANS FOR- PREPARE
PEOPLE. RESPOND AND RECOVER
FROM THESE EMERGENCY OF ABSENT
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY JUST
TO DESCRIBE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL THE PROPOSAL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
MR GABRIEL BROGAN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NORTH ABOUT NORTH
BAY REGIONAL CENTER. HERE FROM
HIS PERSPECTIVE HOW THINGS ARE
GOING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. NAME IS GABRIEL
ROGAN AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
NORTH BAY REGIONAL CENTER WHICH
SERVES NAPA SOLANO AND SONOMA
COUNTIES. MINISTERED BY TALKING
ABOUT HOW OUR REGIONAL CENTER
HAS ADAPTED TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN AS WELL AS OTHER
EMERGENCIES. SUCH AS THE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES THAT HAVE
IMPACTED OUR REGION AS WELL AS
THE NUMEROUS PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. IT'S REALLY
BEEN A COMMUNITY WIDE EFFORT
BUT I'M GONNA TALK TODAY ABOUT
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC THINGS ARE
REGIONAL CENTER HAS DONE. FIRST
IT STARTS WITH INCREASED
OUTREACH TO OUR COMMUNITY.
WE'VE INCREASED OUR REACH
REALLY AT ALL LEVELS THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE FAMILIES AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS. IN ORDER TO INSURE
PEOPLE SAFETY MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE TIMELY INFORMATION. AND
AUTHORIZED NECESSARY SERVICES.
WE'VE DISTRIBUTED PP THROUGHOUT
THE CRISIS AT ALL LEVELS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THE DEVELOP MULTIPLE
SURGE HOUSING LOCATIONS FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TESTED POSITIVE
OR WHO HAVE BEEN POTENTIALLY
EXPOSED. WE'VE DEVELOPED A
RAPID RESPONSE PROCESS WHEN
VIRUS OUTBREAKS OCCUR IN OUR
VENDOR LOCATIONS. WE'VE
INVESTED IN IT INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
ARE ABLE TO CONDUCT THEIR
VISITS AND MONITORING
ACTIVITIES REMOTELY AND WE'VE
ESTABLISHED TECHNOLOGY LENDING
LIBRARY FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
WE'RE ACTIVELY COORDINATING
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND PARTNERING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO KOBE TESTING ACROSS
OUR THREE COUNTIES AND ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS ACCESS
TO VACCINATIONS GOING FORWARD.
THE CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS- BUT I WOULD POINT TO
ONE IN PARTICULAR AND THAT IS
THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
STAFFING DISRUPTIONS WHEN
COLGATE OUTBREAKS OCCUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WE'VE BEEN VERY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S
DIRECTIVES TO AUTHORIZE
OVERTIME AND ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
STAFFING AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
ANY STAFFING GAPS OR SHORTAGES.
GENERALLY SPEAKING IN MY
OPINION THE DIRECTIVES ISSUED
BY THE DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL. FOR EXAMPLE
ALLOWING SERVICE COORDINATION
ACTIVITIES TO HAPPEN REMOTELY.
ALLOWING SERVICES TO BE
ROVIDED IN REMOTE LOCATIONS
ARE ALTERNATE LOCATIONS WAIVING
FEES THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
BURDENSOME FOR FAMILIES AND
AUTHORIZING REGIONAL CENTER
DIRECTORS TO ADJUST RATES IN
HEALTH AND SAFETY SITUATIONS.
IN MY OPINION THE DEPARTMENT'S
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY THROUGHOUT THIS
CRISIS. THEY'VE BEEN
TRANSPARENT THEY'VE BEEN
RESPONSIVE- THEY'VE BEEN
COLLABORATIVE I AM IN FAVOUR
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE EMERGENCY.
COORDINATION POSITIONS AT EACH
REGIONAL CENTER I THINK THAT
WILL BE CRITICAL TO OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE EFFORTS
GOING FORWARD. I WOULD JUST ASK
THAT THE SALARIES FOR THOSE
POSITIONS BE COMMENSURATE WITH
THE LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY
NECESSARY FOR THOSE POSITIONS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. IN SUMMARY I
WANT TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BUDGET LETTER SUBMITTED BY
PARKER. AND SPECIFICALLY
ADVOCATE FOR DECREASES SERVICE
COORDINATOR CASELOADS AT
REGIONAL CENTERS THOSE
POSITIONS ARE CRITICAL ALWAYS
BUT ESPECIALLY NOW AS WE WORK
TO ASSIST FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE
THE MANY CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN OUR SYSTEM. AND AS
WE STRIVE TO INCREASE EQUITY
FOR UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS OF
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND ADVOCATE FOR
INCREASED WAGES FOR THOSE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY
TO SUPPORT OUR POPULATION
THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS. AND
THEY ARE TRULY HEROES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M SUPPOSING HOW LONG
WOULD YOU. THANK JUST THE%
EMERGENCY DECLARATION TO GO
FORWARD WITH BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE REMOTELY WHICH ONES DO
YOU THINK SHOULD LAST FOR
LONGER THAN THE PANDEMIC. I
THINK REGIONAL CENTER SHOULD BE
PROVIDED THE FLEXIBILITY GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH
EMPLOYEES INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
AND THE CONSENSUS IS IT REALLY
DEPENDS. THERE ARE SOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHO
REALLY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
REMOTE SERVICE DELIVERY AND
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO STRONGLY
WOULD PREFER THAT DELIVERY
HAPPENS IN PERSON SO I WOULD
ARGUE FOR FLEXIBILITY AND
REALLY CUSTOMIZING OUR APPROACH
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES THAT
WE SERVE. THANK YOU UP. MISTER
MARK MELANSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORK. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHAEL
INSTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK WE ARE STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED PROVIDER
MEMBERS LARGE AND SMALL ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING SUPPORTED LIVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING RESPITE
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE IN PLANNING
SERVICES. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND ESPECIALLY
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS FROM OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY TO KEEP PEOPLE
HEALTHY AND SAFE THROUGHOUT
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS I
MUST BEGIN BY ACKNOWLEDGING AND
APPRECIATING THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
NANCY PARCHMENTS EFFORTS. AND
THE COLLABORATION THAT SEES THE
ALLEN HAS HAD AND CONTINUES TO
HAVE WITH THEM YOU CAN IN SUCH
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING TIMES
AS WE ALL JUGGLE COMPETING
PRIORITIES AS MR WINFIELD
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED EZLN
ALWAYS APPRECIATES FROM WE HAVE
TIME WITH YOU ALL. I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO DESCRIBE THE
CHALLENGES THAT PROVIDERS OF IN
PERSON SERVICES HAVE
EXPERIENCED DURING THE DAM
ENDEMIC AND WHAT CHALLENGES
REMAIN CERTAINLY ALL OF OUR
LIVES HAVE DRASTICALLY CHANGED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC CCL AND HELD A
LEGISLATIVE BRIEFING IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TITLES IN PERSON SERVICES AND
IT CAN DOWN. INTO OUR RECORDING
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE AT
C. C. ON DOCK WORK THAT PROGRAM
DETAILS HOW THE EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORTS OF IN PERSON SERVICES
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS SAFE THROUGHOUT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WE
WILL HEAR ALL ABOUT HOW IN
PERSON SERVICES ROSE TO MEET A
PANDEMIC. MOMENT IN A COVERT
NINETEEN MINUTES. THE URGENT
NEED MEDIA PER. OF MAINTAINING
HEALTHY SAFETY STAFF THE PEOPLE
SERVICE BEGAN ON DAY ONE. IN
PERSON PROVIDERS HAS BECOME
INFECTION CONTROL EXPERTS. IN
SECURE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
IN AN ABUNDANCE OF CLEANING AND
SANITATION SUPPLIES. ALL WHILE
PROVIDING INCREASED STAFFING
CLIENT TRAINING. ALL OF THIS
WAS AT A TREMENDOUS COST TO THE
PROVIDERS IN THE NETWORK. FIRST
QUESTION WAS WHEN STAFF SHOW UP
FOR WORK. UNFORTUNATELY THEY
DID. WE IMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO
TRAIN ON HOW TO LOOK FOR SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF COPD NINETEEN
AND DEVELOP DETAILED RESPONSE
PLANS. AS LOCKDOWNS WERE IN
IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE STATE
PROVIDERS FOR MANAGING AND
BALANCING DEMANDS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF FAMILY VISITS
IN THE CLIENT'S DESIRE TO
CONTINUE WITH THEIR CHOSEN WAY
OF LIFE. WE WERE ALREADY FACING
A WORK FORCE CRISES. AND
PROVIDERS INCREASE THEIR
EFFORTS TO FIND WAYS TO ATTRACT
RECRUIT RETRAIN RETAIN AND
TRAIN NEW EMPLOYEES AND OUR NEW
CORPORATE NINETEEN WORLDS. THAT
INCLUDED MANAGING THE ALREADY
COMPLEX RELATIONSHIP WITH IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES AND
SCHEDULING AND RESCHEDULING
ADEQUATE STAFFING COVERAGE
BASED ON STAFF'S EXPOSURE. TEST
POSITIVE FOR DOPING NINETEEN
AND THE NEED FOR STAFF TO
QUARANTINE. THE WORKFORCE
CRISIS WHICH HAS BEEN A CRISIS
BEFORE DURING AND IS STILL TRUE
TODAY CONTINUES TO BE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE FOR PROVIDERS
OF IN PERSON SERVICES. WHAT ARE
THE SOME OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS
PROVIDERS HAVE HAD TO ADAPT AND
CHANGE THEIR OPERATIONS DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THREE THE SHRINKING OF SUPPORT
TEAMS WAS ESSENTIAL TO LIMIT
EXPOSURE TO PROVIDE NINETEEN
WEST STAFF IN AND OUT OF THE
HOMES HE WAS LAST RESPECTS
MOTION EVERYONE. COVERAGE FOR
THE NATIONAL DAYTIME HOURS
DURING THE DAY SERVICE WELL
WISHERS. IN MANY CASES THE DAY
SERVICES AND EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES SO
THAT CLIENTS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
PAID INTERNSHIPS AND EMPLOYMENT
WHEN DAY SERVICE PROVIDERS WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE AND DISCONTINUE
SERVICES. INCREASING THE HOURS
FOR RESPITE AND PERSONAL
ASSISTANTS TO PROVIDE THE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT AND RELIEF TO
KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER AND SAFE.
COORDINATING MULTIPLE HEALTH
AND SAFETY WAIVER REQUESTS FOR
MULTIPLE CLIENTS MULTIPLE
REGIONAL CENTERS. FOR
INCREASING THE HOURS OF SUPPORT
AND FOR COVERING THE COST OF
THE DRAMATICALLY INCREASING
OVER TIME. PLANTS WITH NEW SICK
LEAVE MANDATES AND ARRANGING
AND REARRANGING COVERAGE NEEDS
ACCORDINGLY. AND PREPARING FOR
THE MOUNTING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AS A RESULT OF ISOLATION
LOSS OF ROUTINES AND
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS TO THE
BLOCK DOWNS IN THE SHELTERS IN
PLACE. NOW WE'RE FOCUSED ON
VACCINE. ARE THERE STATE
SPECIFIC DIRECTIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY BENEFICIAL TO
PROVIDERS. YES EXTREMELY
HELPFUL WHILE CRITICAL AND WELL
INTENDED INTERPRETATION'S
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF THE GPS
DIRECTIVES DOES VARY WILDLY
THROUGHOUT THE TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE AS MRS HANNEKE MENTIONS.
AS A STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE A VAST
DIFFERENCES FROM- ARE OVER ONE
HUNDRED PROVIDER MEMBERS
BUNDLING BARACK BUREAUCRACIES
WAS A FAIR STATEMENT NOT AND
SHARE. THE DIRECTORS MUST BE
MORE SPECIFIC INTEREST
PERSPECTIVE NOT JUST ISSUED AS
GUIDANCE THEY MUST PROVIDE FOR
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXCEPTIONS AND
SHOULD NOT BE USED TO DENY
ACCESS. TO SERVICE OUR FUNDING
FOR PROVIDERS. THE VIRTUAL
SUPPORT DIRECTED. FOR IOS THAT
ALLOWED FOR REMOTE SUPPORT HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE IN FACT
EXPECTED. ALTHOUGH IT MUST NOT
BE EXCLUSIVE ENFORCING SUPPORTS
THE DIRECTIVES HAS COMPLIMENTED
AND INCREASE THE QUALITY OF THE
SERVICE AND IMPROVE THE OUTCOME
FOR THE PEOPLE SERVED
ESPECIALLY HEALTH AND SAFETY
OUTCOMES. THIS WOULD BE A
DIRECTOR THAT ALLOWED FOR
HYBRID IN FOR A HYBRID OF IN
PERSON AND VIRTUAL SUPPORTS
THAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CONTINUE POST PANDEMIC. THE
ISOLATION RATE DIRECTIVES FOR
SLS WAS RELEASED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FINALLY
ALLOWED FOR A COMPETITIVE WAGE
FOR A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS. WHILE THE
DIRECTOR OF PREVENTION OR
EARLIER OR AT LEAST BEEN
WRECKED MAKE RETROACTIVE BACK
TO MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TO MAKE
PROVIDERS HOLE AS THEY CREATE
COURAGEOUSLY COMBAT THE
CHALLENGES THEY FAE BY THE
PANDEMIC. OUR PROVIDER OF NEW
AREN'T OUR PROVIDER NETWORK IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE DIRECTOR.
DIRECTIVE EXPANDING THE ACCESS
TO THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM OFFERED MORE OPTIONS
FOR PEOPLE CERTAIN FAMILIES.
AND ALTHOUGH NOT A DIRECT IF
THE VACCINE THAT IS PROVIDED
FOR STAFF AND FAMILIES ISSUED
BY DPS WILL GREATLY APPLY.
APPLAUDED BY OUR NETWORK AND
PEOPLE SERVED. IN CLOSING THE
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED FOR A FOCUS ON THE
FUTURE. THE NEED FOR OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY TO COME TOGETHER FOR
COORDINATED EMERGENCY RESPONSE
EFFORTS AND ANY TYPE OF CRISIS
SERVICE FASTER. I DO WANT TO
TAKE JUST A BRIEF MOMENT TO
HUNDRED DREXEL PROFESSIONAL
PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH. NOT
DIRECTLY DUE TO TRANSMITTING
CODED NINETEEN BUT OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION TO REDUCE
EXPOSURE TO OPEN NINETEEN.
MATTHEW MATTY. JOHN STANTON
DEDICATED TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
HIS CAREER TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AMONG US WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
RECIPIENTS. OF THE FIRST ROUND
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORKS DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL YEAR RECOGNITION
AWARD. BECAUSE OF MADDIE YES
PLEASE JUST LIKE NINETY THAT
YOU SEE ON THE CONTINUED FIGHT
FOR RATIONALIZING THE WORK
FORCE IN DEMANDING COMPETITIVE
WAGES. PROVIDERS MUST HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY STAFF EDITOR
WAGE. IT'S OUR WORKFORCE THAT
CONNECTS THE PEOPLE SERVED WITH
THE ACCESS POINTS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THEIR CHOSEN WAY OF
LIFE. WE ARE NOTHING WITHOUT
THEM. WE MUST PAY THEM
ACCORDINGLY AND ELIMINATE THE
SUNSET SUSPENSION LANGUAGE THAT
YOU CAN POINT TO SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASES TO STABILIZING
FOR PROVIDERS. IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES. AND FINALLY AS
ALWAYS INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IDENTIFYING
THE QUALITY MEASURABLE OUTCOMES
THE PEOPLE SERVED TO ACHIEVE
THEIR CHOSEN WAY OF LIFE. CCL
AND SPONSORED BILL AB EIGHT ONE
THREE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MALEMA MOVE US
IN THAT NECESSARY DIRECTION
TOWARDS THOSE QUALITY
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES. THE
CEILING LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATORS
IN THE DEPARTMENT AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND BEYOND.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
WEDNESDAY'S. PANEL HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MUCH AND YOU. FOR VERY VIVIDLY.
WITH YOUR PICKS PAINTED WORDS
BRINGING- BRINGING THE
PROVIDERS INTO THE ROOM WITH US
WE APPRECIATE IT AND- YOU CAN
ONLY IMAGINE THE DIFFICULTIES
OF TRYING TO. MAINTAIN SERVICES
TO A VULNERABLE POPULATION.
DURING A PANDEMIC AND WE THANK
YOU AND MISTER ROGAN FOUR YEAR-
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS BUT BUT
THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE DOING
THE WORK. RIGHT ON THE GROUND.
WE THANK YOU- BELIAU ANY ANY
FURTHER. QUESTIONS REMARKS
AFTER THESE PRESENTATIONS
DEPARTMENT. HERE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT- I THINK WE CERTAINLY
HAVE OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US
TONIGHT- I WOULD ALSO JUST LIKE
TO REITERATE I THINK THINK THE
DIFFERENT THE- THE IMPORTANCE
OF. A PLANNING- FOR THE NEXT
DECADE WE'VE I THINK WE'VE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGED THE SETBACKS THAT
WE'VE HAD. DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND I THINK WE WERE SLOW ON
PLANNING FOR THIS POPULATION
PRIOR TO THAT THE PANDEMIC AND
NOW COMING OUT I THINK WE'VE
WE'VE ALL SEEN HOW. THE SHAKY
GROUND THAT WE STAND ON AND THE
NEED ESPECIALLY. IN DEALING
WITH PEOPLE WITH WITH ID AND
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE FOR
CREATING A FIRM FOUNDATION SO
PEOPLE CAN BEGIN TO PLAN. AND
FEEL COMFORTABLE ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING. DR PAN. THANK YOU
AND- APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS- YES- WE A COUPLE
COUPLE THINGS FIRST OF ALL- I A
DO YOU KNOW WHAT. WHAT A FOLLOW
UP ON THE L. A. AS- FINE-
REPORT AROUND THE US. I GUESS
THE LACK OF CERTAINTY FOR DS
PROVIDERS AND- APPRECIATE THAT
THE APARTMENTS. TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT BUT IT DID GETS
REALLY HARD TO PLAN IF YOU KNOW
YOUR FLEXIBILITY IT'S THE ONLY.
TO TOLD FOR THIRTY DAYS MAYBE
CELLS IT WILL PROBABLY LONGER
THAN THAT IT'S ADDRESS SO I'D
BE GREAT TO HAVE SOME- SOME
BETTER FEEDBACK ON. BOTH THE
IDEA OF WHAT CATHOLICS BELIEVE
CAN BE COMMITTED TO THROUGHOUT
UNTIL THE END OF C. TO
MERCHANTS AND ALSO WHICH ONES
THAT SEEM LIKE IT. WILL YOU
KNOW THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
BEYOND RIGHT THAT MAKES SENSE
THAT THIS IS THE WAY WE SHOULD
PERHAPS- THIS WE CAN NORMALLY
DO BUSINESS THAT THIS. X.
EASIER ON FAMILIES THAT ALLOWS
US TO BE MORE EFFICIENT SO
FORTH SO- I HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET A- REPORT BACK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- BUT I NEED. YOU
KNOW PLEASE BEFORE MAY REVISE
ON ON ON THOSE PARTICULAR
POINTS- THE OTHER THE OTHER
ISSUE AND I KNOW THAT- OUR
CHAIR AND ASKED ABOUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE VISITED- DDS WEBSITE. I
WOULD MAKE A NOTE THAT THAT
QUESTION WASN'T ACTUALLY
ANSWERED- YOU YOU. THAT THE
ANSWER WAS THAT WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEBSITE THAT HAS A
LOT OF WONDERFUL RESOURCE ISN'T
AS ACCESSIBLE AND SO FORTH.
FREESHEET THAT. BUT THE
QUESTION ACTUALLY WAS HOW MANY
PEOPLE VISIT THE WEBSITE. AND
THE REASON I'M SORT OF GOING
BACK TO THAT IS THAT I'M SURE
DEPARTMENT ALSO USES OTHER
MECHANISMS BUT SOMETIMES- IN
TERMS OF HOW WE COMMUNICATE-
YOU KNOW POSTING THINGS ON A
WEBSITE CERTAINLY IS IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE AS A REFERENCE BUT-
OFTENTIMES DOES NOT REFLECT THE
WAY FOR PEOPLE TO FIND OUT NOT
SURE DEPARTMENT ALSO HAS OTHER
MECHANISMS WHERE MORE
PROACTIVELY GETS INFORMATION
OUT TO PEOPLE- BUT- AGAIN IF.
YOU'RE HAVING A SITUATION
WHERE- YOU KNOW YES. BUT ARE.
THE FIRST SHORTAGE OF TIME
THERE'S UNCERTAINTY OF FUNDING
AND SO FORTH. HAVING A MORE- IF
PROACTIVE ENGAGED- FORMA TV
CATIONS IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- INSTEAD OF A
MORE PASSIVE WAY WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE TO FIND THE INFORMATION
INSTEAD OF INFORMATION BEING
PUT IN FRONT OF THEM. THAT'S
RELEVANT TO THEM SO- SO TO GET
A WOULD APPRECIATE THAT-
DEPARTMENT PERHAPS FOLLOWING UP
WE DON'T NEED THE ANSWER RIGHT
NOW BUT- ON HOW IT'S GOING
ABOUT DOING IT AND I'M SURE I
KNOW THAT YOU DO MORE THAN JUST
PUT THINGS ON THE WEBSITE BUT-
WE WANT WE WANNA BE SURE THAT-
THE VARIOUS PROVIDERS AND
CLIENTS ARE ARE. ARE ABLE TO
EASE MORE EASILY GET
INFORMATION THAT WAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS ANIMAL
IT IS. I DON'T SEE YOUR HAND UP.
SO I'M GOING TO. THEN TAKE A
SOUND ISSUE NUMBER THREE
EXTENSION OF FUNDING A PROPOSED.
FINJAN OF FUNDING PROPOSED FOR
SUSPENSION. SURE STEVEN PAUL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES IF I
COULD JUST- QUICKLY- TOUCH AN
ISSUE TO- ON THE DIRECTIVES YOU
KNOW I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT HONESTLY DIRECTORS HAVE
PROVIDED DDS WITH LOOKS ABILITY
TO RESPOND TO THE PANDEMIC.
NUMBER ALLOWED US TO QUICKLY
RESPOND TO US AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY AND- NO
WE'RE STILL LEARNING WHAT WORKS
WHAT DOESN'T AND SO I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THEIR THERE IS
SOME CONCERN WITH THE
POTENTIALLY CODIFYING THESE
DIRECTIVES- THE FEMALE LIMITED
DEPARTMENTS. FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND A IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
ASSESS THE DIRECTIVES AND-
WORKS. FOR TO THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS MATTER-
WITH THE WITH THE GARCIA ISSUE-
NUMBER THREE- SO FINANCE WAS
ASKED TO. PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE SUSPENSION PROPOSALS.
AND THEN SECONDLY WHETHER THE
SUSPENSION FRAMEWORK IS
INTENDED TO BE ON GOING- AS
NOTED AND THEN GENDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES- ONE
YEAR EXTENSION OF THE
SUPPLEMENT OWN PROVIDER RATE
INCREASE. AND THAT'S A TOTAL OF
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION- TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE. POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND. ALSO EXTENSION OF UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE SUSPENSION.
THAT'S A TOTAL OF FIFTY FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION. THIRTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND- SO GIVEN THE FORECAST OF
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IN THE
MULTI YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES THIS QUESTION TO GO
INTO EFFECT ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY TWO. OZ
PENSION WOULD BE LIFTED IF THE
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINES
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
BUDGET ACT PROCESS. THAT
THERE'S SUFFICIENT GENERAL FUND
REVENUE SUPPORT ALSO BEEN A
PROGRAMS AND SUBSEQUENT TO
FISCAL YEARS. IDC'S REFLECT
SIMILAR COACH DOC BY THE
MINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE EMPIRE BUDGETS- TO
THE SECOND QUESTION- I WOULD
SAY YOU KNOW ANY FUTURE CHANGES
TO SUSPENSION FRAMEWORK- WOULD
BE EVALUATED REEVALUATED
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
BUDGET PROCESS. AND WE ARE
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS IS A
DIFFICULT ISSUE AND WE WELCOME-
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- AND NOW WITHOUT
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS INTEGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DDS ARE
YOU PRESENTING ON THIS AS WELL.
YES HI MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND STAFF THIS IS JIM MIKE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES- BEEN ASKED IN A
GENDER TO DISCUSS THE PLAN TO
ADDRESS CHALLENGES FACING THE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICE THE SYSTEM.
THIS IMPORTANT QUESTION AS WE
LOOK TO IDENTIFY WHAT'S NEEDED
FOR A SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM THAT
FOCUSES ON THE NEEDS AND
PREFERENCES OF THOSE TO RECEIVE
SERVICES. I THINK IT'S HELPFUL
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE AND HOW WE'VE
ADDRESSED PREVIOUS CHALLENGES
AS WE'RE GOING TO BUILD ON THAT
THOSE EXPERIENCES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. OVER THE YEARS WHAT'S
NOW THAT DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
TASK FORCE HAS BEEN A VALUABLE
RESOURCE TO HELP INFORM
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES INCLUDING.
EXPANDING SERVICE OPTIONS FOR
FORMER RESIDENTS OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
SUBSEQUENTLY. CONTINUING TO
FOCUS ON THE WILL ON WAYS TO
STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE
BEGAN THE PROCESS OF EXPANDING
AND DIVERSIFYING THE TASK FORCE
AND SERVE TO NOW CURRENTLY WE
HAVE MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
THE TASK FORCE IN THIS WORK
GROUPS. AND SOME OF THOSE
GROUPS INCLUDE- THOSE THAT
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY RESOURCE
SAYS AND SYSTEM AND FISCAL
REFORM. OBVIOUSLY THE PANDEMIC
HAS BROUGHT SOME CHALLENGES
THAT THAT WEREN'T ORIGINALLY
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED BY THE
TASK FORCE. BUT WHEN WE BEGAN
BUT WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THE GUIDANCE OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY SOME
OPTIONS. TO ADDRESS THE
CHANGING NEEDS. AND ONE OF
THOSE APPS OPTIONS THAT WAS-
REFERENCED EARLIER WAS
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALTERNATIVE
SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL. AND
THIS ALLOWS FOR SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY AND NOT ONLY LIVERY
BUT TO RECEIVE SERVICE SAYS
THAT ARE ADAPTABLE TO
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. AND WE
COLLECTIVELY LEARNED DURING
THIS TIME THAT SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITIES AND CHANGES THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY
ARE WORTHY OF CONSIDERATION FOR
CONTINUED LONG TERM. AS MR
WINFIELD MENTIONED EARLIER
WE'RE WORKING ON- SHE
REGULATIONS TO MAKE PERMANENT
THE EXPANSION OF SOME OF THE
SERVICES. THAT CAN BE ACCESSED
THROUGH PURCHASE SPEND
DIRECTION AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT OPTIONS. FOR THE
REMOTE DELIVERY OF SOME
SERVICES. NOW AS NOTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THAT THE
TASK FORCE. TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SHORT AND
LONG TERM SERVICE OPTIONS. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES INTENDED AS JUST ONE
STEP THAT'S GOING TO HELP
INFORM SOME LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS. AND THOSE SOLUTIONS
ARE GONNA FOCUS ON INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE. COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND ALSO THEN
WE HAVE TO EXPLORE PAYMENT
STRUCTURES THAT ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT DOES ANOTHER PRIORITY
AS WELL AS COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL FUNDING RULES SUCH AS
THE HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SETTINGS ROLE. A
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS WITH THAT
PARTICULAR- THE HOME THE
CENTRAL IS CONTINUED OUTREACH
AND TRAINING. REGARDING PERSON
CENTER PLANNING AND PRACTICES
BECAUSE THAT FORMS THE BASIS
FOR MILLION DOLLARS FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BUILD
ON WHAT WE'VE LEARNED PRIOR TO
AND DURING THE PANDEMIC. TELL
CONFORM THOSE LONG TERM SERVICE
AND SUPPORT OPTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M IS
FINISHED PRODUCT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SENATE HEADED FOR
THE L. A. O. WE HAVE JUST WE
HAVE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PROPOSED SUSPENSION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATES
FIRST WE WOULD NOT THAT THE
SUSPENSIONS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE ACROSS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS NOT JUST DDS BUT MEDI
CAL IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
CHILD WELFARE IT CETERA. THESE
REALLY ARE CORPS ONGOING-
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND THE
POSSIBLE PROPOSED AS MENTIONS
REALLY TREAT THEM AS TEMPORARY.
THIS CREATES A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND IN PARTICULAR
IN THE GDS SYSTEM IT MAKES IT
HARD FOR PROVIDERS TO BUDGET
AND PLAN INCLUDING- HIRING AND
RETAINING STAFF. THE L. A-
RECOMMENDS REJECTING THE
PROPOSED NEW SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE ACROSS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS- GIVEN
THE STATE'S A MULTI YEAR
DEFICITS- PERPER PROJECTED
DEFICITS RATHER THE STATE WILL
LIKELY NEED TO MAKE CHANGES TO
ITS BUDGET WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. AS IT STANDS THE STATE
COULD PROBABLY NOT AFFORD THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AVOID THE
SUSPENSIONS AND FUND ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA OF THE GENERAL FUND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH REJECTING
THE PROPOSED NEW SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE FOR THE TWO DDS ITEMS
ARE ESTIMATED AT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE MILLION. IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
REJECT THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE
ACROSS ALL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS WOULD ADD
COST RELATIVE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MULTI YEAR
OUTLOOK. OF ONE POINT THREE
BILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ONE POINT NINE
BILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. HOWEVER BY ACCEPTING AND
TREATING- THESE COSTS AS
ONGOING. THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE ABLE TO MAKE COMPENSATING
COMPENSATING BUDGET CHOICES
WITH THE BENEFIT OF FULL
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THESE
ONGOING PROGRAMS COST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NIGHT I
THINK. FROM THE HEARING WE HAD
LAST WEEK ALSO AND WE TALKED
ABOUT- SUSPENSION AND THEN TO
THIS WEEK. IN THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD ABOUT A LACK OF
CERTAINTY AND THE INABILITY TO
PLAN AND THE NEED TO RAISE
RATES SO WE CAN HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS TO DO THE VERY
IMPORTANT WORK I THINK THAT WE
ALL AGREE WOULD NEED TO BE NONE
THAT A BUDGET MUST BE MADE
WITH- SOME LEVEL OF CERTAINTY
AN- EXISTING IN REALITY. SO I
THINK UP SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THOSE TWO THINGS
DON'T ALWAYS THEY'RE NOT LINED
UP IN SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT WE SEE AND I WOULDA I
THINK I WOULD SPEAK FOR- ACROSS
THE AISLE WHEN WE SAY. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A BUDGET THAT
PEOPLE CAN COUNT ON THE
CERTAINTY THAT IS BASED IN
REALITY OF WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA CUT AND NOT CUT DOWN AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE- SO I WOULD I WOULD
SAY I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU AND
LOOK FORWARD TO REVISITING HOW
WE DO THIS. A DIFFERENT. I
THANK YOU AND I THINK I'VE
RAISED THIS ISSUE MULTIPLE
TIMES BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
THIS IS PRIMARILY TOLD THE USE
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AND STALE POINT OUT SO- AND BY
THE WAY THIS IS NOT A GOOD TOOL
SO I'M NOT SUGGESTING WE USE
IT. ANYWHERE ELSE- BUT WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE BUILT IN
CUTS. THAT WE WILL EACH YEAR
DECIDE WHETHER WE WILL NOT
EXECUTE. FOR JUST HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SIGNIFICANT CUTS.
AND SO WE TALK A BUDGETS IS
BEING PRIORITIES- WE DON'T DO
THAT FOR OTHER PARTS OF THE
BUDGET. WE JUST WE MAINLY DO
THIS AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND I THINK IT
FORTUNATELY IT SENDS I THINK.
TO BE A WRONG MESSAGE ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE VALUE- SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHEN WE DO THIS
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK SORT OF HAPPENED AFTER
THE LAST GREAT RECESSION AND
THOSE KIND OF A TOOL TO ITS ERA
BUT AND IT DOES DISTORT THE WAY
WE LOOK AT OUT YEARS TO AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WE TRY TO DO YOU
KNOW WE OUGHT WE TO DO A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING WE'VE PUT
IN MANY MEASURES ACTUALLY- TO
ENSURE THAT- WE HAVE- FUNDS TO.
TO HELP US THROUGH THE BAD
TIMES- IN FACT ACTUALLY MADE
THE ACTIONS WE JUST TOOK TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES AND TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS AND SO FORTH.
OR BECAUSE OF A PRUDENT
BUDGETING. THAT WE'VE DONE- BUT
BY BUILDING IN THE SUSPENSIONS
AND THEN. SORT OF. PROJECTING
THAT WE WERE A QUOTE ACTUALLY
GONNA MAKE THESE CUTS- OUT INTO
IT OUT YEARS NO MATTER WHAT THE
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES ARE. AND
THEN SAYING THAT WILL EACH YEAR
WILL REEVALUATE YES OF COURSE
WE VALUE IN EVERY PART OF THE
BUDGET EACH YEAR BUT THE BILL
THEN AUTOMATIC CUTS. INTO THE
AND THEN COOKED SUSPEND THEM
ONE YEAR AT A TIME I THINK IS-
IN INTO POTENTIALLY JUST LIKE
YOU DON'T HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGAIN I DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD DO IT ACROSS THE
BUDGET THAT'S NOT ONE
SUGGESTING BY ANY MEANS. I
THINK IS AN APPROPRIATE AND- WE
REALLY SHOULD HAVE. A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS TO ME
VERY BAD HABIT WE'VE GONE INTO
AS A STATE IN TERMS OF OUR
BUDGETING PRACTICES WE'VE
DEVELOPED A LIFE BREAK A LOT OF
VERY GOOD HABITS IN MY TIME THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE ALSO DAHLE
SOME BAD HABITS AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THE WORST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS MELINDA'S. COMMENTS I
DON'T SEE YOUR HAND. NOT SURE
YOU'RE STILL WITH US. OKAY I'M
HERE NO COMMENTS FROM ME THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY- NOW
WE HAVE- JORDAN LINDSEY-EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR. DR PAN SENATOR MELENDEZ
MY NAME IS JORDAN LINDSAY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE R.
CAN UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION WE
REPRESENT FAMILIES OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOP DISABILITIES AND R.
TWENTY TO R. CHAPTERS ELEVEN
YOU SEE P. AFFILIATES ACROSS
THE STATE- MANY OF MY COMMENTS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED BY
YOU DR PAN AND OTHERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE INCREDIBLY
THANKFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS TAKING A STAND AGAINST THE
SUSPENSION OF THESE TRUCKS AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. I
LIKE TO DISCUSS THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR SYSTEM OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH IDG DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND BEYOND- FIRST
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES RETAINER
PAYMENTS DURING THE- PANDEMIC
ND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION FOR INCREASED
UTILIZATION FOR IN PERSON
SERVICES AND THAT SERVICE TO
STABILIZE SERVICE DELIVERY SO
THAT WE COLLECTIVELY CAN MOVE
OUR FOCUS AWAY FROM RETAINING
OUR STAFF AND INSTEAD FOCUS ON
ON MOBILIZING A RESPONSE. AND
ALLOW US TO DO THAT AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. ALSO I WANT
TO MENTION THAT. THIS RESPONSE
THAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC FROM PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS IT HAPPENED BY A
SYSTEM THAT IS ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS UNDER FONG. AND
I JUST WANTTO SAY IMAGINE THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WE COULD HAVE
RIGHT NOW IF WE HADN'T BEEN
HOLDING NON BIASED IN THREAD
FOR THE LAST TWO DECADES. THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMMUNITY
FOUGHT HARD TO REDUCE THIS
UNDERFUNDING FROM ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION TO ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION AND THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
WAS ESPECIALLY INSTRUMENTAL IN
SECURING THOSE NEEDED
INVESTMENTS. AND WE WERE
COMPACT RIVER WE WERE PREPARED
TO MAKE MORE PROGRESS THIS YEAR
TO IMPLEMENT. THE RATE STUDY.
BUT I IMPLORE THE COMMITTEE IN
THE MINISTRATION TO CONSIDER
THIS PANDEMIC AS ONLY A PAUSE
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RATE STUDY. OTHERWISE THIS
WOULD BE YET ANOTHER
CONFIRMATION ANOTHER STUDY THAT
CONFIRMS YES CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERFUNDING INDIVIDUALS ID DE
THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR SUPPORT
STAFF. BUT WE ARE GOING TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT. I WANT TO
DISCUSS QUICKLY BY UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THE BACKGROUND
IN YOUR AGENDA IS FANTASTIC-
THIS WASA CUT FROM- THE
RECESSION ERA TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT NINE. AND UNIFIED HOLIDAY
SCHEDULES A BIT OF A MISNOMER
IN THIS PARTICULAR CUT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED THE LAST FEW YEARS IN
THIS COMMITTEE QUITE A BIT ON A
MORE APPROPRIATE NAMES FURLOUGH
DAYS FORCED FOR LOADED. IN SO
THREE THINGS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY GREGIS ABOUT
FORCED FURLOUGH DAYS RIGHT NOW
ALL OR THESE ONE AFTER ORDER
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
PERFORMED FOR ROAD CLEAN WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT ALREADY.
DANIEL ARE WE GOING TO TURN
AROUND AND SAY THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR KAROQ EFFORTS TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE AND NOW WE'RE GOING.
TO FOR LOW YOU FOR DAYS WITHOUT
PAY. CHIU THIS IS THE OPPOSITE
OF PERSON CENTERED SERVICES THE
ASSUMPTION THAT EVERY REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENT CAN BE WITH OUT
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. FOR
THE SAME FOURTEEN DAYS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION FAMILY SITUATION
LIVING SITUATION AND NOW
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ONLINE
CONNECTIVITY SITUATION. THAT IS
THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF THE
DIRECTION OF OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM
THAT THE DIRECTION OUR ENTIRE
SYSTEM WANTS TO MOVE IN. AND
THEN FINALLY ABOUT UNIFORM
QUALITY SCHEDULE OR MORE
CORPORATE NAMES FORCE FURLOUGH
DAYS. COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC WE SHOULD BE MAKING
EVERY EFFORT POSSIBLE TO BRING
NORMALCY BACK ESPECIALLY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS NORMALCY
TO SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR
PEOPLE DISABILITIES. WE SHOULD
NOT BE TAKING AWAY DAYS OF
SERVICE AT THIS TIME. THE
SUSPENSION PROPOSAL FOR THE
RATES INCREASE AND YOUR FROM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET. SAYS TO US A COMMUNITY
YES WE CONFIRM THAT YOU ARE
HUGELY UNDERFUNDED YES WE KNOW
THAT OUR COMMUNITY YOUR
COMMUNITY HAS STRUGGLED
ENORMOUSLY THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. BUT NEXT YEAR WE'RE
LIKELY TO TAKE AWAY MORE MONEY
AWAY FROM YOU BY ENACTING THE
SUSPENSION OF ANY PROGRESS YOU
MAKE. I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
IN THE AGENDA FROM THE L. A. L.
ABOUT THIS- WE APPRECIATE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
CENTER PRO TEN ATKINS- SENATOR
SKINNER. THE COMMENTS MANAGER
YOU JUST MADE A DOCTOR IN THE
COMMENTS YOU'VE JUST MADE-
ESPECIALLY THE COMMENTS ABOUT
HOW THIS IS ONLY FOR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES- THESE.
SUSPENSION CUTS ARE ONLY IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECTOR- YOU HAVE ALL PUSHED
BACK ON THIS STATUTE. AND YOU
HAVE EMPHASIZED THAT THE LANE
AND CUT IN SERVICES ONE YEAR
ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH. A SUSPENSION
OF ONLY SERVES TO CREATE MORE
UNCERTAINTY AND MORE ANXIETY IN
A TIME. WHEN CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEIR FAMILIES AND
OUR SUPPORT STAFF DESPERATELY
NEEDS STABILITY. THAT CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ALL THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK WE SEE YOU WE
HEAR YOU- AND IT'S NOT MAY YET
WE'LL BE COMING BACK AGAIN OKAY
ANYMORE. THE DOCTRINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- I DID
WANT TO TOUCH PERHAPS A LITTLE
BIT OF HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE-
AND BEFORE I GO THERE ME ONE
LAST COMMENT ON THE SUSPENSION-
CAN YOU IMAGINE. S. CONTRACTING
WITH A COMPANY TO HELP IMPROVE
ONE OF OUR ROADS AND
TRANSPORTATION AND TELL THEM OH
BY THE WAY WE'RE GONNA PAY THIS
MUCH FOR EXAMPLE TO HAVE BUT
THAT'S A 10% YOU KNOW OUR 15%
STANCHION AND SO NEXT YEAR. WE
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY WILL PAY THE FULL AMOUNT
BUT WE DON'T WE MIGHT GIVE YOU
10% CUT. AND THAT'S THE
CONTRACT YOU HAVE. I DON'T KNOW
IF ANYBODY WOULD ACTUALLY TAKE
THAT CONTRACT. BUT YET WE
EXPECT OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS TO ACCEPT
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT THEY
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE CLIENTS
THAT THEY ACTUALLY WILL. BUT
THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS- I WOULD ALSO JUST
MAKE NOTE THAT- THAT ON THE
RATE STUDY I A MEMBERS CHAIR OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. WE'RE TOLD-
THAT WE NEED TO WAIT FOR THE
RIGHT STUDY WE NEED TO WAIT FOR
THE WAIT STUDY THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT STUDY AND WE FOUND OUT
HOW MUCH WE'RE UNDERFUNDING.
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT- AS IS MENTIONED THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
WHAT HAS BEEN FOUND IN THE RATE
STUDY THAT TRY TO ADDRESS THE
GAPS IN FACT PRIOR TO THE- TO
COVE IT WE EVEN HAD A HEARING.
TO GO OVER THAT RATE STUDY AND-
AND TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE FOUND AND WHAT
STUDY AFTER ALL WE ONLY WAITED
HOW MANY YEARS TO ACTUALLY GET
STUDY AND ACTUALLY PUT. THE AND
IT SAID LATE WE'RE YOU KNOW
TREMENDOUSLY UNDER FUNDING. AND
THEN- THE NOT TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT SO- APPRECIATE THAT WITH
CODED THAT- IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING BUT WE DO NEED TO
BE SURE WE KEEP ON TRACK- ON
DATA AND THEN ALSO IF NECESSARY
UPDATE ANY INFORMATION WE HAVE
ON THE RATE STUDY THAT'S NOT
THAT OLD YET. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE TRY TO-
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP- AND ASK
FOR PROGRESS ON TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. SOMETHING APPROPRIATE-
PAYMENT IS WE'VE- AS WE TRIED
TO DO WITH THROUGH THAT RIGHT
STUDY SO- AND I ALSO- SO ONE
EXPRESS MY- OPPOSITION TO THE
FORCED FURLOUGHS- WHICH WAY I'M
GLAD TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
SUSPENDING FOR THIS YEAR BUT I
THINK WE SHOULD JUST END IT ALL
TOGETHER- THAT THAT THAT'S
ENOUGH AND IF WE DECIDE THAT
SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO THAT
AND- LET'S. CONSCIOUSLY MAKE
THAT DECISION BUT LET'S NOT PUT
ON AUTO PILOT THAT THAT
SOMETHING DOES HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY GOING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM'S
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. WE HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN ERIN
CARRUTHERS. I BELIEVE. MISTER
FILL YOU BACK WITH US. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN'T. THANK YOU I'LL BE
PROVIDING A RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS ON EIGHT FIFTEEN OF
THE AGENDA REGARDING SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. AS OF
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH THERE WERE
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY NINE
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS WHO
HAVE TRANSITIONED INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. A
REGIONAL CENTERS TO REPORT TO
THE DEPARTMENT MONTHLY ON
MILESTONES AT THE BEACH BY THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING INTO THE PROGRAM
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO
TRANSITION. IN WHILE THE DATA
SHOW ENOUGH TREND IN THE NUMBER
OF SELECT PURCHASE THAT HAVE A-
TO A PROGRAM- I COMPARISON IF
YOU LOOK AT THE BEGINNING OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE'RE JUST
OVER A HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS.
WHO HAD- STARTED THEIR SERVICES
THROUGH SELF SELF DETERMINATION
ALSO WE HAVE SEEN OR ARE YOU
INCREASE OVER THE PAST YEAR-
IT'S HARD TO TELL WHAT COMPANY
WHAT IS THAT CODE HAS HAD ON.
TRANSITION INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM WE HAVE
HEARD ANECDOTALLY THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY SAID IT AFFORDS
INDIVIDUALS- HAS- HASTENED
THEIR- TRANSITION INTO THE
PROGRAM. WE ALSO HAVE HER BACK-
THE DEPARTMENT'S DIRECTIVE
WE'VE ENOUGH FINANCIAL SERVICES
FEES FROM THE- BUDGET HAS ALSO
BEEN HELPFUL TO PARTICIPANTS
WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM FOLKS
SAYING FACTORED INTO PANDEMIC.
I'M GIVING YOU ALL OF THE
FAMILY JUST WASN'T READY TO
TRANSITION DURING THIS TIME.
AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO. MONITOR
AND WORK CLOSELY WITH THEM. TO
US AND SIGN- SO THOUGH- IT
HASN'T OVER THE TWELVE MONTHS
OR A LOT OF IMPROVE AND WE CAN.
AS A STATE AGENCY AND OUR-
AUGUST THE STATE WHY TO.
ADVISORY COMMITTEES. FOR SOME
OF WHICH HAVE UNTIL- WE ALSO.
HAVE FRIDAY AND CONSULTANT MORE
FOR FAMILIAR WITH THE PROGRAM
IT'S BEEN A SAYS THAT'S- AND WE
ALSO RECEIVING TECHNICAL. FROM
NATIONALS OF STATE OF DECEMBER
SERVICES TO. AND OF ITSELF. ON
A WASTE YOU SOME OF THE YEARS
THAT CAN A WHOLE AROUND LAST.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THIS S WHAT
EVENTUALLY- SO THAT YOU CAN GET
FROM THE PLAN THAT'S REFERENCED
IN THE- BUDGET WITH STEPS
INSTEAD TO THE GOALS OF SUBJECT.
PROGRAM AND WITH EVERYONE
INVOLVED AND WE INTEND TO
DEVELOP AND THAT SUPPORTS WATER
ACTIVE CREATION. OF THE SELF
DETERMINATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS CARRUTHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SANDERS APPEARING CARRUTHERS
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
STATE COUNCIL WAS A CO SPONSOR
OF THE ORIGINAL SELF
DETERMINATION LEGISLATION IN
MANY ROLES IN HELPING MAKE THIS
PROGRAM A SUCCESS THE TWO OF
THOSE ROLES INCLUDE OVERSIGHT-
WE CAN BE A STATE WIDE BODY OF
THE CHAIRS OF EACH OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS LOCAL SUB TO
TERMINATION BY THREE
COMMITTEES. WHICH MR WINFIELD
ARE DISCUSSED WE'RE ALSO TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM AND REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON PRISTINE
SATISFACTION AND IMPLEMENTATION
SO FROM THE NUMBERS ON PAGE
SIXTEEN IN IN YOUR COMMITTEE
PACKET MOST REPORTED BY MR
WINFIELD THE IMPLEMENTATION IS
SLOW I'M SPECIALLY SLOW DURING
THIS INITIAL PHASE IN PERIOD.
OF THE THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
NAMES THAT HAVE BEEN DRAWN FOR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED SLOTS FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY NINE PEOPLE HAVE
FULLY TRANSITIONED FROM THE
TRADITIONAL REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE PROGRAM INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM SO AFTER
ALMOST. THREE YEARS THAT'S
ABOUT 20% THE QUESTION IS ON MY
AS WELL THIS RATE IS A SIGN OF
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE
PROGRAM FOR IS IT JUST THE PACE
OF IMPLEMENTATION. I'VE LOOKED
AT IT FROM MANY ANGLES AND MY
CONCLUSION IS THAT THE SLOW
PACE IS A MATTER OF
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE GOOD
NEWS IS THERE'S MANY PLACES AND
WAYS TO IMPROVE ON
IMPLEMENTATION AT FIRST I
WANTED KNOWLEDGE THE DELAYS
CAUSED BY CORPORATE. DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT. MR WINFIELD YES
LEADERSHIP. REGIONAL CENTERS
SERVICE COORDINATORS FAMILIES
PEOPLE WITH IBD EVERYONE
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. BOB
ENSURING GREAT LEADERSHIP TO
JUST IT BEING HENCE THIS
PROGRAM DESPITE BE INCREDIBLE
BARRIERS THE PENAMPANG TO MAKE
POST. BIANCO GOOD. IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY WINFIELD
MENTIONED STATEWIDE SELF
DETERMINATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PRODUCER BERIA'S
RECORDS. ON THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM
IDENTIFIED FOUR MAIN BARRIERS
I'M GONNA SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE-
BARRIERS AND WE'VE PROVIDED
THAT REPORTS IN ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THIS
COMMITTEE. I ALSO THINK THAT
THE DDS DATA THAT'S IN THE
AGENDA IS VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE
IT HELPS US. LOOK AT WHERE OUR
BREAKDOWNS MAY BE HAPPENING AND
COME UP WITH TARGETED REMEDIES
NOW WE CAN SEE WHO WAS
COMPLETED EACH STEP OF THE
PROCESS AND WE CAN SEE IF I
REGIONAL CENTER- THE DATA SHOWS
THERE'S A DROP OFF BETWEEN
STEPS ONE AND STEPS TO. 85% OF
PEOPLE COMPLETED THE FIRST STEP
BUT ONLY TWENTY EIGHT HAVE
FINISHED THE SECOND STEP- SO WE
CAN LOOK AT AND THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE IN THE PROCESS
INCOME OF THE TARGET REMEDIES.
FOR EACH STEP OF THE PROCESS SO
SOME SOLUTIONS INCLUDE- SETTING
BENCHMARKS FOR THE DIFFERENT
DATA POINTS THAT ARE THE
DEPARTMENTS TRACKING AND
REPORTING ON- AS I MENTIONED IS
A GOOD ENOUGH THAT 85% OF
PEOPLE FINISH THE FIRST STEP-
IS IT BAD THAT ONLY TWENTY. 8%
OF FINISH THE SECOND STEP AT
THIS POINT THE PROCESS OR IS IT
JUST A NATURAL PART IN FLOW
THIS PROCESS. A BENCH MARKS
WILL SET UP REASONABLE
EXPECTATIONS. FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S
GONNA TAKE TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE. ALSO BETTER
SOLUTIONS EACH REGIONAL CENTER
SHOULD SET A GOAL FOR HOW MANY
PEOPLE CAN ENROLL IN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS. I JUST SAID IT'S
PRACTICAL. AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
ANOTHER RECOMMENDED IS THERE'S
BE A KEY. TO ENROLL FOR. WHO
ARE MY OF LOCAL SELF
DETERMINATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEES. INTO THE PROGRAM BY
JUNE- THEY ARE THEY ARE VERY
ENGAGED IN THE PROGRAM THE MOST
MOTIVATED. AND THEY SHOULD.
THEY SHOULD BE ON. LASSETER'S
ONE BURIED IT DOESN'T SHOW UP
IN THE DATA OF THE PHASE IN
PERIOD ITSELF HAS CREATED ITS
OWN BARRIER TO THE PROGRAM- THE
SYSTEM EVERYBODY INVOLVED THEIR
TIME THEIR THOUGHTS OR
SOLUTIONS ARE ALL GOING INTO.
MANAGING HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE
THREE YEAR PHASE IMPROPER
PROCESS- SO IT'S ALREADY LAW
THIS PERIOD ENDS ON JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT SHOULD EXPAND
STATEWIDE BAN WITHOUT CHANGE ON
THAT WITH THE SYSTEM AND SHIFT
ITS FOCUS TO OTHER CPAP ASPECTS
MAKING THIS PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A- THIS PROJECT HELLO
AND I'MSURE THANK YOU SO ANY
PARTICULAR YO WE JUST HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM SO- AND REALLY
IT'S THAT WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS SO THE FIRST IS
CONCERNS THE ROLLOUT AND PLAN
FOR EXPANDING THE PROGRAM IN
JULY AS MR CROWTHER'S JUST
NOTED STATUTES ARE REQUIRED A
THREE YEAR- PHASE INFURIATED.
AFTER THE TIME THAT THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED APPROVAL
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
TO- SECURE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
THE PROGRAM THAT THREE YEARS
ENDS- THIS SUMMER. AND IT'S
UNCLEAR AND AT THAT POINT
STATUTES SAYS THAT THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE TO ANY
CONSUMER WHO IS INTERESTED IN
IT- YOU KNOW PROVIDED THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROPER
INFORMATIONAL SESSIONS AT
CETERA. SO WE HAVE SUGGEST SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S
REALISTIC- TO THINK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE READY TO
ROLL IT OUT TO ANYBODY
STATEWIDE WHO IS INTERESTED IN
THE PROGRAM. OUR SECOND CONCERN
IS- PRIMARILY FISCAL SO STATUTE
REQUIRES THAT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM- BE
BUDGET NEUTRAL. AND THE WAY
THAT IT'S WORKING IS THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL BUDGET FOR EACH-
CONSUMER IS BASED ON THE
PREVIOUS YEAR'S SPENDING ON
THAT CONSUMER AT LEAST TWO
CONSIDERATIONS ARE CAN BE
ALLOWED HOWEVER SO FOR ONE IF
SOMEBODY IS NEW TO THE SYSTEM
AND DIDN'T HAVE SPENDING IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR OBVIOUSLY- A NEW
BUT IT HAS TO BE DEVELOPED.
SECONDLY IF AN INDIVIDUAL HAD-
SOME AMOUNT OF UNMET NEED IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR THAT CAN BE
ACCOUNTED FOR AND WHAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM SOME REGIONAL
CENTERS AS WELL AS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ITSELF IS THAT
CONCERT COMING IN HIGHER- FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAN IN PREVIOUS
YEARS. AND THIS COULD REALLY
MEAN A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST-
IT COULD MEAN THAT CONSUMERS
WERE NOT GETTING EVERYTHING
THAT THEY NEEDED IN PREVIOUS
YEARS AND THIS IS SORT OF
MAKING UP FOR THAT IN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. COULD
ALSO MEAN THAT SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED OUTSIDE OF THE
TRADITIONAL DDS NETWORK BUT-
OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL DDS
SERVICE PROVIDER NETWORK- COULD
YOU COULD COST MORE. AND THAT
IN TURN COULD BE A REFLECTION
OF THE RATE CHALLENGES- THAT
WE'VE ALREADY. HEARD DISCUSSED
AT TODAY'S HEARING- WE THAT THE-
REQUEST MORE INFORMATION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL BUDGETING PROCESS IN
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
AND THIS SHOULD INCLUDE DATA ON
COSTS AND AUTHORIZED SERVICES-
BOTH BEFORE AND AFTER
INDIVIDUALS BEGAN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DEPARTMENT FINANCE. BOTH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING AT.
OKAY AND IF IT IS SO WE'VE BEEN
TRYIG TO IMPLEMENT THIS FOR
THREE YEARS AGAIN I DON'T HAVE
THE HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE BUT
IT IS IT IS IT A VALUABLE
SERVICE THAT WE WANT TO
MAINTAIN OF AND I'M ASSUMING
STEP ONE IS THE ORIENTATION AND
THE GETTING INTO THE STEP TWO
IS CHOOSING SERVICES AND
IMPLEMENTING THOSE CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG. BUT IF PEOPLE ARE
DOING STEP ONE OF THE NOT GOING
INTO STEP TWO IS IT. RIGHT I
MEAN IF PEOPLE DON'T GO TO A
RESTAURANT AFTER WELL WEEK WE
DON'T JUST KEEP WILL BE KEEPING
IT OPEN WE CLOSE THE RESTAURANT
BESIDE US THAT WILL PEOPLE ONE
EIGHT. YEAH I'M SURE THIS IS
NANCY PARCHMENT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOP ALL SERVICES
IF I MAY- RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION- THEIR SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS. A
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN- DESIRED
BY OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
FAMILIES- IT IS A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF A PROGRAM IN THE SENSE.
THAT IT PROVIDES CHOICE AND
FLEXIBILITY- AND RESPONSIBILITY
ON BEHALF OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS CHOOSING TO PARTICIPATE IN
SELF DETERMINATION VERSUS
TRADITIONAL RETAIL CENTER
SERVICES. AND WE HAVE FOUND
OVER YEAR OVER THE YEARS- WHEN
WE HAVE INTRODUCED NEW PROGRAMS
IN OUR SYSTEM. THAT THERE HAS
BEEN. TIMES WHERE IT'S TAKEN
EIGHT EIGHT NUMBER OF YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY BUT A NUMBER OF
YEARS TO BE ABLE TO BUILD THE
STRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO- BUILDS
THE POLICIES AND IMPLEMENTATION
AND CERTAINLY WE HAVE FOUND
CHALLENGES WITHIN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM- BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY A PROGRAM THAT
IS. DESIRED BY OUR COMMUNITY
AND ONE THAT WE AS A DEPARTMENT
REMAIN COMMITTED. AND
IDENTIFYING THE BARRIERS AND-
BUT ALSO ADDRESSING AS MISS
PADDICK HAD HAD NOTED LOOKING
AT THE- THE- THE COST- PRIOR TO
SOMEBODY WHO IS PARTICIPATING
AFTER SOMEBODY'S WHO WHO WHO IS
ENGAGED IN SELF DETERMINATION.
AND THE DRIVERS THAT ARE
IMPACTING KIND OF THOSE FISCAL-
ELEMENTS ONCE WE ARE ABLE TO
GET FOR THEIR VISIBILITY INTO
IT- WE ARE WORKING WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM CMS- TO
ASSIST US IN REVIEWING OUR
CURRENT. PROGRAM AND- WE ARE
LOOKING AT DEVELOPING A PLAN
FOR GOING FORWARD- THAT- WE-
ANTICIPATE AND WILL HAVE
AVAILABLE THIS SPRING- TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT I HOPE HOPE
THAT HELPS- PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF CLARITY REGARDING THE
PROGRAM AND- KIND OF SOME OF
THE- AND OF HIGH LEVEL
STRUGGLES AND IMPLEMENTATION.
N. M. AND A AND I'VE HEARD GOOD
JUST REPEATEDLY THROUGH THIS
HEARING. YOU KNOW WE THINK
ANECDOTALLY HOW MUCH GOOD DATA
ARE WE COLLECTING ON OUR AGAIN
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BENCHMARKS FOR TALK ABOUT.
OUTCOMES WERE TALK ABOUT
BARRIERS. WHAT KIND BOOKS OF
DATA TOOLS ARE WE USE TAX GET
RELEVANT V<c.cyan> RELATIVITY. AND</c>
THEN AND THEN RIP IT DOWN THEN
USING IT. YES THANK YOU- ON
FIRST OF TO TERMINATION- AS MR
WINFIELD HAD HAD NOTED- AND
SAME WITH- L. A. O. AND MR
CROWTHER'S. IS THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOW WITH
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED A SPENDING PLAN- THAT
IS- BY DEFINITION FOR US ARE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY HAVING EXPENDITURES
THEY'RE SPENDING THEIR THEIR
THEIR BUDGET- AND SO IN IN OUR-
IN OUR SYSTEM- WE HAD TWO
THINGS THAT- WE- WE CAN ACCESS
FOR MEASURE- ONE IS- WHAT IS
THE UTILIZATION. OF
EXPENDITURES SO- I AM-
RECEIVING SERVICES- FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND- RESPITE
AND YOU KNOW DAY SERVICES AND
MY TOTAL EXPENDITURES ARE. ACTS
HOWEVER I HAD AUTHORIZED THE
AUTHORIZED SERVICES OF Y. SO I
MAY HAVE HAD MORE AUTHORS-
SERVICES AUTHORIZED THAT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SPEND- AND THERE'S
VARIOUS REASONS FOR THAT- AND
THAT'S WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE'RE COMPARING-
BEFORE THEIR SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM DOES- SERVICES THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED. DOES IT HAVE BEEN
EXPENDED BEFORE AND THEN THOSE-
INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS THAT
FAMILIES- HAVE YET UNDER SELF
DETERMINATION AND THEN. IT'S SO
EARLY ON RIGHT. NOW THAT WHILE
WE'VE NO. HOW MUCH IS OFF BY
STILL DETERMINING WE HOW MUCH
IS EXPENDED BEFORE SELF
DETERMINATION AND FOR THOSE
FOUR HUNDRED AND SOME
INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW WHAT THEIR
BUDGETS ARE- FOR THEIR SPENDING
PLAN WHAT WE DON'T HAVE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME IN
THE PROGRAM IS HOW MUCH THEY'RE
SPENDING. OF THOSE
EXPENDITURES- SO- WE DO HAVE IN
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE AND
WHILE WE HAVE MANY CHALLENGES
IN OUR DATA- THIS IS IN ONE OF
THOSE AREAS THAT THAT WE DO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
EXPERIENCE OR TIME IN THE
PROGRAM- THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE US THAT THAT. THAT
KIND OF ASSESSMENT AT THIS TIME
BUT WE ARE ARE TRACKING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT. MADAM CHAIR
AND COURTESY STATE COUNCIL IF I
CAN ADD AN AMPLIFIED DIRECTOR
BURDENS COMMENTS. YES THIS
PROGRAM IS VERY MUCH IN DEMAND
WANTED BY THE COMMUNITY THE
FIRST MEASURE ACTUALLY SPEAKS
TO THAT- IT IS AFTER YOU'VE HAD
YOUR ORIENTATION DO YOU STILL
WANT TO GO ON AND CONTINUE IN
THE PROGRAM. 85% SAID YES TO
SPEAKING DIRECTLYTO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT DEMAND AND ALSO-
DECREE WITH DRUG DEPARTMENT'S
COMMENT THAT. WITH 20% OF THE
PEOPLE THROUGH THE PROGRAM IT'S
NOT QUITE A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE AS TO WHAT THE
EXPENDITURES WILL BE WHETHER.
WHETHER NOT THE L. A. O.
CONCERNS. WITH CAN BE SUPPORTED
BY INFORMATION. I THINK. THAT
CAN. THANKS VERY MUCH. THIS IS
THE LOOKING THROUGH. SOME OF
THE INFORMATION PRESENTED TOOK
THE FIRST OF ALL- IF SOMEONE IS
GOING THROUGH SELF
DETERMINATION- AT WHAT POINT IT
ARE SIMPLE OF THE FORTY FORTY
SEVEN PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
A PLANET HAVE EXPENDTURE IF
THEY DECIDED THIS ISN'T WORKING
FOR THEM CAN THEY GET BACK OUT
AGAIN. YES FROM REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS CAN OPT OUT OF SELF
DETERMINATION IF THEY WANT TO
GO BACK TO TRADITIONAL SIX AT
ANYTIME. ANYTIME OKAY ALL RIGHT
OKAY THAT THAT'S HELPFUL TO
KNOW AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT IT IS THAT THE
AMOUNT OF THE BUDGET THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY TO BUDGET. IT IS THAT
IS BASED ON- THE PREVIOUS I
GUESS THE PREVIOUS YEAR BEFORE
YOU DECIDE TO ENTER INTO SELF
DETERMINATION. IS A- NOW- WELL
CERTAINLY SOME DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES MAY BE FAIRLY
STABLE OVER TIME CERTAINLY
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY CHANGE AND
SOMETIMES SOME OF THE DEVELOP
DISABILITIES MAY NOT BE SO
STABLE DEPENDING ON THE NATURE
OF THE DISABILITY IS. ARE THERE
JUST THEIR INTENTION THAT THEIR
ADJUSTMENTS WILL BE MADE FOR
THOSE THINGS OVER TIME OR I
KNOW THIS IS WE'RE STILL KIND
OF NEW OURS OURS AFFECTS BUDGET
FOR I MEAN HOW FIX IS THIS
BUDGET OVER TIME. AND HOW DOES
IT TAKE ACCOUNT OF CHANGING.
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THAT
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL. YEAH SO
THIS DETERMINE PRO. IS SIMILAR
TO TRADITIONAL. MANAGEMENT AND
THAT- THE PLANNING TEAM COMES
UP WITH A PLAN. DENNIS THAT
PLANNED AT THE TOWN BUDGET IS
DETERMINED AND INDEED- IS
DERIVED FROM THE BUDGET. SO THE
MONEY TEAM LOOKS AT PRIOR
TWELVE MONTHS OF EXPENDITURES
AND THEN THEY CONSIDER ANY
UNMET NEEDS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
MIGHT HAVE. AND THEN THAT HELPS
TO DETERMINE WHAT IS IN THE I.
P. AND ASK THE BUDGET AND SPIN
OKAY SO I WAS IN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PLANNED AHEAD OF
BUDGET FOR ONE YEAR. AND THEN
THEY MADE CERTAIN CHOICES.
PLANNING TEAM WILL LOOK AT THAT
AND THEN DECIDE NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET ARDELL. LOOK AT A
HYPOTHETICAL SET OF- THAT THAT
FOR. OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THEY
SELF DETERMINATION PER THAT ARE
DID NOT DECIDE TO PURCHASE. IT
SO I'M JUST WONDERING LIKE HOW.
WHAT DOES THE TEAM LOOK AT IF
SOMEONE'S ACTUALLY IN THE SELF
DETERMINATION- PROGRAM- ARE
THEY ACTUALLY LOOKING AT WHAT
THEY ACTUALLY CHOSE TO SPEND
UNDER BUDGET ARE THEY LOOKING
AT A HYPOTHETICAL PLANNED FOR
SOMEONE OF THIS AND SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT'S BASED ON
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR NEEDS
AND THOSE NEEDS CAN BE
REVISITED AND ANYTIME. OKAY OUT
SENT OUT OF THE PLANNING TEAM
COULD MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT TO THE
BUDGET BASED ON. THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY ALL RIGHT- AND THEN- I
GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION IS
THAT- SO I GUESS. IS IT- WILL
COMING SOON WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BRANCH THIS OUT TO EVERYONE.
BUT AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS MADE THAT IT SEEMS TO
BE POPULAR BECAUSE 85% PEOPLE
OF TO GET ORIENTED SHOWS TOO
BUT SAME TIME- IT MAKE NOTE
THAT WE- WE HAVEN'T HIT THE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. RIGHT LET
ME WITH A TWENTY FIVE WE'VE HAD
SPACES WE'VE HAD THREE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED. TWENTY SIX
PEOPLE SELECTED BUT THEN A
HUNDRED SEVEN. YEAH ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO THE TRUE SO WORD
THAT CONTINUE PARTICIPATION
ONLY TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR. OF
WHICH ONLY FOUR TO FORTY SEVEN
ARE CONTINUING SELF. NOT SAYING
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT THIS
BUT- IS THERE A THOUGHT THAT
PERHAPS WERE I MEAN WE HAVEN'T
REALLY UNVEILED A PHILIP THE
PILOT IN SOME WAYS THAT INITIAL
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED SO. IS THE
PLAN TO STILL THE CONTINUE THE
PILOT TO GET MORE DATA OR TO I
MEAN WE'RE AT THAT WE'RE GOING
WE'RE RUNNING UP AGAINST A
POINT WHERE SINGLE NOW WHAT'S
GOING TO OPEN UP TO EVERYONE
BUT DO WE REALLY KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THIS. SINCE WE CAN'T EVEN
GET THE PILOT TO BE COMPLETELY.
FILLED. AND DOCTOR CANADA.
NANCY BIRDS MENDES. YEAH THERE
IS A COUPLE THINGS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE NOTE OF IT IS THAT WE ARE-
EVALUATING- WHAT ARE KIND OF
PLANNED FOR ROLLOUT LIKE. LIKE
I HAD HAD HAD SAID THAT WE FIND
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO. HAVE A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE- KIND OF PLANET
APPROACH TO NEXT STEPS TO
ADDRESS- THE BARRIERS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED BUT THEN ALSO
TO. IDENTIFY YOU KNOW HOW TO
WHAT THE DIGITAL GUARDRAILS IF
ANY ARE NEEDED- SOME EXAMPLES
OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH YOU KNOW
HOW ARE WE APPROACHING THERE'S%
THAT I USE. AND SELF
DETERMINATION THE ONLY VENDOR
TO SERVICE IN SELF
DETERMINATION IS THE FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT SERVICE- AND AS WE
LOOK AT- SOME OF THE BARRIERS
SOME OF IT IS CENTERED AROUND.
AND HOW WE'VE APPROACHED OUR
OUR OUR STRUCTURE AND FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT SERVICES SO. WE NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD- SO TO YOUR POINT AS
FAR AS- ARE WE GOING TO USE
MORE INFORMATION TO HELP INFORM
US AND I THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO IT YOU
KNOW AS NOTED WE HAD. MORE THAN
DOUBLED- THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS THAT HAVE MOVED
PAST ORIENTATION. PASSED HAVING
THEIR BUDGET THAT TOO THERE'S
MANY PLANT. WE HAVE MORE
INDIVIDUALS OF THAT MILESTONE
AT THE LATER STAGES THAT WE DID
EARLIER ON- I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU THAT NATIONALLY- THERE'S-
MOST STATE WHO HOW ASSAULTED.
PROGRAM AND WE'RE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THAT- AVERAGE ABOUT
10215% OF THOSE. WHO ARE WITHIN
THEIR WAIVERS ACTUALLY OPTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM- AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THAT'S A CAP
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO ACHIEVE
TO- BUT I THINK IT GIVES US A
LITTLE BIT OF VISIBILITY INTO.
WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE
EXPERIENCED- WHEN THEY'VE HAD
THE BROADER- DOOR OPEN FOR A
MORE PARTICIPANTS BEYOND WHAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN OUR FIRST
THREE YEARS OF THE PILOT OF OR
NOT I SHOULDN'T USE THE TERM
PILOT. OF THE FADED OF THE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED VERSES-
HAVING IT OPEN TO OUR BROADER
COMMUNITY. OKAY SO I GUESS WHAT
I'M NOT HEARING IS- THE ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION WHICH IS THAT
DO YOU PLAN TO CAN T. D. IT
WELL I GUESS YOU'LL TELL. OF
THE BY MAIL BE TELLING BECAUSE
THERE'S- A STATUTORY DEADLINE
RIGHT THIS TALK ABOUT OPENING
IT UP OR NOT. YEAH- ARE YOU
PLAN TO CONTINUE TO PILE WHICH
BY THE WAY STILL HAS SLOTS SO
IT'S NOT THAT WOULD DENY ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO DO IT. ARE WE
SAYING THAT WE ACTUALLY KNOW
ENOUGH TO COMPLETELY OPEN IT UP
AND THEN ALSO. SINCE YOU
MENTIONED 10215% AND I'M TRYING
TO REMEMBER. WHAT SO WE HAVE A
PILE OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
WHICH WE HAVE A FILLED OUT THAT
WE WERE ACTUALLY AT 10% OR
FIFTEEN PERCENT. HOW MANY
PEOPLE WOULD THAT BE GIVEN WHO
YOU'RE SERVING NOW- AND DDS SO
I MEAN. TWENTY FIVE AND
REPRESENTS WHAT PERSONNEL WHAT
PERCENTAGE. YEAH I DID- TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I YOU KNOW
I AM WELL I'M NOT. AND IT IS
CAN YOU JUST SAY OF THAT THAT'S
CORRECT OUR PLAN WE DO PLAN ON
ON ON. HAVING AN OUTLINE OF
KIND OF THOSE STEPS GOING
FORWARD- YOU KNOW AND I DO WANT
TO CLARIFY BECAUSE I'D MISUSED
THE WORD PILOT THIS IS NOT A
PILOT- AND- SO. YOU KNOW IT IS
OUR INTENT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
OPEN- TO OUR BROADER COMMUNITY-
WE HAVE SOME THINGS TO WORK
THROUGH. AND BEFORE I CAN SAY
THAT YOU KNOW EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO BE ON TRACK TO HAVE A
VERY BROAD OPENING. AND WE NEED
TO THINK THROUGH HOW DO WE DO
THAT HOW DO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS BE ABLE TO. HELP
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW MOVED TO
SELF DETERMINATION HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT SOME OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH WE NEED TO- I
WHAT I CALL KIND OF STRUCTURE-
IN THE PROGRAM NOW. YOU'LL HEAR
FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS- THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS PROGRAMS
NOT JUST SAYING OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN. YOU
KNOW AS OF JUNE OR JULY AND I'M
NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT. WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT E'RE ADDRESSING THE
BARRIERS AND ANYTHING THAT
NEEDS TO HAVE KIND OF COURSE
CORRECTION IN THE PROGRAM. YOU
REALLY HAVE A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM GOING FORWARD- WE WANT
THAT WE WANT IT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THIS IS WHAT OUR
COMMUNITY IS A SATHYAM FOR THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE CHOICE-
SO- AS FAR AS THOSE NEXT STEPS
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE HAVE TO ALSO
WORK THROUGH OUR WAIVER- AND-
SO ANY CHANGES OR ANYTHING THAT
WE'RE DOING IT'S GOING TO BE.
VERY VERY TRANSPARENT AND
WORKING WITH OUR FAMILIES THAT
ARE- VERY DEDICATED AND
ADVOCATING FOR SELF
DETERMINATION- SO I JUST I
ASKED YOU KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW
MORE TO COME OVER THE SPRING
WHEN WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
WITH OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAMS TO BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT
MODIFICATIONS- WOULD- BENEFIT
THE PROGRAM GOING FORWARD ON
ARTS. SO I'M HEARING FROM YOU
IS THERE STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
DO. CERTAINLY I AND I'M NOT
SUGGESTING WE RECENTLY STOPPED
DOING THIS- BUT ALSO BASED EVEN
ON YOUR OWN DATA. AND EVEN
THOUGH YOUR OWN TESTIMONY RIGHT
NOW THAT THEY'RE STILL A LOT OF.
THAT WORK OUT. SO AT LEAST. IT
THOUGH YOU'RE NOT SAYING THIS
RIGHT NOW I THINK CERTAINLY AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY AND YOU ALWAYS
HAVE BEEN- IN MY WORK WITH YOU.
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MORE
OF AN UPDATE AND A WHAT YOUR
PLANS ARE LEASE AND YOU KNOW
FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR. IN
TERMS OF HOW TO MOVING THIS
PROGRAM FORWARD AND BE SURE
THAT THOSE GUARD RAILS ARE ARE
THERE SO. IT'S YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY NOT OPPOSED TO DOING
SELF DETERMINATION I THINK THAT
THE ISSUE IS THAT- SOUNDS LIKE
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT ALL THE
GUARDRAILS YET GIVEN THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
WE HAVE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE
STILL. DON'T HAVE THAT MANY
PEOPLE IN THE PILOT ARE YOU
DON'T CALL PILOT BUT BASICALLY
AND- IS OUR FIRST COHORT RIGHT
WE DON'T EVEN FILL THE NUMBERS
UP OKAY- FOR THAT AND SO I
THINK WE WANT TO BE SURE WE
HAVE THOSE. ENOUGH DATA TO SO
THAT WE HAVE THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED AND I THINK CERTAINLY.
HERE THOSE OF US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO BE SURE
WERE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION
SO AND THAT WE WANT AND WOOD
IT'S SNOWING I ROLLED OVERSIGHT
TO BE ABLE. TO KNOW WHAT WHAT.
WHAT THE PLANS ARE AND. WHAT
KIND OF GUARDRAILS ARE BEING
PUT IN PLACE. YES THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I WILL MAKE NOTE THAT-
WE ARE. AND SHORT TERM LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE- PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE- TO
MOVE. YOU KNOW THROUGH THEIR
THAT. TO YOU KNOW INCREASE R.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIXTY.
INDIVIDUALS QUICKER AND THERE
ARE SOME SHORT TERM- THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO- TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT ON A SHORT TERM
BASIS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
SHORTEN A LONGER TERM. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND- OUR COMMUNITY
ON THE SOUTHERN ONE OTHER PIECE
OF EVERY SHOULD BE INTERESTED
IN KNOWING. THE LOVE THE AMOUNT
OF OVERHEAD IN TERMS OF- FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FOR PEOPLE AND
SELF DETERMINATION VERSES IF
THEY'RE GETTING REGULAR SO HOW
MUCH. OVERHEAD DISASSOCIATED- I
WAS THE WE WANT TO PROVIDE
FAMILIES WHO AREN'T SELF
DETERMINATION SOME SUPPORT SO
AND I JUST LIKE HERE YOU GO
THE- FIGURE OUT YOURSELF AND WE
WILL HAVE SO IN TERMS OF
OVERHEAD I'M NOT. SAYING IT'S
ALL BAD- BUT- I JUST WANNA KNOW
WHAT THE OVERHEAD ALSO IS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT DOING THIS UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
PANDERING PRODUCING STATE
COUNCIL- THE RATES FOR
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE AMOUNT
THAT NEEDS TO BE IMPLEMENTED-
WHAT I'M SEEING FROM MY POINT
OF VIEW IS THAT EVERY PART OF
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING TOGETHER
TO STILL IMPLEMENTED WORKS OF
THESE ISSUES SO WELL THERE'S A
LOT TO WORK ON I WOULDN'T TAKE
THAT AS A INDICATION OR SIGN OF
PROBLEMS OF THE PROGRAM- BY
REGIONAL CENTERS FAMILIES
CONSUMERS I'M CERTAINLY THAT
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENTS AT
LEADERSHIP IS WORKING ON AN
EVIDENCE OF THAT IS HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ROLLED
EVEN DURING CO BUT- WITH ALL OF
THE DEMANDS AND- JUST.
LIFESAVING OUR- OF THE PANDEMIC
FROM THOSE LAST YEAR IT IF
PEOPLE WEREN'T COMMITTED THIS
PROGRAM USING JUST A SORT OF
WALK AWAY AND NOT MAKE MOVEMENT
ON IT BUT THERE. HAS BEEN
MOVEMENT DESPITE ALL ODDS AND I
THINK THAT'S GOOD EVIDENCE TO
THE DEDICATION TO THIS PROGRAM.
I APPRECIATE THAT I THINK IT'S-
IS AGAIN I'M NOT OPPOSED TO
ACTUALLY I THINK THAT IT'S GOOD
DIRECTION IF THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
WANT- BUT ALSO. IN OUR
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION WE WANT TO
KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT TO EAT. IS
WERE ROLLING OUT THAT WE'RE
DOING IT NOW. IT DIDN'T IN A
MANNER ACTUALLY THAT THE
DIRECTOR JUST TALKED ABOUT AND
THAT WE- HAVE CLARITY FOR
OURSELVES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATION OVERSIGHT FUNCTION
WHAT- WHAT LESSONS LEARNED WHAT
KIND OF GUARDRAILS ARE. YOU
OVERSIGHT EXPENSES YOU KNOW THE
SUPPORTS FAMILIES NEED WHEN
THEY'RE DOING. STUFF THE
TERMINATION THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I. AND I THINK
WE'RE KIND OF ALL SAYING THE
SAME THING WE CAN WE CAN FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A GOOD IDEA BUT-
IF IT'S BEEN UP AND RUNNING AND
IT'S NOT FULLY IMPLEMENTED YET.
TO GO BACK TO THE EARLIER
ANALOGY BEFORE WE FRANCHISES
OUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY. IN THE WHO IS WHO IS
IN THIS NOT PILOT BUT THIS.
FIRST A FIRST WAVE WILL SAY-
AN EFFECTIVE MANNER BEFORE WE
SAY WE'RE TAKING THIS. WE'RE
EXPANDING THIS EVEN FURTHER.
OKAY I THINK WE'LL MOVE ON TO
NOW ISSUE NUMBER FIVE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATORS. THANK YOU MEDICARE-
NANCY PARCHMENT DIRECTOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES- I. E. FOR THE BEST-
ISSUE FIVE- I WILL BE
ADDRESSING- QUESTIONS ONE AND
TWO- AND THEN THIS IS YOUR BIG-
WILL- PROVIDE RESPONSES FOR
QUESTIONS THREE AND FOUR- I
HATE IT THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THE OPPORTNITY TO- PRESENT TO
YOU OUR PROPOSAL FOR THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAM-
THIS IS. REALLY STEM FROM ALONG
THE- QUITE ACTUALLY SINCE I
STARTED THE DEPARTMENT- AS
DIRECTOR BUT EVEN BEFORE THAT-
THE PRIORITY OF ADDRESSING THE
INEQUITY OF SPENDING AND
DISPARITIES WITHIN OUR
PROGRAMS- ONE IS THAT THE
NUMBER OF- POLICIES AND
EFFORTS- THAT WE HAVE IN AND
WORKING- ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT-
CHALLENGES. I'M FACING-
SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND- NEED TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP- THE EFFORTS.
OF AS A PRIORITY BUT ALSO
LOOKING AT NEW WAYS TO BE ABLE
TO- BE RESPONSIVE AND DISRUPT
YES- INEQUITY OF SERVICE
DELIVERY AND IN PARTICULAR
AREAS. SO PART OF OUR EFFORT-
THE GRANT PROGRAM HAS BEEN IN
OPERATION SINCE- SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. AND OVER THE YEARS-
THAT FOR THOSE- FOR NOT AS
FAMILIAR WITH THAT WE DO HAVE
ELEVEN MILLION. DOLLARS THAT-
HAD HAS BEEN APPROVED IN OUR
BUDGET FOR THAT IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT COULD GO TO A
GRANT PROGRAM AND- THE FIRST
YEAR WE IMPLEMENTED IT WE HAD
IMPLEMENTED IT ON TO REGIONAL
CENTRES- AS KIND OF THE SOLE
SOURCE OF IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS
TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT WERE
RELATED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.%
THE SECOND YEAR- REALLY THROUGH
THE WISDOM OF- SOME FAMILIES
WHO IS THAT HEY WAIT YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE REALLY THE ONES THAT HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY AND IF WE HAVE KIND
OF CONCERNS AND- FEARS OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER- SOME OF IT IS-
KIND OF THAT QUALIFY A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY SOME OF IT
IS- BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROKEN THERE IS- JUST
A NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT NEEDED
TO BE ADDRESSED. AND THAT WAS
VERY WISE SO THANK YOU YEAR WE
IMPLEMENTED USING BE COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS- OVER THE
YEARS THE LAST FEW YEARS WE
HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF. MODELS BASED
ON NAVIGATOR. OR FROM A TORAH.
AND I WE'RE IN A ROW FORTY SOME
DIFFERENT PROJECTS- THAT HAS- A
BALLS YOU KNOW INTO VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE STATE- WITH FOCUS
AND VARIOUS DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES- NINE OF THOSE
PROJECTS WERE WITH FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS- ONE OF MY ARE
CHALLENGES THEM AND WE HAVE
THAT WE'VE TALKED TO. THIS
COMMITTEE- IN PAST YEARS IS
ABOUT HOW DO WE MEASURE-
SUCCESS OF THESE PROJECTS YOU
KNOW AND HAVING A CONSISTENT
WAY TO BE ABLE TO DO. KIND OF A
PRE AND A POST AND WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE THE NOT ONLY THE
QUANTITATIVE BUT THE
QUALITATIVE. OUTCOMES AND SO IN
LOOKING AT- KNOWING THAT
EVIDENCE BASED FROM A TORAH AND
LOOKING AT THE RESPONSE THAT
WE'VE BEEN GETTING ON OUR
NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS- WE WANTED
TO BUILD ON THAT. AND ALSO
WANTED TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ONE WAY TO
MEASURE SUCCESS OF A STRATEGY
OR INITIATIVE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS. AND THAT THE INEQUITY
OR SERVICE ACCESS IF YOU WILL-
SO THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE YOU- THE GENDER
CORRECTLY NOTES THAT IT'S- WE
HAVE PROPOSED FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION TOTAL FUND THREE POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND- THAT
WOULD CONTRACT WITH FAMILY
RESOURCES IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WOULD BE LOOKING FOR
ESSENTIALLY TWENTY ONE
DIFFERENT CONTRACTS- AND BASED
ON STAKEHOLDER INPUT THAT WE
PLAN ON ON GAINING OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS- IF THERE
NEEDS TO BE A FEW MORE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ASSURANCES TO A
BROADER COMMUNITY ACCESS WE
CERTAINLY WOULD ENTERTAIN THAT-
BUT WHEN WE- ARE LOOKING AT
THIS. THE FIRST YEAR WE WANT TO
ALSO BE ABLE TO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT. REVIEW OF OUR
GRANT PROGRAM. I THE PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE- ALREADY FUNDED
AND HOW BEEN IN IN. EVALUATION
LATE LET US KNOW WHAT ARE THE
CURRENT EFFORTS AND- AND IS IT
REALLY PROMOTING- AND REDUCING-
DISPARITIES AND- INCREASING
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND THEN
WHAT WOULD BE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
THAT- PROGRAM. SO FOR THE FIRST
YEAR WELL WE HAVE- FIVE
HUNDRED- THOUSAND EARMARKED FOR
THIS CONTRACT TO AN INDEPENDENT
PARTY- WE DO- WANT TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND LOOKING AT MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A VERY
MEANINGFUL AND REVIEW THAT IS
GOING TO BE INFORMATIVE. TO US
AND ALSO INFORMATIVE TO OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL- SO THAT THIS PROPOSAL AS
THEY NOTED- DOES- PROPOSED THE
TWENTY ONE DIFFERENCE- FRC'S-
WE WOULD DO THIS THROUGH A
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL WE WOULD
WORK- THROUGH- THAT THE
COMMUNITY TO PROPOSE THAT AND
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WAS
PROPOSED. YES WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER AND KIND OF A
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR HOW IS IT
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT- AS A
PROBABLY NOTED AND THE AGENDA
AT THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
ARE REALLY ENGAGED IN EARLY
START WELL SOME OF THEM MAY
HAVE CONTRACTS WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS TO DO SOME OTHER
EFFORTS THEIR PRIMARY FOCUS
REALLY HAS BEEN. ON CONNECTING
TO THE COMMUNITIES- IN AN EARLY
START AND HELP BEING KIND OF-
PARENT EDUCATION- THIS REALLY
BROADENS THAT SO WHAT WE WOULD
BE ASKING IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ONE OF THOSE DIFFERENCE WHERE
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS CAN
EXPAND. THEIR EFFORTS AND WOULD
BE ABLE. TO HIRE ONE OR MORE-
NAVIGATE THAT ARE TRUSTED THE
CAN. SO IT WOULD BE DRIVEN
BASED ON EITHER A FAMILY MEMBER
OR SOMEBODY THAT IS- SEPARATE
FROM A REGIONAL CENTER- TO BE
ABLE TO HELP FAMILIES- CONNECT
AND UNDERSTAND REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. ALSO GENERIC
RESOURCES AND OF BUILDING THAT
BRIDGE BUT ALSO BUILDING B.
INDIVIDUALS AND THE FAMILIES-
SKILL SETS TO BE ABLE TO AT-
ADVOCATE AND NAVIGATE- EVEN
BEYOND THE WORK THAT- THAT
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO WITH THEM- WE WOULD-
BUILD N A- MEASURE THAT WOULD
BE PRE AND POST. SO WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE A STANDARDIZED
MEASURE ACROSS THE STATE YOU'VE
HEARD ON A COUPLE OF THE OTHER
PANEL SOME OF THE CHALLENGES-
OF SOME INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE
HAD GOING FORWARD- THAT THE
CONSISTENCY BETWEEN RACIAL
CENTERS AND SO AGAIN THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT. THE DEPARTMENT
THEN ISSUING AT PROVIDING KIND
OF THE STRUCTURE AROUND IT SO
WE WOULD HAVE CONSISTENCY IN
THE GOALS AND THE TRAINING AND
EXPECTATIONS THAT WOULD BE
ACROSS. EACH OF THOSE AND THEN
THE SAME FOR THE MEASURES THAT
WE WOULD. BE PUTTING FORWARD-
AND WE CAME UP WITH THE
PROPOSED AMOUNT- WE LOOK TO SEE
HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST TO HAVE
A COUPLE OF POSITIONS- THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK WITHIN
THE DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC AREAS.
AS WELL ASTHE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORTS THAT WOULD GO IN. AND
SO ON AN AVERAGE IS ABOUT- ON A
ON GOING BASIS IT WOULD BE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PER. AND REGIONAL
CENTER BUT AGAIN BASED ON
STAKEHOLDER INPUT WE ARE GOING
TO- EVLUATE HOW IT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
SMALLERREGIONAL CENTERS HAVE.
ALMOST IS AS MANY CHALLENGES AS
LARGER REGIONAL CENTER
CATCHMENT AREAS- SO WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST DO A STANDARD HEY
IF YOU HAVE. FOUR THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN YOUR COMMUNITY
VERSUS FOURTEEN THOUSAND- WE
DON'T WANT TO MEASURE IT BASED
ON THAT WE WANT TO MEASURE TO
BASED ON BASED ON HOW WE CAN
HAVE AFFECTED- NEEDS MET- ON
THIS PROGRAM. SO MR TREVINO
WILL GO AHEAD AND PROVIDE
UPDATES BASED ON YOUR QUESTIONS
THREE AND FOUR THANK YOU. SURE
ENOUGH. I THANK YOU MISTER- TO
AGAIN OF THE- THANKS THE UP.
I'M GONNA PICK IT UP PAGE OF
THE AGENDA TALKING ABOUT. ARE
APPROACH. AS DOOR MARK JUST-
EACH REGIONAL CENTER NOW HAS A
CULTURE SPACE. DEREK TO
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY.
WE HAVE ONE AT THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AND ALSO HAVE A
RELATIVELY NEW ASSISTANT DEPUTY
FOR SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY.
HER NAME IS LAYING ON A WALSER-
THE ANNUAL BUDGET INCLUDES
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GRANTS TO REGIONAL CENTERS IN
THE BUDGET- A YEAR AGO A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE ALSO ADDED AS- ALLOWED
RECIPIENTS. OF THAT FUNDING-
AND THESE GRANTS SUPPORT
REGIONAL CENTER PLANS. TO
PROMOTE EQUITY. ANNUALLY THE
REGIONAL SIDE KALEB WITH THE-
TOGETHER AND REPORT DATA
RELATED TO PURCHASE SERVICE
AUTHORIZATION UTILIZATION AND
EXPENDITURES. THEY ALSO
UNDERTAKE ACTIVITIES TO
IDENTIFY A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES. BARRIERS TO
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS AND TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PLANS TO
REDUCE IDENTIFIED DISPARITIES-
ANNUALLY THOSE REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT ON
EQUITY MEASURES AS PART OF
THEIR ANNUAL PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS THEY HAVE TO REVIEWS-
SATISFACTION SURVEY DATA WITH
THEIR BOARDS OF DIRECTORS. NEWS
REGIONAL CENTERS OF NONPROFITS
WITH BOARDS I ACTUALLY HAVE TO
REVIEW ACTIONS TAKEN TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION AT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS. ALL THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE COPIES OF MINUTES AN
ATTENDEE COMMENTS AND ALSO
THEIR OWN RECOMMENDATIONS ON A
PLAN FOR PROMOTING EQUITY
PROMOTING EQUITY AND REDUCING
DISPARITIES. I DO THEM IN SCOPE
IN NINETEEN DURING CALENDAR
TWENTY TWENTY THE TIME FRAMES
FOR. THESE MEETINGS AND THE
REPORTS WERE EXTENDED AND THEIR
ANNUAL REPORTS WERE DUE ONLY
RECENTLY- WE'VE I DO WORK WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS- AND THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE AND THE SERVICE ACCESS
AND EQUITY WORKGROUP- AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER MEETINGS TO IDENTIFY
SOME PRIORITY AREAS OF FOCUS.
FOR THE SPRINT PROGRAM. ONE
YEAH THERE'S THREE OF THEM-
BUILT BUILDING THE LEADERSHIP
CAPACITY OF SELF ADVOCATES AND
FAMILIES TO INCREASE THEIR
REPRESENTATION INVOICE AND THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
SECONDED CREATING COLLABORATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONNECTION OF
LEARNING BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THIRD
IMPROVING ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY-
INCLUDING TRAINING FOR SELF
ADVOCATES AND FAMILIES. SO WITH
THOSE PRIORITIES IN MIND THE
DEPARTMENT AS ANNUALLY FUNDED
PROJECTS THESE PROJECTS FALL
INTO SEVERAL DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES INCLUDING
TRANSLATIONS CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY TRAINING.
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING
TRAINING AARON NAVIGATORS AND
PARENTS SUPPORT SERVICES
INCLUDING PROMISE FOR A
PROGRAMS FOR ACCESSING SERVICES
AND REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THROUGH OTHER SYSTEMS. SINCE
ITS INCEPTION IN SIXTEEN I'M
SORRY IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT FIRST YEAR WE
FUNDED OVER A HUNDRED PROJECTS
AND WE GRADUALLY BROUGHT THAT
DOWN ANNUALLY OVER TIME. FOR
REASONS I'LL MENTION A SECOND
WE DID SIXTY FIVE PROJECTS IN
THE SECOND YEAR SIXTY FOUR IN
THE THIRD FIFTY FIVE PROJECTS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY FINALIZING SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OF WORDS IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR BUT THE
DETAILS OF ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM IS AVAILABLE IN THE EQUITY
SECTION OF OUR WEBSITE. I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A QUICK DIGRESSION
HERE BECAUSE I DID MENTION OUR
WEB WEBSITE. DR TAN HAVE.
INCREASED FOREST EARLIER AND
SAID IT WAS CREDIT TO OUR TEAM.
WHO'S MONITORING THE HEARING
REMOTELY AND SUPPORTING US
TODAY IN THE LAST THIRTY DAYS
WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
VISITORS TO OUR WEBSITE. THAT'S
THE EQUIVALENT OF ONE SIXTH OF
OUR POPULATION ALTHOUGH NON
NONCONFORMIST. ACCESS AS WELL
OF COURSE. IN A RECENT SURVEY.
THAT WE DID IT. OUR CONSUMERS
AND FAMILIES ARE SELF ADVOCATES
AND FAMILIES. 89% OF THEM
INDICATED THAT ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET HAS BEEN A CRITICAL
TOOL FOR THEM IN THE PAST YEAR.
AND THAT THAT SAME PERCENTAGE
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR INFORMATION
DIRECTLY FROM OUR DEPARTMENT
VIA EMAIL AS WELL- SO YOU KNOW
WHILE IT'S OF COURSE NOT THE
ONLY THING THAT WE DO. WE ARE
HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE POSTING
HOUSE VALUE. AND IS BEING
SHARED BY PEOPLE THE ON OUR OWN
EFFORTS TO DISSEMINATE IT- BEEN
BACK TO THE- JUST DISPARITY
GRANTS PROGRAM THEY'RE THEY'RE
OVER THESE LAST FOUR FOUR YEARS
WE HAVE. LEARNED A FEW LESSONS
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO LEARN
THEM. WELL FIRST OF FINING
CONCRETE OUTCOMES IS REALLY
DIFFICULT. MEETING WITH
FAMILIES AND THEN COUNTING THE
NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
<c.green>EEN TRANSLATED THOSE THOSE</c>
THINGS ARE EASIER CAL. HOWEVER
THEY'RE REALLY DIFFICULT TO
CONNECT WITH MEASURABLE
IMPROVEMENTS AND ACT IN ACCESS
DESPITE THE INTUITIVE
CONNECTION THAT BEING ABLE TO
READ SOMETHING IN YOUR OWN
LANGUAGE MIGHT MEAN FOR YOUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS THAT IT'S
REALLY HARD TO MEASURE. HOW
YOUR ACCESS HAS BEEN IMPROVED-
PURCHASE OF SERVICE IS AN
IMPORTANT METRIC- AND IT'S ONE
THAT WE- CONTINUED OUR TO
REQUIRE REGIONAL CENTERS TO
REPORT ON- BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF FACTORS THAT INFLUENCE THAT
THE AGE THE PLACE OF RESIDENCE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
SERVICES THE DISTANCE THAT
PEOPLE. EITHER NEED TO BE
TRANSPORTED- OR THAT THE
SERVICE PROVIDER MUST COVER TO
GET TO. I AM PEOPLE'S
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
ALSO AFFECT OF PURCHASE OF
SERVICE SPENDING. WELL OF
COURSE WILL CONTINUE AT A
POPULATION LEVEL TO COMPARE
THOSE THINGS- WERE ALSO TRYING
TO DIVE DEEPER INTO OUR DATA TO
LOOK AT SIMILARLY SITUATED
INDIVIDUALS. TO DRAW MORE FINER
COMPARISON- LIGHTLY LIKE IF YOU
WILL. BUT WE'VE ALSO LEARNED
AND IT PROBABLY IS OBVIOUS YOUR
IF WE HAVE A POT OF ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE FIVE
HUNDRED PROJECTS WITH IT.
THAT'S NOT A GREAT DEAL OF
MONEY IT'S ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PROJECT
AND IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT WITH
THAT KIND OF MONEY FOR
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS TO ACHIEVE
CONCENTRATED AND IMPACTFUL
RESULTS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM. THIS IS ALSO
EXACERBATED BY THE FACT THAT
BECAUSE OF THE ANNUAL FUNDING
CYCLE A NUMBER OF THESE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN TIME LIMITED
TO EITHER TWELVE OR TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS- SO YOU'RE RAMPING UP
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING TO RAMP
DOWN TO REPORT ON IT TO MEASURE
THE IMPACT. AND THAT IN A LOAN
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
STATE'S SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
IMPACT OF THIS PROJECT
SUMMERTIME. SO WITH THESE
CONCERNS IN MIND IN TWENTY
TWENTY. STATEWIDE EQUITY
MEASURES WERE IMPLEMENTED TO
ALLOW ALL OF US TO TRACK
PROGRESS IN IN A BETTER WAY. WE
SO FAR ANALYZE CHANGES FROM
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE YEAR BEFORE
THE EQUITY GRANTS THROUGH
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR-
OF THE TWENTY ONE POPULATION
LEVEL EQUITY MEASURES EIGHT OF
THEM IMPROVED BY THREE POINTS
OR MORE. TEN CHAU DOLLAR MINOR
CHANGE AND THREE ACTUALLY
SHOWED US IT WAS A LARGE CAP-
NOTABLY TO WE WERE CONCERNED TO
SEE THAT THERE WAS NO
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE SIX
MEASURES THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HISPANIC OR
SPEAK SPANISH. ALSO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO IDENTIFY THINGS
THAT THAT CONCERN US A GREAT
DEAL WE'RE CONTINUING TO
ANALYZE MORE RECENT DISPARITY
DATA FROM BOTH OF US THAT AT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SCHOOL
YEAR IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES
FISCAL YEAR- THERE IS ROOM FOR
A LITTLE BIT OF OPTIMISM ONE
PRELIMINARY FINDING THAT I'LL
SHARE WITH YOU IS THAT AMONG
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE AT HOME
THE RATIO OF. PER CAPITA-
PURCHASE OF SERVICE SPENDING
FOR ASIANS COMPARED TO WHITES
IMPROVED IN SIX REGIONAL
CENTERS. WELL THE PER CAPITA
PURCHASE OF SERVICE SPENDING
FOR BLACKS AND HISPANICS
IMPROVED IN TEN OF THEM- SO WE
DO THINK WE'RE MANAGING TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE A LITTLE BIT LOOKING
UP MORE CURRENT DATA- BUT OUR
ANALYSIS YET ISN'T COMPLETE-
GIVEN THE EARLIER INTERESTED.
STATED IN THE AGENDA WITH OUR
OUR PROPOSAL FOR COMMUNITY
NAVIGATORS I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD
A COUPLE COMMENTS ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH THOSE PROJECTS
WHICH WE FIND THROUGH THIS
DISPARITY GRANT PROGRAM.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY ALL OF THE
NAVIGATOR FOR PROJECTS FUNDED
THROUGH THE GRANT ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO COLLECT THE
STANDARD SET OF DATA AND
PROGRAM INFORMATION SO THAT WE
CAN AGGREGATE. DATA DATA
AVAILABLE ON TO THE CONSUMER
OUTCOMES. SO WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
IT YET THE THEY EFFORT TO
COLLECT THAT INFORMATION BEGAN
IN THE LATE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY BETWEEN MARCH AND JUNE.
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS SET OF
INFORMATION WILL INCLUDE THE
ASSISTANCE THAT FAMILIES
RECEIVE AND ACCESSING MORE
GENERIC SERVICES SUCH AS
HOUSING SUPPORTS AN IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS WELL AS
CHANGES IN PURCHASE OF SERVICE
DATA. WE ALSO HAVE SOME MORE
QUALITATIVE DATA. THAT WHEN WE
LOOK AT DATA BEFORE AND AFTER
THE PRE AND POST SURVEYS OF
KNOWLEDGE GAINED. AND OTHER
QUALITATIVE IMPACTS ON FAMILIES
PARTICIPANTS IN THESE PAST
PROJECTS HAVE REPORTED AN
INCREASED ABILITY TO NAVIGATE
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM.
INDICATED AND DEMONSTRATED MORE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT GENERIC
SERVICES THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE
TO THEM AND ALSO A GREATER
SENSE OF EMPOWERMENT AND
SEEKING MANY TO SUPPORT. IN
PART BECAUSE THEY NOW KNOW MORE.
SO GIVEN SOME OF THESE LESSONS
LEARNED AND DATA LIMITATIONS ON
GOING FORWARD- ALL GRANT
PROGRAMS WILL HAVE A SET OF
MEASURES OF THE PROJECT IMPACTS
IDENTIFIED IN DISCUSSION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. WHERE YOU CAN
JUST STANDARDIZED THE PROJECTS
IS SIMILAR TYPES HAVE SIMILAR
MEASURES AS I JUST DESCRIBED
FOR THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS
PROJECTS. BOB WE WERE ALSO
ASKING PROJECTS REPORT ON THEIR
MEASURES ON A QUARTERLY BASIS-
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE MORE
ACTIVE IN OUR OVERSIGHT OF
PROJECTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
REMAIN ON TRACK- WE WILL NOTE.
IT'S AN ELEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
pPROGRAM WE HAVEN'T- CARVED OUT
FUNDING HISTORICALLY TO DO AN
OUTCOME EVALUATION OF
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS DIRECTOR
MARGIN INDICATED. WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL FOR HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO AN EVALUATION OF
THE IMPACT OF THESE. ROGER X.
HELLO AND WE INTEND TO BE A
TARGET THAT EVALUATION NOT NOT-
TO KIND OF COUNT WHAT'S BEEN
DONE IN TERMS OF ACTIVITIES BUT
TO MEASURE THE IMPACT OF THOSE
ACTED WE REALLY DON'T. OF
COURSE MEETINGS WITH FAMILIES
IS IMPORTANT BUT THE OUTCOME OF
THAT MEETING FOR THE FAMILY IS
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO US AND
SO THOSE ARE REALLY THE DRIVERS
FOR OUR PROPOSAL FOR AN
EVALUATION WHICH ALL TURNED TO
MAX AND QUESTION FOR WE WERE
ASKED TO DESCRIBE THE GENERAL
TIMELINE HERE BOB SO- WE'VE
ALREADY BEGUN TO THINK ABOUT
HOW TO STRUCTURE THE EVALUATION
AND THE NECESSARY EXPERTISE FOR
A CONTRACTOR- THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE IN ORDER TO
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THE WORK.
WILL BE PLANNING TO ENGAGE WITH
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE AND ITS SERVICE ACCESS
AND EQUITY WORKGROUP AND. OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO PROVIDE INPUT-
OF WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
THE RIGHT. IN WAYS THAT LEAD TO
QUANTIFIABLE ANSWERS ABOUT HOW
WE'RE MOVING THE NEEDLE. ON
ACCESS AND EQUITY MEASURES- AN
ASSUMING THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE
APPROVED FOR THIS EVALUATION.
WE HAVE TO KIND OF PLANS AT
THIS TIME TO DO THAT
CONSULTATION AND THEN RELEASED
A REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL A COUPLE
MONTHS AFTER ENACTMENT OF THE
BUDGET IN JULY. WITHOUT A
ANTICIPATED AWARD BY THE END OF
CALENDAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR WITH
ACTUAL WORK BEGINNINGS- NOT IN
SOMETIME IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND I THINK WE SAT
I AM GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS ON THIS
QUESTIONS. I THINK WE'LL HEAR
FROM MISTER MISTER GOMEZ. VICE
PRESIDENT DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED. BERMAN M. SHERMAN
DISTINGUISH COMMITTEE ON MY
NAME IS FOR NUMBER GOMEZ I AM
THE FATHER OF TWO CHILDREN IN
MY FOURTEEN YEAR OLD WHO HAS
DOWN SYNDROME. IT PRIOR TO
PROVIDING YOU WITH MY TESTIMONY
WEARING MY ADVOCATE HAVE I WANT
TO CONTINUE. WEARING MY DAD
HALF OF THIS IS US CURRENT ON
YOUR- IN IN HIS THIS IS THE
FACE OF ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
CONSIDERATION IS GOING IN THIS
OUR CONVERSATIONS THAT GOES
BEYOND THE DATA IN IN IN
STATISTICS THAT ARE SHARED. ARM
HE IS A WRITER HE IS THE ONE
WHO MOTIVATES US. IN IN SHARING
AS A FATHER I WANTED TO COMMENT
THAT. WE ARE PARTICIPANTS IN
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
WE'RE FORTUNATE WE DIDN'T MAKE
THE FIRST ARE PART OF THE
LOTTERY BUT WE ARE ABLE TO BE
PART OF THE SECOND ROUND OF THE
LOTTERY. IN THIS IS JANUARY
THE SUBJECT COMMUNITY PROGRAM
AND THE REASON I WANT TO SHARE
THIS IS BECAUSE FOR US. AS A
DIRECTOR BURGEONING SHARED IT
MADE A HUGE WORLD THE
DIFFERENCE IT GIVES CHOICE IT
GIVES FLEXIBILITY GIVE US
CONTROL. THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
DO THAT WE NEEDED. OUR FAMILIES
THAT WE WORK WITH ESPECIALLY
THE ONES IMPACTED BY
DISPARITIES ARE ALSO LOOKING
FOR THAT CHOICE. WITH A
FLEXIBILITY FOR THAT CONTROL IN
MANY OF THE PARTICIPANTS WERE
LOOKING TO COME ON BOARD. AS OF
JUNE SEVENTH IF THAT IS THE
DATE THAT THE ARM. THE LEVERAGE
SPECIAL GUEST. YOU WILL SEE. A
FULL TRANSITION OF THE
COMMUNITY COME IN. WE ARE
LOOKING TO BE ABLE TO GO BEYOND
THE CURRENT LIMITATIONS AND
BARRIERS THAT. SHOULD SELDOM
TERMINATION BE A RESTAURANT I
pCAN GUARANTEE YOU THERE WILL BE
A LONG RUNNING AROUND THE BLOCK
WAITED TO GET IN AND BE ABLE.
TO THANK YOU OF THE DEATH OF.
MOST OF THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
DISABILITY VOCE ONE SECOND WE
HAVE A DRINKING I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO IDENTIFY. ARE YOU
DOING SIR I DON'T KNOW MAYBE
I'VE I AM LET ME JUST TURN OFF
MY PHONE TO SEE IF IS THAT OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY HOPE THAT
THERE'S NO MORE DIGGING OKAY-
I'M VICE PRESIDENT DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED WHERE AN ADVOCACY
GROUP THAT'S DIRECTED BY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND FAMILIES
I'M ALSO THE CO FOUNDER OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S FUNDED
THROUGH THE DDS DISPARITY
CRACKED. UP PROGRAM THE ICC
HELPS FAMILIESNAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM AND WE BREAK OWN
BARRIERS ON THE PEER TO PEER
BASIS THROUGH A WHAT WE CALL
OUR COMMUNITY IN THINKING ABOUT
S. THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR THAT
I AM TESTIFYING ABOUT THE SAME
URGENT PROBLEMS AND DISPARITIES
THAT ARE FACING OUR COMMUNITY
AND OTHERS. I APPRECIATED THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO REPRESENT THE
VOICE OF OUR COMMUNITY. I WAS
ASKED TO ADDRESS WHETHER DDS
FUNDED PROJECTS TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES HAVE BEEN MAKING
THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE. BASED
ON THE DATA. IT CLEAR IT IS
CLEAR THAT THINGS ARE NOT
GETTING BETTER. AFTER FIVE
YEARS OF DISPARITY GRANTS
LATINOS ASIANS AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE STILL RECEIVING
FEWER SERVICES THAN WHITES AND
THE DISPARITIES CONTINUE TO
WORSEN. DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED ANALYZE THE MOST RECENT
DATA AND WE FOUND THAT PROFOUND
DISPARITIES STILL EXIST IN ALL
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS
PARTICULARLY WITH WHAT THE
LATINOS. FOR EXAMPLE. AFTER THE
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO
SPEND ON GROUNDS. INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT. DIRECTLY TO
REGIONAL CENTRES THERE WAS ONLY
THREE REGIONAL CENTERS OUT OF
THE TWENTY ONE. THAT PROVIDED
THE LATINOS HALF OF WHAT THE
WHITES RECEIVED ONLY HALF. AN
ALL THE OTHERS PROVIDED LESS IN
THAT HOUSE. NOW WE HEAR THAT
THE REASON IS PROBABLY BECAUSE
THE LATINO COMMUNITY TEACH OUR
CHILDREN. AT HOME INTO
ADULTHOOD. BUT EVEN WHEN YOU
COMPARE THE LATINO ADULTS WHO
WHY DID THOSE THAT ARE LIVING
AT HOME THE DISPARITIES REMAIN.
AND WHILE ASIANS AND AFRICANS
AMERICANS DON'T FACE THE SAME
LEVEL OF DISPARITIES THEY ARE
STILL FACING SIGNIFICANT
INEQUITIES ARE THE MEASURE ANY
MEASURE. MANY PEOPLE OF COLOR
CONTINUE TO REPORT FEELING
INTIMIDATED. AN OVERWHELMED BY
THE SYSTEM AND ARE SOMETIMES
THE WE'RE AFRAID TO SPEAK UP IN
FEAR RETALIATION WE NEED TO SEE
MORE OF A CULTURAL CHANGE AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER LEVEL. WE
SEE MORE OF A CULTURAL.
HUMILITY TO BE IMPLEMENTED. WE
DO NOT DENY THAT THE REAL BY A
SUCCESS WE NEED TO STOP
ATTRIBUTING DISPARITIES TO THE
ETHNIC CULTURES OF FAMILIES OR
THEIR LACK OF EDUCATION OR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE OF THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE WE MOVED WE NEED TO
MOVE INTO A CULTURE OF HUMILITY
EMPATHY OF THE ACCEPTANCE AND
SUPPORT. REGIONAL CENTERS NEED
TO MAKE A CONCENTRATED EFFORT
TO MEET FAMILIES WHERE THEY'RE
AT AT EVERY LEVEL. I WAS ALSO
ASKED TO COMMENT ON THE TWO NEW
PROPOSALS FROM THE GOVERNOR THE
FIRST IS TO FIND A ONE TIME
INDEPENDENT. EVALUATION ON THE
DISPARITY PROJECTS. THIS IS AN
ACTION THAT DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED HAS BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THIS
REQUEST AND WE SUPPORTED. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE EVALUATION BE
FROM THE COMMUNITIES
PERSPECTIVES. ABOUT THE
EVALUATORS MUST HAVE DIRECT
INDEPENDENT ACCESS TO THE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS PROJECTS.
MANY OF THE PROJECTS ARE NOT
RUN BY CBO'S BUT BY THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOT LED
BY PARENTS. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT THESE GET EVALUATED AS
WELL. THE PROPOSAL WAS TO SPEND
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ON THE COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM BASED IN THE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER. WHERE WE SEE
THE VALUE OF FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTRES WITHOUT A DOUBT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE PEER TO PEER
SUPPORT WOULD BE HELPFUL. WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH FAMILIES WILL
BE LIMITED. BECAUSE TRUE
COMMUNITY OUT REACH HAS TO BE
NEUTRAL AND UNBIASED MANY SEE
THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS AS
AN EXTENSION OF REGIONAL
CENTERS THE PROMOTER AND THE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS THAT THEY
REPRESENT THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE REGIONAL CENTERS
REACHING OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY. AND THAT LOYALTY IS
OFTEN PERCEIVED TO BE THE
SYSTEM THAT THEY REPRESENT. A
PROGRAM LIKE THE INTAKE OF O.
AS IN OTHERS ARE DESIGNED TO
OUT REACH INTO FROM THE COMMUTE
BACK INTO THE REGIONAL CENTER.
IT IS FROM FAMILIES
PERSPECTIVES FROM OUR ISSUES
ARE CHALLENGES IN OUR NEEDS. WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT IN ORDER
FOR THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM TO
SUCCEED TO ITS FULL POTENTIAL.
IT WILL REQUIRE COLLABORATION
TO INCLUDE CPOS. WHO ALREADY
HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST OF
RESPECT AND VALIDATION WITH
FAMILIES. DESPITE THE LACK OF
PROGRESS WE ARE HEADING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. IN IT COULD
REALLY PRODUCE A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE OUR COMMUNITY IS WAKING
UP AND OUR VOICES ARE BECOMING
MORE UNITED. MORE FAMILIES ARE
FEELING INFORMED AND EMPOWERED
BECAUSE F THE HARD WORK OF
THIS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE REALIZING
THAT EACH ONE OF US HAS TO BE
THE CHANGE BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
SO HARD TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM.
SO THE FAMILIES THEMSELVES IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS WILL
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE. WE CAN
ONLY HELP PEOPLE ONE BY ONE BUT
THERE ALSO NEEDS TO BE A SYSTEM
CHANGE AS WELL NOW WE KNOW THAT
THE DIRECTOR BARGE MAN AND HER
STAFF ARE COMMITTED TO MOVING
THE NEEDLE. IN SOME REGIONAL
STAFFS ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
US AS PARTNERS THERE IS STILL
SO MUCH WORK THIS NEEDS TO BE
DONE. TO SUCCESSFULLY WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED FAMILIES WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT WE NEED TO HOLD
HANDS AND EMPOWER THEM WE ALSO
LEARNED THAT EVERYONE MUST BE
EQUAL PARTNERS AT THE TABLE TO
HELP MAKE THE MANY CHANGES THAT
ARE STILL NEED TO. OUR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
WE THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR INPUT AND I'M
WONDERING IF- IF DIRECTOR
BARGER HAS ANY THOUGHTS OR
RESPONSES- TO MR GOMES. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK ITH MR GOMEZ AND MANY OF
THE OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND- THEIR PARTICIPATION NOT
ONLY IN OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE BUT IT'S
REALLY MORE. AN ORGANIC HAS
REALLY BEEN- KIND OF OUR STAR
IN IN MANY OF THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD- THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION AND DESIRE FROM
MR GOMEZ TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE- COMMITTEE NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM- LOCKED HANDS. WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
I IS ABSOLUTELY AN EXPECTATION
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE- SO THOSE
ARE HE THINGS THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO BUILD AND TO KIND OF
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND MAKING
SURE. THAT THERE IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT THE ONE OF
THE GREATEST OUTCOMES OF THE
ELEVEN MILLION OF KIND OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM. IS RAISING UP
THE FACE- AND THE VOICE OF OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED WITHIN OUR
NETWORK A REMARKABLE COMMUNITY
AND WE CAN'T WE CAN'T DO.
REALLY ANY OF THOSE WORK
WHETHER IT'S THAT COMMITTEE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM OR ANY OTHER
INITIATIVES WITHOUT THEM- AND I
REALLY HOPE WE BRING ON NEW
PARTNERS AS WELL YOU NEED TO
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE STILL
HAVE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
ARE NOT REPRESENTED IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT I REALLY BELIEVE WE NEED
TO BUILD BUILD UP IN OUR OUR
NETWORK AS WELL- CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE PANDEMIC OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THEIR ROLE IN DOING OUTREACH- A
DISTRIBUTING- PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT- DOING OUTREACH TO
GET INFORMATION- TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND GETTING FOOD TO
PEOPLE- WAS INVALUABLE AND WE
SEE A SIMILAR ROLE- RELATED TO.
THIS INITIATIVE AS WELL. THANK
YOU. OKAY GET THE YOU MISTER
MISTER GOMEZ A CERTAIN OUR STAR
BUT I BUT I WOULD OFFER THERE'S
A LOT OF STARS OUT NOTS GUY.
WHO WERE WHO ARE STAND READY
AND WILLING AND ABLE TO ASSIST
YOU AND JUST YOU KNOW I THINK
WE ALL THINK ABOUT FROM OUR OWN
PERSPECTIVE OUR OWN WORLD I CAN
CERTAINLY THINK AND IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY. IT'S A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION. WORKING
WITH LATINO COMMUNITY IN THE
API I. AFRICAN COMMUNITY ARE
OUT THERE MAKING SURE PEOPLE
GET TO MAKING SURE PEOPLE HAVE
FOOD AND DIAPERS AND
VACCINATIONS AND TRANSPORTATION
SO- RIGHT IT IS NOT IT IS NOT
US IS THE GOVERNMENT WAS OUT
THERE DOING IT IT IS OUR
PARTNERS WHO ARE DOING THAT
WORK. ENOUGH AND CERTAINLY
WOULD APPRECIATE ANY I THINK
ANY EXTRA GRANTS ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COME THEIR
WAY. TO CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING THAT BEST
A RELATIONSHIP THEY ALREADY
HAVE ESTABLISHED SO. I LOOK
FORWARD IN HEARING HOW WE'RE
PROGRESSING IN THAT JOINING OF
HANDS GOING FORWARD. I MAY NOT
ENSURE JUST ADD ONE TO YOUR
POINTS- AND THAT IS REALLY THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT FORWARD
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
HAD. AND PARTICIPATING IN THE
GRANT PROGRAM. IS THAT'S WHY
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT
FORWARD IS ACTUALLY OUTSIDE OF
THE GRANT PROGRAM. BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY FROM
ANY OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE THEIR
GOOD WORK AND EVEN- ENHANCE-
AND IT JUST ALL AREAS THE THANK
YOU. THAT'S GREAT AND I WOULD.
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE YOU'RE
ALREADY DOING THIS BUT IT WOULD
BE SOME KIND OF PARTICIPATORY
EVALUATION THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD BRING AND ALL ARE. ALL
OUR NORTH STARS. LOL AS YOUR
HAND UP- THANK YOU MANAGER
SYMPATHETIC FROM THE L. A. O.
AND- JUST HEAD TO UNDERSCORE
THE LAST COMMENT THAT WAS THAT
YOU JUST MADE ACTUALLY- WE JUST
HAVE- ONE RECOMMENDATION OR
SUGGESTION IN THIS AREA WHICH
IS TO REALLY ENSURE SO WE THE
MINISTRATION DISCUSSED- THE
BILL THE WAY IN WHICH IT WILL
EVALUATE. THE PAST GRANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO REDUCE
DISPARITIES IN WE WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF A
FORMAL EVALUATION OF THIS NEW.
STATEWIDE EFFORT IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO APPROVE
FUNDING FOR THE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM. YOU'LL BE
THE FIRST TIME THERE WAS A
STATEWIDE EFFORTS- IN THE DDS
DEPARTMENT IN IN THE
DISPARITIES AREA. AND IT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT TO HAVE REALLY A
FORMAL EVALUATION OF ITS-
EFFECTIVENESS. AND TO DO THAT
IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE BEST TO
REALLY BUILD IN THE NECESSARY
DESIGN FEATURES AND
MEASUREMENTS- AD METRICS REALLY
FROM THAT FROM THE OUTSET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
WAS UP. WHO'S GOING TO ASK THAT
THAT IT IN IN MY EXPERIENCE
THAT WE GENERALLY I MEAN THE
BEST PROJECTS HAVE THE
EVALUATION BUILT INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE PLANNING.
OF IT SO YOU CAN WRAP YOUR ARMS
AROUND FROM THE BEGINNING AND
DON'T GO OFF IN A DIRECTION
THAT YOU HAVEN'T. FIGURED OUT A
WAY TO MEASURE SO I WOULD- I
WOULD CONCUR THAT THE
EVALUATION PLAN NEEDS TO BE
PART OF. THE BEGINNING. A
DEPEND. I THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH AND I DO I KNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE- APARTMENT GETTING
BACK ON THE NUMBER OF VISITORS
TO THE WEB PAGE AS WE VAST- A
FIRST QUESTION ACTUALLY FOR. MR
GOMEZ. WITH THE DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED- THANK YOU YOU
MADE REFERENCE IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TO INTIMIDATION THIS
IS SOMETHING I ALSO HEARD
SEVERAL YEARS AGO- CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON ON ON THIS PROBLEM
ABOUT. FAMILIES OF COLOR
FEELING INTIMIDATED.
ABSOLUTELY- THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN- WITH THE QUESTION IN
ADDITION TO THAT INTIMIDATION
HAND IN HAND GOES WHAT WE CALL
THE CULTURAL HUMILITY IN MANY
CASES WERE FINDING OUT THAT- A
LOT OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD
WHETHER THERE'S INTERACTION
WITH OUR FAMILIES WE'RE SEEING
THAT THAT THIS IS NOT A
PRACTICE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF TIMES. FAMILIES THEY FEEL
ARE ARE DOWN TO THEY THEY STILL
MADE A FAIRER- AND IT'S ALREADY
A REALLY COMPLICATED SYSTEM TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH. AND WHEN A
PARENT DOES. FEEL EMPOWERED AND
GETS TO A POINT WHERE THERE ARE.
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS THEN
A LOT OF TIMES THEY FEEL THAT
STRONG PUSHBACK IN IN IN ITS
PERCEIVED AS IN DATA
INTIMIDATION. IN MANY CASES-
THAT PUSHBACK IS AUTOMATICALLY
SENT THROUGH TO WHAT THEY CALL
IT A FAIR HEARING WHICH- WOULD
PROBABLY THIS THERE'S NOTHING
FAIR ABOUT A FAIR HEARING WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR COMMUNITY. OKAY
ALL RIGHT I APPRECIATE THE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT- YOU KNOW I
IF IT THINK- APPRECIATE THIS-
PROPOSAL- THAT'S FOR US AND
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM SOME THE
PREVIOUS PROJECTS- BUT I THINK
I KNOW THAT- ADDRESS BAR
TONIGHT'S HATS MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE THIS ISSUE SPEND LONG
STANDING UP BEFORE I EVEN WAS
ON THE SUB COMMITTEE WE WERE
DEALING WITH THAT AND WE'VE
BEEN DEALING. FOR MANY YEARS- I
GUESS YOU KNOW WHAT WELL ONE OF
THE- AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE
HAVE GRANTS WE HAVE PROGRAMS I
THINK ONE THINGS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE- IS ABOUT ALSO
CHANGING THE CULTURE WITHIN.
THE THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND SO
FORTH- AS WELL SO IT'S MORE- TO
TRY TO MAKE IT MORE WELCOMING
FOR PEOPLE- FOR AGAIN- FAMILIES
OF COLOR AND AGAIN THE
DISPARITY STILL PERSIST I
APPRECIATE I HEAR APPROVED
MEANT I HAVEN'T HEARD MAGNITUDE
SO- SO I'VE HEARD WHAT I'VE
HEARD SOME TESTIMONY SAYING
THAT THINGS HAVE. GONE THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THAT'S ALWAYS
GOOD BUT WE HAVEN'T HEARD
MAGNITUDE OF THE MOVE LIKE SO.
AND WE'RE HEARING TESTIMONY
FROM DISBELIEF VOICES UNITED
THAT ACTUALLY THE MOVEMENT
ISN'T ALL THAT GREAT- SO IN
ADDITION TO PROGRAMS ARE UNDER
STANDARDS ARE BEING PUT IN
PLACE FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY PASSED A
LAW SAYING THAT- BOARDS-
CORPORATE BOARDS SHOULD HAVE.
AT LEAST SOME REPRESENTATION
OF- YOU KNOW OF THIS VENTURE
YEAH PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES UNDER CORPORATE
BOARDS. YOU THINK THAT REGIONAL
CENTER SHOULD TO DO EVEN MORE
THAN A CORPORATE BOARD SHOULD.
SO ARE THEIR STANDARDS FOR-
DIVERSITY ON THE BOARDS OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND ALSO
STAFF- TO THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS SET OR- OR THAT-
IT THAT'S BEING SET. TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE- IT MORE.
BASICALLY SURE WE A- VOICES IN
THE GOVERNANCE OF- THESE VERY
IMPORTANT THAT INSTITUTIONS.
THANK YOU DR PAN- CURRENTLY
THERE IS AND HAS BEEN- GOSH I
CAN'T REMEMBER A TIME WHEN IT
WAS- BROUGHT INTO TWO LOTS BEEN
MANY MANY MANY YEARS- THAT THAT
THE BOARDS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE TO REPRESENT THEIR
COMMUNITY- SO THAT DIVERSITY
AND WE TRACK AS A DEPARTMENT WE
TRACKED THAT BY- AND YOUR
REVIEW- AND REQUIRE REGIONAL
CENTERS IF THEY ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE- BUT WITH- THE
DIVERSITY OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN ON
HOW TO ACHIEVE- TO ACHIEVE THAT.
IN ADDITION- RECENTLY SOME OF
THE OTHER- AREAS IN WHICH WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BOARD WAS INFORMED OF THESE
ISSUES IS THAT IF IT WASN'T
LAST YEAR IS THAT PRIOR YEAR-
WE HAD PROPOSED AND THERE IS
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE- THAT WAS
WAS ADDED. ON TO REQUIRE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO- PRESENT TO
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS THEIR-
DISPARITY KIND OF- THAT THE
INFORMATION AND- THEIR
PROPOSALS AND THEIR PLANS
BEFORE SUBMITTING TO THE
DEPARTMENT. IS WE REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BOARDS
ALSO HAD AN INCREASED
AWARENESS. OF THE- THE
INFORMATION THAT THE COMMUNITY
IS SHARING- WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER AS WELL AS THEIR DATA
RELATED TO PURCHASE OF SERVICE-
WE ALSO IN ADDITION BECAUSE-
BEING. A MISTER GOMEZ AND
OTHERS HAVE SHARED- THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE- ACCESS OR THE-
FAIRNESS BE KIND OF APPROACH TO
FAIR HEARINGS AND THAT IS THE-
DUE PROCESS THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM HAS AND THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE AREAS THAT I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR- SERVICE
ACCESS AND EQUITY WORKGROUP AND
EVALUATE. YOU KNOW IS THERE-
ALTERNATIVES- THAT WE COULD-
HAVE AVAILABLE TO- PROVIDE A
REVIEW- UNDER DUE PROCESS AND-
BECAUSE THOSE ARE CERTAINLY
ISSUES THE CULTURE- WE
PRIORITIZED- DISPARITY- GRANTS
WE WANTED TO HAVE CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY AND- TRAINING-
WITHIN THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS- THIS IS AN
AREA THAT I THINK WE CAN DO
MORE- WE'VE WE HAVE BEEN TAKING
A LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENCE- CAN I TRAININGS
THAT HAVE. REALLY POSITIVE KIND
OF OUTCOMES AND IMPACT WHETHER
IT'S IMPLICIT BIAS OR CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY- SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPLORING- THERE WAS. ALSO.
THAT THE STANDARD INFORMATION
PACKETS- THAT WE INTRODUCED-
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
FAMILIES HAVE SHARED- EVEN
ENTERING INTO THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM IS THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO THE
SAME INFORMATION WHICH AN
INCREASE DISPARITIES- SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
WERE INTRODUCED IN THAT WE'RE
IN THE FINAL STAGES OF HAVING-
THAT. AVAILABLE AS WELL- AND I
HAD ONE FINAL THOUGHT AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT IT'S LESLIE SAID
IT TAKEN NOTE- MAYBE SOMETHING
TRIGGER AND I'LL CIRCLE BACK
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON IT. OKAY
SHE US- I US SEEM LIKE A- AGAIN-
MAY THE STAFF ARE REALLY- IT I
THINK THAT- YOU WE'VE WE'VE
TOUCHED ON THESE BEFORE WHEN WE
HAD AND OUR CONVERSATIONS I
THINK. GOT THIS POINT TWO OR
THREE YEARS AGO. ANDTALKED
ABOUT THE NEED FOR A CULTURAL
CHANGE- WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF- AB AND APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION TO HAVE SOME
REPORT ON SOME UNKNOWN WHERE WE
ARE WITH THE AMPLE ARE. ALL
OUR- REGIONAL CENTERS THAT THEY
HAD TO DIVERSITY PARK IT'S WHAT
ARE TODAY IT'S ADDRESS SO- AND
ALSO IN TERMS OF OUR STAFFING
AS WELL. SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS DEPARTMENT IS MAKING
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS
THAT- WE'VE TALKED ABOUT-
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND I.
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION SHOWS
THAT YOU'RE FOLLOWING THROUGH
ON THIS- WELL WE STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO AND I THINK AND
CERTAINLY DON'T WANTTO
UNDERMINE THE- PROJECTS ARE
BEING PROPOSED BUT I THINK WAS
WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE.
PROJECTS ARE GREAT BUT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE ITSELF OF THE
INSTITUTION OTHERWISE- YOU
KNOW- HERE'S YOUR PROJECT OVER
HERE SO- THE DM EVALUATION
CERTAINLY'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT
AS WELL- AND- SO- IT AGAIN
LOOKING FORWARD TO- FOLLOWING
UP ON. ON THE PROGRESS THAT'S
BEING MADE THAT- THAT. THAT
YOU'VE DISCUSSED SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND INDIRECT BORDER-
THERE ARE CALLED. SPECIALIST AT
EACH SHOW REGIONAL. AND A THEY
GOING IN ON ON THE- GROUND THE
CLIMATE IF YOU WERE. OF THE
BEACH REGIONAL AND PER. INPUT
AND- HELP. YEAH THERE IF WE DO-
WE FIND IT. MITCHELL SPECIALIST
AND EVERY REGIONAL CENTER- AS
AS MR DRIPPING ED NOTED AND
THEN ALSO THE DEPARTMENTS- WE
HAVE AN APARTMENT ALSO BRING
TOGETHER THE CULTURAL
SPECIALIST I REALLY PLEASED
WITH OUR REORGANIZATION WHICH
MR WINFIELD HAD TALKED ABOUT A
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC BUT
ONE OF THE AREAS IN WHICH WE
WERE ABLE TO ALSO ENHANCES THE
DEPARTMENT- WAS ADDING A COUPLE
POSITIONS TO OUR SERVICE ACCESS
AND EQUITY- OFFICE. AND THIS
TEAM HAS ABSOLUTELY PULL
TOGETHER AND OF AN ORGANIZED
APPROACH NOT ONLY WORKING WITH
A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- BUT ALSO HAVING
REGULAR MEETINGS AND TRAININGS
WITH THE CULTURAL SPECIALIST AT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS. I'M SO
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS COULD
HAVE CERTAINLY ORGANIZED- THOSE
EFFORTS- BUT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE AND REALLY PLEASED THAT-
THE POSITIONS ARE THERE AND
PLEASE THAT- MAY NOT A WALTER
IS ORGANIZING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SOME CONTINUITY IN
TRAINING- THAT IS ALSO IN
COLLABORATION. WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AND IS A
THE FEE GO WAYS LIKE WITH THE
NOW. IN THE PROMO THE LAST
DIGIT MEAN THERE YOU'RE
REACHING OUT TO TED. FAMILIES
ARE THEY ALSO TAKE OUT OF. BACK
TO. THE AIRFORCE IN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ABOUT THE
BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE MIGHT BE
REPORTING WHY THEY DON'T REACH
OUT. I'LL HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT TO WHAT DEGREE- I'M INCLINED
TO SAY THAT IN SOME WAYS
THERE'S REALLY STRONG KIND OF.
HERE COMMUNICATION THAT IS
DEFINITELY HAPPENING BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WHERE THERE'S A REAL
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN-
THE CBO'S OR THE FRC'S IN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS- BUT I THINK
THAT THERE'S YOU KNOW SOME
AREAS WHERE THERE THERE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE SOME RELATIONSHIPS
THAT THAT. NEED TO BE ENHANCED
AND- HEELS YOU KNOW AND ADDS
THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
SOME TRUST ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE OVERCOME WE HAVE SOME WORK
IN THAT DEPARTMENT THAT WE NEED
TO DO- BUT SO I WOULD SAY THAT
WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A MIX
OF BOTH. AND AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR- SOME GROWTH. MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN STANDARDIZE
GOING FORWARD. IF YOU. OKAY
ANYTHING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ON THIS BEFORE WE MOVE
ON. TO BINANCE NOTHING AT OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU- THAT INTERNET
DEPARTMENT- I GONNA GO AHEAD
AND HAVE- ACRYLIC HALF NATIVE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
TRAILER BILL AND THEN ALL-
ADDRESS THAT THAT NEXT COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS AND CLOSING OUT
THE AGENDA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR SIMILAR. THANK YOU BECAUSE
THE OTHER WITH THE DEPARTMENT-
TRAILER ITEMS IT REFLECTS TO
ISSUES THE FIRST ONE IS THE
ACUTE CRISIS CLARIFICATION AND
MISSION EXTENSION. THIS
LANGUAGE EXTENDS THE
AVAILABILITY OF CANYON SPRINGS
FOR THE STABILIZATION TRAINING
ASSISTANCE AND REINTEGRATION
SERVICES WHILE ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUES. IT ALSO PROVIDES
CLARIFICATION FOR ADMISSION TO
KEEP PRICES PROGRAMS AND
APPROVED BY THE DIRECTOR FOR
PLACEMENTS TO THE PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY IT PROVIDES IF YOU
CLEAN UP REFERENCES TO
CINEMATOGRAPHY DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS. THE SECOND TRAILER
ISSUE IS FACILITIES FOR SPECIAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE REMOVES THE
RESTRICTION FOR DEVELOPMENT AND
USE OF THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
ASSOCIATED WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER CLOSURE. IT AUTHORIZES
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A SIMILAR
MODEL FOR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
HEALTH CARE NEEDS. THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO
TRANSITION INDIVIDUALS FROM OR
AVOID EACH. PLACEMENT IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WERE
LARGE CONGREGATE SETTINGS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DIRECTOR MARJORIE WANNA PICK UP
FROM THERE YES PLEASE THANK
YOU- SO I'VE BEEN- ASKED TO
ADDRESS. TWO OTHER QUESTIONS-
ONE IS TO- FURTHER DISCUSS KIND
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND THOSE REALLY
EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH NEED.
PARTICULARLY INDIVIDUALS WITH
CHALLENGING I'M KIND OF
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT NEEDS AS
WELL AS HEALTH CARE NEEDS- WE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON OUR SAFETY
NET FOR THE LAST- PAST FIVE
YEARS AT LEAST YOU KNOW SINCE%
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE CLOSURE
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
THEN. WITH THE CLOSURE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS- WEDID
HAVE A NEED TO KIND OF BUILD
THE COMMUNITY CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WITH VERY
HIGHLY COMPLEX NEEDS- JUST AS A
QUICK UPDATE OR ENHANCE IT.
ENHANCE VEHICLE SUPPORTS HOMES
WHICH WAS NEARED AFTER THE
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
FOR PERSONS WITH SPECIAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS- WE HAVE FORTY OF
THOSE HOMES THAT ARE COMPLETED
WE HAVE THIRTY SEVEN AND
PROGRESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
MORE RECENTLY WE HAD A SORORITY
TO DEVELOP COMMITTEE CRISIS
HOMES FOR ADULTS- WE HAVE
THIRTEEN OF THOSE THAT ARE
COMPLETED AND THEN WE HAVE NINE
AM PROGRESS AGAIN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- AND- IN. THE LAST
YEAR WE ALSO RECEIVED AUTHORITY
TO DEVELOP- COMMITTEE CRISIS
HOMES FOR CHILDREN- WE HAD
PRIOR APPROVAL FOR ADULTS AS I
JUST NOTED- AND THEN ALSO PRIOR
APPROVAL FOR THE ENHANCE BUREAU
SUPPORTS HOMES FOR KIDS- WE
HAVE FOUND THAT WHERE ARE
EMERGING NEEDS PRIMARILY IS
WITH CHILDREN. ADOLESCENTS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN- WE WERE SEEN
VERY CALM NEEDS PARTICULARLY.
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE AUTISM
AND CO OCCURRING NEEDS BUT THEN
ALSO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DEVELOPED DEVELOPER THE
DISABILITY AND CO OCCURRING
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS- SO FOR
CHILDREN WE HAVE SEVEN HOMES
THAT ARE IN PROGRESS FOR
COMMUNITY CRISIS- AND THESE
WOULD BE INTENDED TO BE TIME
LIMITED WITH THE INTENT. OF
HAVING KIDS GO BACK HOME- IT IT
DEFINITELY IS INTENDED TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER-
AND THEN NAY ENHANCE BIRO
SUPPORTS HOMES WEEK WE HAVE
SEVEN THAT ARE COMPLETE AND WE
HAVE NINE IN PROGRESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND THIS
KIND OF LEADS TO. SOME OF THE
WORK THAT- IS NOTED I CANYON
SPRINGS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO
EXTEND THAT SUNSET- AND IT WAS
PURPOSEFULLY KIND OF PUT IN
THERE WHEN- THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED- PARTICULARLY-BECAUSE- YOU KNOW. OUR
EVERYBODY OUR EFFORTS AND
CERTAINLY ADVOCATES HAD HAD
REALLY NOTED THAT DID NOT WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE INDIVIDUALS
IN LARGER CONGREGATE SETTINGS
THAT REALLY HAVING. KIND OF
THOSE STARS SERVICES THAT ARE
IN THE COMMUNITY WITH FOUR OR
FIVE INDIVIDUALS- MORE MUCH
MORE ADEPT TO A HOME LIKE
SETTING- THAT SAID WE'VE HAD
SOME CHALLENGES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE. OF A
TORTILLA I BELIEVE IT'S- A
TOTAL OF. SEVEN HOMES THAT WE
CAN HAVE IN THE STATE OF OUR
START- SERVICES. ONE OF THE
HOMES- WE HAD REPORTED- WE HAVE
THREE HOMES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE BEFORE
INDIVIDUALS HAD MOVED IN WHICH
WAS. FOR ADOLESCENTS HAD BURNED
DOWN. AND THIS WAS A REAL BIG.
STEP FOR US IT WAS ONLY A MONTH
AWAY. FROM BEING ABLE PROVIDE
SERVICES- IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
FOR THE TWO HOMES THAT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED IN THAT AREA
FORTUNATELY WE'RE ABLE TO.
TEMPORARILY PROVIDE SERVICES
OVER AT PORTER BILLS-
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER- FOR
ADOLESCENTS NOT IDEAL STUDYING
WE REALLY WANT TO GET THEM INTO
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. THE
MARKET RIGHT NOW IS ABSOLUTELY
INSANE FOR HOUSING- HOUSES ARE
YOU KNOW BEFORE AND HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE GETTING OFFERS
AND- THE HOUSES ARE ARE GOING
OFF THE MARKET SO THERE'S A
UNIQUE CHALLENGE THAT THAT-
WE'RE FACING- PARTICULAR WITH
THAT- AND THEN ALSO WITH OUR
TWO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOMES
THAT- WILL NOW BE READY IN THE
NEXT MONTH OR TWO. WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN THAT AREA
BECAUSE OF KOBE IS. A PART OF
THAT HAD TO DO WITH PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO GO OUT A PLEA TO
UNDO THE CONSTRUCTION ARE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE PERMITTING- BUT
BECAUSE OF THESE UNFORTUNATE
DELAYS WE ARE ASKING FOR THIS
EXTENSION THESE ARE SERVICES
THAT ARE NEEDED- AND- AGAIN-
IDENTIFYING A PARTICULAR NEED
FOR CHILDREN- WE- WE ARE SEEN.
WE HAVE FOR OUR STAR SERVICES I
HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN KIDS ON THE
WAIT LIST FOR OUR KIDS
SERVICES- WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO- WORK WITH OUR OUR-
CHILDREN'S FACILITIES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN WHAT ARE
START TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THAT. BUT IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY AT- CANYON SPRINGS
THAT WOULD- PROBABLY REDUCE.
OUR ABILITY TO SERVE ON SOME OF
THE GREATEST. NEEDS IN
CALIFORNIA AT THIS POINT. HAPPY
TO ANSWER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. STEVEN
PUBLIC WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR
NOT AT. MISSPELLING THE THING
TO ADD EITHER YOU. HI THE PLAN.
ALL RIGHT FROM A LOT OF
PLANNING GOING FORWARD A LOT OF
PLANNING WE HAVE TO DO AND
COMPREHENSIVE RIGHT I MEAN I
KNOW WE'RE IN A PANDEMIC BUT
COMPREHENSIVELY. YOU GUYS MAKE
ME THINK ABOUT MY RETIREMENT
PLAN WE NEED TO GET OUT TO
THESE REGIONAL CENTERS. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- I BELIEVE THIS THEN
CONCLUDES THE DEPARTMENT
PRESENTATIONS. AND I THINK THIS
PRODUCT ARE YOU GONNA BE DOING
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ARE GOING
OVER OUR- POSTAL'S. YES MADAM
CHAIR- YOUR STAFF HAS REQUESTED
THAT WE READ THROUGH THE TWELVE
DIFFERENT- STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS THAT WERE PROPOSED TO
TAKE TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
SO YES YOU'RE READY I CAN GO
AHEAD AND DO WHAT I DON'T IT
JUST FOR MY PURPOSES PERHAPS
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT A
THREE MINUTE RECESS HELLO GET A
DRINK OF WATER AND COME BACK AS
A OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH A RECESS
FOR THREE MINUTES.
WE WILL. RE
COMMENCE WITH THE WITH OUR
HEARING. WITH MISS PATRICK-
GOING OVER THE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. BACK IN
SESSION. IT RESPECT I'M SURE
ASSEMBLY PETTIT FROM THE L. A.
O. AND AS NOTED PREVIOUSLY I
WILL JUST BE READING- THE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED BY STAKEHOLDERS TO
YOUR SUB COMMITTEE SO THE FIRST
IS IMPROVING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION PROPOSES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION
FORTY EIGHT SEVENTY TO INCREASE
UTILIZATION OF THE FUNDS SET
ASIDE FOR THE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. AND INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
FOR PROVIDERS TO PLACE
INDIVIDUALS INTO COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS EQUITY
EQUITABLE RATE ADJUSTMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO STATE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES. THE LOS ANGELES
COALITION OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITIES
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
REQUEST THIRTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION. SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE RATE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN RESPONSE TO STATE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES. THE
THIRD ISSUE CONTINUE THE
SUSPENSION OF THE FAMILY
HOSTAGE PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AN ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM FEET.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO AMEND WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTIONS
FORTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE AND
FORTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TO
CONTINUE THE SUSPENSION OF THE
FAMILY COST PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM AN ANNUAL FAMILY
PROGRAM FEET. THE FOURTH ISSUE
IS CONTINUE VIRTUAL INSTRUMENT
ACT IN PERSON MEETINGS
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO AMEND WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION FORTY
SIX FORTY SIX. AND GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION. NINE FIVE ZERO
TWO ZERO TO CONTINUE TO WAIVE
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR IN PERSON
SERVICE COORDINATION MEETINGS.
THE FIFTH ISSUE CONTINUE
REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTOR
APPROVAL OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS EXEMPTIONS. DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTIONS FORTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
POINT SIX FORTY SIX EIGHTY NINE
POINT EIGHT AND FORTY SIX
NINETY ONE POINT NINE TO ALLOW
REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTORS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS. ISSUE SIX CARDIFF
IDEAS CORRECT NINETEEN
DIRECTIVES RELATED TO
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO CODIFY IN EXISTING DIRECTIVE
TO ALLOW CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES
TO UTILIZE THE FLEXIBILITY
OFFERED BY PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
DIRECTED SERVICES. ISSUE SEVEN
CARDIFF IDEAS CODE NINETEEN
DIRECTIVES RELATED TO EARLY
START REMOTE SERVICES.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO AMENDED GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION. NINE FIVE ZERO TWO
ZERO TWO CODIFIED EXISTING
DIRECTED TO WAIVE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR IN PERSON
SERVICES FOR THE EARLY START
PROGRAM. IF YOU EIGHT REMOVE
THE PROHIBITION ON SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS
WHO CHOOSE TO LIVE AT HOME WITH
FAMILY. DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA PROPOSES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE FORTY SIX
EIGHTY NINE TO REMOVE THE
PROHIBITION ON SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES FOR ADULT CONSUMERS
WHO LIVE AT HOME WITH THEIR
PARENTS OR CONSERVATORS. ISSUE
NUMBER NINE REQUIRE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO SECURE OR FUND
CRITICAL GENERIC RESOURCES TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY AND HARMFUL
DELAYS. DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA PROPOSES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTIONS
FORTY SIX FIFTY NINE POINT FIVE
AND FORTY SIX FIFTY NINE POINT
SEVEN TO REQUIRE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO SECURE OR FUND
CRITICAL GENERIC SERVICES.
ISSUE TEN DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SUSTAINABILITY THE
ARCTIC AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION REQUESTS THE
REMOVAL REMOVAL OF BUDGET
LANGUAGE THAT SUSPENDS
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET. ISSUE ELEVEN DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DIRECTOR DISCRETION MISTER
LESSER RODIN REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION
FORTY FIVE NINETEEN TO GIVE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DDS THE ABILITY
TO APPLY THEIR DISCRETION ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS TO ALLOW FOR
THE PROVISION OR EXTENSION OF
OUT OF STATE SERVICES FOR MORE
THAN SIX MONTHS WHEN SUPPORTED
BY A COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT.
AND THE FINAL ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE REGIONAL CENTER CASE
WOULD REACH YOUR NEEDS. THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES AND S. C. ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA REQUEST FIFTY FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE
MATCHED WITH TWENTY EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
I'M GOING TO HIRE ENOUGH
SERVICE COORDINATORS TO MEET
STATUTORY CASELOAD RATIO
TARGETS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT READING
WHOSE WORK VERY NICELY DONE.
OKAY IF NOTHING ON THIS I
BELIEVE WE WILL MOVE TO CALLS.
SO MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES
MADAM CHAIR OKAY SO FIRST LET
ME SAY THAT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE ARE ANY- PEOPLE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE. ALL RIGHT SO
THEN WE WILL GO BACK TO THE
CALL LINE. I CAN FIND MY PLACE.
IN THE AGENDA. TO READ THE
NUMBER AGAIN UNLESS YOU HAVE
THAT HANDY MISTER MODERATOR.
YES UP FOLKS ARE IT'S ONE ZERO
TO COMMENT OVER THE PHONE RIGHT.
OKAY AND THE PHONE NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE HELLO AGAIN ASK THAT
YOU MUTE YOUR PHONE OR YOUR
DEVICE THAT YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS ON. WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE AND PERTINENT TO THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY. FIRST CALLER PLEASE. WE
DO HAVE SOME ACTIVITY WE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
HOUSE ACTIVITY
MR MODERATOR. FOLKS ARE STILL
QUEUING UP AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO QUEUE UP FOR
OUR COMMENTS.
APPROACH FOR THE
MODERATOR Q. ONE UP SO. WE NEED
TO MAKE TIVITY OR I WILL TAKE.
THE IF YOU'RE NOT PREPARED TO
MAKE COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
WHICH IS FINE YOU CAN ALWAYS
EMAIL THE COMMITTEE. THESE ARE
SOME OF YOUR OTHER ISSUE BESIDE
SHYNESS MISTER MODERATOR. WE TO
HAVE SOMEONE WITH AN OPERATOR
DOWN WILL BE JUST A MOMENT OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
FIRST RETURN TO THE LINE
OF ROOM A RATHER LINE TWO ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
HAVE A GOOD ATTITUDE ATTITUDE
ATTITUDE ATTITUDE ATTITUDE
ATTITUDE. MISTER MODERATOR.
MA'AM YOU SOMEBODY YOU NEED TO
ME YOUR PHONE OR YOUR DEVICE.
PERHAPS YOU RE QUEUE. YES AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE DAY ZERO TWO
Q. A FOLKS. IN RETURN FULLER
LINE OF- ONE NINE FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
DEBBIE MARSTELLER WITH PROJECT
WILL DEPEND ON WHEN ORANGE
COUNTY FOR BY REGIONAL CENTER
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT WE'VE
GOTTEN THROUGH THIS LAST YEAR.
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
NEED FOR MODERNIZE GOING HEY
FOR DIRECT SERVICE STAFF.
ESPECIALLY THE X. FROM THE
VARIANT LIKE ORANGE COUNTY IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT. WE MODERNIZE
THE PAY AND- I RECOGNIZE THAT
PEOPLE ARE HARD WORKING HIGHLY
SKILLED AND COMPLETELY CRUCIAL
THE ABILITY OF VENDORS TO
PROVIDE QUALITY SERVICES IF WE
CAN WE MUST ALWAYS SITS ON
AVERAGE AND THAT OUR STAFF SO
WE'RE- MAKING MINIMUM WAGE-
FOUR YEARS AGO HAVE NOW BEEN
STAGNATING. BECAUSE IF WE DON'T.
AT MINIMUM WAGE THEN WE DO NOT
BENEFIT FROM THE ABILITY TO.
ADDRESS FOR MINIMUM WAGES
BECAUSE THAT SO IT'S BEEN A-
IT'S PROBLEMS IN MAINTAINING
STAFF AND WITHOUT THEM WE DO
NOT HAVE SERVICES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE
MODERATOR. THANK YOU NEXT
RETURNED TO LIGHT A ROOM RATHER
LINE TWO ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOYCE CLARK AND I AM
A PARENT THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD
SON WHO A SERVER THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES I'M HERE TO ADDRESS
THE TOPIC ON SELF DETERMINATION
I JUST REALLY WANT TO.
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PROGRAM IT IS
ESSENTIAL THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS TO REALLY CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT HAS MEANING AND
EFFECTIVENESS FOR THEM. WE WERE
FORTUNATE TO BE SELECTED IN THE
ROLL OUT AND IT DID TAKE US
SOME TIME TO GET ON BOARD WITH
THE PROGRAM THE- PANDEMIC
CERTAINLY PUT A- HOLD ON MANY
THINGS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MY SON'S THIRTY TWO YEARS. I
WOULD SAY WE HAVE FINALLY
DEVELOPED A PROGRAM THAT HAS
FULL MEANING FOR HIM HE'S DOING
THE THINGS THAT HE WANTED TO
DO. IT SPENT MANY YEARS
ADVOCATING FOR INCLUSION AND
SELF DETERMINATION ALL OF THESE
KINDS OF THINGS AND I WOULD
REALLY HATE TO SEE IT DELAYED
ANY FURTHER. AS A MATTER OF
FACT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT FOR
WHAT IT IN OPEN BECAUSE I DO
THINK THIS IS THE ANSWER TO THE
ISSUES- THAT ARE OCCURRING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THE PANDEMIC AN IMMEDIATE.
IMPORTANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
CHOICE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
PUT OUT A PLUG INTO THAT WE
WERE FORTUNATE HERE IN SAN
DIEGO WE DID HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF OUR REGIONAL CENTER. AND
ALSO THAT THIS GIVES- SERVICE
COORDINATORS AND OUR SYSTEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EMPOWER THEM TO
REALLY HELP SUPPORT CLIENTS
THAT DO NOT NECESSARILY SAID IN
A ONE SIZE. FITS ALL PROGRAM.
AND LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT. SELF DETERMINATION IS NOT
A NEW SERVICE IT HAS A TWENTY
ONE YEAR HISTORY IN THE FIELD
ACROSSTHE STRAIT PLEASE DON'T
MAKE FAMILIES WAIT. AN
INDIVIDUAL PLAYED ANY LONGER
TO. CUSTOMIZE SERVICES THAT
THEY- SO DESPERATELY NEED AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO MY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND RETURNED TO LIGHT
OF ONE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS PAULINE
CATCHER DORIAN AND I'M THE
PARENT OF A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
LANTERN AND REGIONAL CENTER I
CANNOT IMPRESS UPON YOU HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR SERVICE
COORDINATORS AT A REGIONAL
CENTERS. THEY'RE WORTH THEIR
WEIGHT IN GOLD BUT MAY HAVE
BEEN NUMEROUS TIMES AND WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN AT A LOSS THAT
WASN'T DONE THAT WE COULD HAVE
GONE TO A REGIONAL SENATORS
CORNERS HAVE BEEN GONE ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO EITHER FUND OR
HELP US FIND THE GENERIC
RESOURCES NEEDED. TO ADVOCACY
TO HELP GET WHAT WE NEEDED
WHETHER WAS TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR THROUGH OTHER
RESOURCES THAT WE HAD ACCESS TO
AND WHEN ALL ELSE HAVE BEEN
EXHAUSTED THEY WERE THERE TO
STEP UP TO THE PLATE TO REALLY
HELP WITH PAINFULFOR THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR DEDICATION
TO OUR FAMILY WE'VE SEEN THEM
ALL BECOME VERY STRAINED OVER
THE YEARS- ARE YOU WE GOT INTO
THE SYSTEM WHEN WE- MY SON WAS
DIAGNOSED AT THE AGE OF TWO SO
FOR THE FIFTEEN YEARS. THAT
I'VE GONE THROUGH WE'VE SEEN SO
MUCH CHANGE AND WE REALLY FEEL
FOR THEM AND THE STRESS OF THE
ADDITIONAL- ADDITIONAL WEIGHT
HAS REALLY PLAYED A ROLE ON
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB
THEY DO THEIR VERY BEST. THERE
HAVE BEEN TIMES WHEN MY FILE
TAKES LONGER AND LONGER TO
SERVE AND A PERFECT EXAMPLE IS
THAT WE HAVE RECENTLY OFFER A
PARTICULAR SUBSTANCE AND OUR
SERVICE COORDINATOR TOOK TEN
DAYS IN ORDER TO YOU KNOW THE
DOCTOR THAT SHE WAS WORKING ON
IT SHE JUST DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
EVEN EMAIL ME BACK AND I REALLY
FEEL FOR HER- WHEN I SPOKE TO
HER I COULD TELL THAT SHE WAS
OVERWHELMED AND DOCTORS AND
EVEN INCLUDE THE THINGS THAT GO
ON WITHIN. THIS YEAR WITH THE
PANDEMIC EVERYBODY'S WORKING
FROM HOME IT'S EVEN WORSE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE NEEDED-
WITHIN THEIR STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO DISTRIBUTE THE WEIGHT OF ANY
ONE PERSON MISSING ON EVERYBODY
ELSE SO- I HAVE NO IDEA WHEN
THEY'RE WALKING REYES WAS I'VE
NO IDEA WHEN DO YOU. MEMBERS
WHERE WE ADDRESS- REAL. FAST
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE
IS A- DEFINITE STRAIN ON. THE
NUMBER OF CLIENTS EACH PERSON
IN THE- EFFECT CARE OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A COLOR. AND TRY TO KEEP
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE IF YOU CAN.
AND OUR NEXT ARE LINE IS TO ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY IS
THAT ME. YES IT IS HI. HI MY
NAME IS THAT WE ON I AM A
REGIONAL PLANNER CLIENT AND
ALSO AND EIGHT THEIR RECORDS
AND H. YEAH. AND THE DIRECTORS
FOR FASHION ON ALL AND GET ME
OUT OF REACH THE THIRTIETH FOR
FAMILY DON'T CHILD THERAPY AND
LOCKED INTO IT. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO ADDRESS. THE
MINIMUM WEIGHT WEIGHT ISSUE FOR
D. F. P. THE WORK THAT WE DO IS
VERY INTENSE AND QUITE FRANKLY
IT'S INSULTING THAT A LOT OF US
GET PAID MINIMUM WAGE SO I
WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS
TO REALLY. CONSIDER THE MINIMUM
WAGE ISSUE AND AS A AND AS AN
ARTIST THE PERSON SIR BY
REGIONAL VENTURED SOUTH IN
TERMINATION IT'S SUPER CRITICAL
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
CONTROL OVER WHAT WE WATCH AND
COMMENTS LIKE IS IT REALLY
NECESSARY. FROM THE LEGISLATURE
KIND OF FRANKLY. MAKE ME REALLY
I YEAH BECAUSE WE'RE NOT BY
HAND THAT MAKE THAT MEAN THAT
WE CAN CAN. OUR LIFE AND GET
GETTING THE PROGRAM UP RATHER.
SOONER THAN LATER WE'LL MAKE
SURE THAT WE- ARE ABLE TO
PREPARE EVERYTHING TO REALLY
ACCESS OUR COMMUNITIES ONE FOR
IT PHYSICALLY ABLE TO DO SO. I
REALLY WANT YOU GUYS TO THE
STATE ITSELF GERMINATION
PROGRAM IF ANYTHING PUSH IT.
PUSH POP THE DATE IN ACTING AT
DINNER THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
REALLY HOPE. HE TAKE MY COM
SERIOUSLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR PLEASE. RETURNED TO
LIGHT OF ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A LUGONES. I DON'T
WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS THAT LAST
YEAR REPORT ON THE WHAT DID
THEY GET ON BRINGING IT UP AT
LEAST AND THAT MEANT IT THE
REPORT READS THAT ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
INDIVIDUALS DID NOT RECEIVE ONE
SINGLE SERVICE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PANDEMIC. DO YOU THINK IT
THAT WAS MY CHOICE LISA MYERS.
IT IS NOT IT IS ALMOST 20%
MEANING A ONE OUT OF FIVE.
FAMILIES IN IT AND THEN IT DID
NOT NEED ONE SINGLE SERVICE
BASED ON. WHAT I STRUGGLE AND
WHAT OTHER MOTHERS HAVE TO
SHARE WITH ME THAT SYSTEMICALLY.
WE DO NOT HONOR ASSEMBLY THEN I
FELT THAT MY LANGUAGE AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT HISPANIC BECAUSE
OF THE SEVERITY BETWEEN THAT.
WHAT ARE THE REGIONAL CENTER
WILL EXPAND BY RATE. AT LEAST
BETWEEN LOCATION AND HISPANIC
IT'S A DIFFERENCE OF. WHITE
PEOPLE RECEIVING EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
VERSUS A HISPANIC FAMILY
EXPENDITURE OF NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO BY LANGUAGE BY
READING THE REPORTS THAT THEY
HAVE- POSTED. AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY THAT MEANS LIKE
LAST YEAR MY LANGUAGE THE
AVERAGE WAS TWENTY POINT FOR
ONE OUT OF LOOKS BY FAMILY. DID
NOT RECEIVE ONE SERVICE AND IF
WE GO BY A COMMITTEE OR RATE
IT'S EVEN WORSE BECAUSE IT.
TWENTY NINE POINT 9% THAT MEANS
ONE OF THREE FAMILIES DID NOT
WITH THE ONE THING LOOK SERVICE
FROM REGIONAL CENTER NOTHING
THE HISPANIC POPULATION. BOB MY
CONCERN MY CHILD WAS DIAGNOSED.
AT FOURTEEN YEARS ELEVEN MONTHS
WE FOUND OUT IN JANUARY.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
WE MET FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH
THE CERVICAL NAY YOUR- INMATE
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN DAYS.
FOR THE CLIENT FAMILY TO GRIEVE
OUR- GOD RULER LITERALLY
DESTROYED MY FAMILY. BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WE WERE
NOT. COMPREHENDING WE WERE DOES.
LITTLE LEAGUE STRUGGLING. AND
THE HOW LONG TOOK ACCORDING IS
CALLED ME AND- ONLY BEYOND. THE
RECORDING NEEDLES WHO PER YEAR
AT THE BEGINNING- RATE. OF.
FORTY SIX THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS CANNOT GIVE
ME A CALL. IS SET UP AN
APPOINTMENT- I'M BEING TOLD
THAT MY DAD HAS A- LOOK AT THE
MOMENT STAY YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE YOUR CALL MULTI IT. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND TRY TO KEEP
YOUR CAR RUNNING. IN THE RETURN
FLIGHT OF TO TWO FAR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS A WHAT ON FROM THE AT THE OF
REGIONAL A- IN TURN THANK YOU
G. IN YOUR STAFF FOR THE
DETAILED AGENDA TO YOU OFTEN-GOOD COME. WITH AFTER THANK YOU
VERY AND THEN WILL FOLLOW WITH
WRITTEN FOR MY WAS TODAY'S THE
DAY BATH. I DON'T REALLY YOUR
FOR EVER BUT HAS ALSO RESULT
LOWER CRITICAL COMMUNITY
ORGANISED. COMPORT THIRD
AMERICAN TO HAVE NOT JUST HE
FOR OTHER ARE AS WELL AS THAT
WORK WITH THIRTY TO DISTRICT
YOU HEAR RANGING FORM CO TEST
PLATE A COMMITTEE TO. OUR THAT
HAS BEEN CORRECTLY BACK I THAT
THE CRITICAL REACH. WE
APPRECIATE APPLICABLE BUT A US
TO MORE RISK THAN HIM NUMBER
WILL INCLUDE RAY JUNK PREVENT
ALLEN AND YOU SERVICE MODEL.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW WE DON'T
PURCHASE A CONTINUUM OF RANGING
TURKEY. TO ALTERNATIVE SUPPORT
FOR IN THE SUBJECT COMMITTEE
PERSON NAME I DO TO CALL OUT
WITH YOU FOR SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATE PROGRAM. AS
IT WILL ALLOW FAMILY UNTIL WITH
THIS FROM DIVERSE COMMUNITY TO
SUPPORT WHEN I. WE WELCOME IN
DEPTH FROM RESTORATION ABOUT
PROGRESS YOU MAY IN SERVICE IN
THE FIRST. GETTING SERVICES
THAT. WE SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE
TO IMPROVE SERVICES TO FOSTER
CHILDREN WE DON'T CENTER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN THE
FORENSIC POPULATION AND IN
TERMS OF STAKEHOLDER ITEM
SUPPORT NUMBERS TO. TEN AND
TWELVE PARTICULARLY ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
RESOURCE CENTER FOR THE- TO
BETTER MEET PEOPLE WE NEED. AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE OF COURSE
AND I'VE- THAT THEY NEED AND
THE- THANK YOU FOR TO I'M GOING
HOME. ABOUT WHICH FACTORSBUT
FAMILY DURING THE SHOULD
PENSION AND WITH PROGRAMS AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
TIME AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RICHARD LIGHT OF TWO
TWO ZERO THREE GO AHEAD. SHARE
DOCTOR AND REMINDERS- I'M VERY-
THE CARE KERR AT THE TIME
DISABILITIES ASSOCIATE WE WERE
OVER HOW COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDER THROUGHOUT THE- I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE- TODAY
AND ALSO THANK. FOR THE
EDUCATION AS AS OUR- BOB AND
THEN I THEN A OF YOUR BILL
WHICH WILL OF BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
IT AS WELL WE HAVE WITH. YOU ON
SUPPORT OF OUR PARTNERS WITH
THE- I WANT TO FOCUS MY ON JUST
THE MOST ON THE PETER SUPPORT
WORKFORCE. AND THEN THE RITALIN
PACKED ON A CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ENGLISH DEVELOPMENT SHOULD- SO
LOOKING AT NUMBERS ISSUE THREE.
AND BE AGENDA TODAY- PENSION-
I'M GREAT SHARE COMMENT
MEDICARE WILL HEAR DR. ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY FISCAL
FONG GOING SO ME- IT CERTAINLY
UNLOCKED WHAT OR- COMMUNITY THE
CENTURY CAN COUPLE YEARS AGO
CHALLENGE FROM. IN GETTING A
COUPLE AWAITING- IN ON THE
FIRST AND WE CERTAINLY YOUR-
MA'AM AND RECOGNIZE OF THE FACT
WE'RE STARTING ALL OF THIS-
WILL QUICKLY DOLLARS
UNDERFUNDED. WILL MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TASK AND THE DO
FEATURE PHYSICAL TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE A TO WAGES- THERE
ADEQUATE PROFESSIONALISM- UNDER
DIRECT WORK FRESH WORK FOR. AND
THAT YOU KNOW BETWEEN IN WITH.
AND THAT OUR SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONNECTIONS IN OUR
SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
ARE GETTING THE SERVICES THEY
NEED. INITIALLY CAMPAIGNERS
PROFESSIONAL MAKE SURE YOU KNOW
THE BETTER CHANCE YOU GET HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES AND SUPPORT-
THAT- LOOKING AT OUR OUR
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT AROUND
EQUITABLE RATE ADJUSTMENTS OR
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DID I
DID HEAR THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL. CONTINUE TO BE
IN TOUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
REMARKS I WAS PART OF THE LAD
COALITION EFFORTS ONE OF SOCIT
MYSELF FOR THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE EARLIER BY MISTER
LINDSEY. I'LL MAKE A FEW
DISTINCT POINTS FROM THE DEAL
WITH THE ALLIANCE. SHORTLY AND
ONE AGREE WITH DOCTOR PAN. AT
THE DEPARTMENT'S OWN RATE STUDY
CALLED FOR BY THE LEGISLATURE
SHOWS THAT THE SYSTEM IS
UNDERFUNDED BY AT LEAST ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
INADEQUACY A RATE IS EASILY THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR. IN THE
AVAILABILITY AND QUALITY OF
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WITH I. D.
D. IN CALIFORNIA- THE SECOND
ELECTRODE REMARKED AT THE
DEPARTMENT ALTERNATIVE SERVICE
MODEL WHILE WELL INTENDED. HAS
BEEN AS WAS NOTED IMPLEMENTED
CHAOTICALLY WITH LAST MINUTE
NOTICES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
LACK OF CLARITY ON RATES TO
PROGRAM'S. INCONSISTENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER LEVEL- THIRD SYSTEM
REFORM DISCUSSIONS BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN OUR OPINION A
LITTLE OF TUNE RIGHT
NOW GIVEN THAT WE'RE ALL. IN
CRISIS IN SURVIVAL MODE WE
BELIEVE SUCH DISCUSSION SHOULD
BE HELD. FOR SURE BUT OUR PARTY
OUGHT TO BE KEEPING COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AS
INTACT AS POSSIBLE. FOR WE'LL
DISCUSS TODAY THAT WE ARE
GRAVELY THAT THE DEPARTMENTS
PUT OUT A DIRECTIVE STATING IT
WILL ATTEMPT TO CALL BACK
FUNDING FROM ANY PROGRAM THAT
SOUGHT AND RECEIVED A PPP LOAN
THESE WERE AVAILABLE TO
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT AMERICA
INCLUDING NONPROFITS THIS IS
EXACTLY THE WRONG DIRECTION
DURING A CRISIS WHICH IS ONLY
COMPOUNDED BY THE CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING DIRECTIVES ABOUT
WHETHER PROGRAMS WOULD EVEN
RECEIVE BASE FUNDING MORE OFTEN
PLATE AND MANY PROVIDERS HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO SEEK PPP LOAN.
GUARANTEE BEING ABLE TO RETAIN
THEIR STAFF AND MEET OTHER
FINANCIAL BLIGATIONS LASTLY I
JUST LIKE INDICATING THE
ALLIANCE TO SUPPORT REVIEWS ONE
TO ATTEND FROM THE LIST OF
PROPOSAL COVERED BY THE STATIC
WE SUPPORT ISSUE TWELVE FROM
THE LIST AS WELL REALLY RELATED
TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS BUT
ONLY AFTER COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES ARE GIVEN FROM MY
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A GREAT HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT CALLER IS TWO ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND DR- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE TESTIMONY
ON THE ISSUES MY NAME IS DR
GRANT PARK TO FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
EASTERNMOST SENT TO THE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER WHERE
CONTRACTED APPOINT THE UNDER
PART C. OF IDA WIKIPEDIA. AND
WE'RE ALSO ASSEMBLY VOICES
EXECUTIVE MEMBER AGENCIES- AND
WE SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN. WITH SPECIAL
HEALTHCARE. MOST CORNELIA NOT
SURE OF THE PLAN. RESEARCH
CENTERS OF CAL. BUT THEN TWENTY
THAT'S- FOR FUN THERE BY CO.
AND THE END BUT A CARD THE ON
DISABILITY HE CALIFORNIA FOR
THIRTY YEARS- LED BY PARENTS
AND A STRONG PARTNER. FOR A
MOMENT WHERE THE PROBLEM IS
WITHOUT. SERVICES KNOWING THE
ON THE GROUND WORK WITH
FAMILIES- ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND- HUESO OFFICE
EIGHT POUND. AND SHIFT PERCENT
OF HALF PRICE FEE ACTUALLY OUT
LIKE. I'M NOT NOT YET- CHILDREN
OF PARENTS WITH CHILDREN SOME
OF IT- YEAH OF COURSE BECAUSE
BY FOR THE- TOTAL AMOUNT SPENT
A COMMITMENT ON IT EITHER I.
BUT I WANT TO FIX THE TO
COMMUNITY NOT A OF COMBAT IN
WHICH WE ARE I. WE SUPPORT THE-
MEMBERS APPROACH PROGRAM BY THE-
OF FOR RESOURCE. AND I WANT TO
KNOW THAT THIS WITH THAT FROM
THE MILLION AND- ACCESS MY
THREE GRANT MONEY THAT WILL
REMAIN. THE DEAL- I AGREE
ACTUALLY WHERE MOST OF THE
AMERICANS COMMENTED. THAT THE
ASSEMBLY NOT BEST SUITED TO
ADMINISTER THE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM LIKE THAT I
BELIEVE THE ACROSS THESE ARE
THE ONLY STATEWIDE NETWORK ABLE
TO ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM.
WELL SUPPORT BERMAN NATION OF
ANOTHER CLEAR DROP OFF THAT
HAPPENS WITH FAMILIES THAT THEY
LIED EARLY START PROGRAM THAT
THIRTY SIX MONTH. PROGRAM WOULD
ALLOW MANY ASPECTS THE LATEST
OAKLAND BE THAT THEY CONSERVE
OUR FAMILY FELT MAKE. THANK
YOUNG WOMAN THANK YOU. THAT-
THERE ARE SOME. ITEMS THAT
MIGHT TO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT CONCERT AMOUNT.
COMMUNITY COURT MANY. PROJECT
THERE SOME- OF THE TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL ARE HYPER. GROUPS
DIFFERENT CULTURE AND LOOK
MOVEMENT GROUP THAT ARE GOING
TO REQUIRE MORE THAN ONE TIME
EQUIVALENT- THREE. YEAH
CURRENTLY COURT- YEAH WENT BACK
ON BUT WE THAT CONDO I WOULD
ASK YOU TO READ YOUR COM WE
HAVE A OF LEFT IN THE AND MUCH
TIME ON PHONE. OKAY I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THAT WE CAN
THAT THE CONDO BE HAVE TO
DEVOTE A SIMILAR CONTRACT. FOR
ANOTHER DAY PROGRAM THAT HAVE.
THEY HAVE COME UP DAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. OUR NEXT CALL IS LAW TO
THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MICHAEL MERRIN
CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR SERVICE
COORDINATION. I THINK ACTUALLY
IN ATLANTA WITH HIGHER
CULPABILITY REGIONAL PLANNERS
ARE UNABLE TO HIRE AND RETAIN
QUALIFIED FOR THE COORDINATORS
WORKING TO MEET TO CALM THREE
FIVE HE HAD CHRISTINE CAPABLE.
THE MISSION RESOURCES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WEEK TO OF TO THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JEREMY HOGAN- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ANOTHER MEMBERS I'M
THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
DISABILITY SERVICES I
CALIFORNIA HUMAN DEVELOPMENT IN
SANTA ROSA WE PROVIDE A PROGRAM
IMPLEMENT SERVICES- I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
ESPECIALLY- NANCY BARGE
MENINDEE DS FOR ALL THE WORK
THEY'VE DONE IN COLLABORATING
AND BEING FLEXIBLE. LIGHTEST
PANDEMIC- I JUST WANTED SOME
MONEY TODAY ECHOING THE
RECOGNITION OF THE HURLOCK WORK
THAT THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS FIELD
I'VE DONE AND THAT THE NEED TO
PAY THEM ACCORDINGLY- THE
PANDEMIC'S ONLY REINFORCED WHAT
PROVIDERS IN THE INDIVIDUALS WE
SUPPORT AND THE STATE'S ON.
RACESTUDY HAS RECOGNIZED THAT
THERE'S A BIG BIG GAP ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR GAP INTHE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE WORK FORCE
AND THE REALITIES OF OUR
FUNDING SYSTEM AND APPRECIATE
WHAT DOCTOR PAN- SAID EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT THE RATE STUDY- AND
ALSO WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
PRIORITIES AND WHAT WE VALUE IF
WE SAY THAT WE TRULY VALUE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORTING THIS POPULATION.
THEN WE MUST PRIORITIZE AND
VALUE THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
WORKING TO SUPPORT THEM AFTER
PERHAPS BEING ABLE TO PAY
COMPETITIVE WAGE AND RECRUIT
AND RETAIN AN EFFECTIVE WORK
FORCE THIS CAN BE DONE BY
PROFESSIONAL ICE IN THE S. P.
WORKFORCE IN MODERNIZING THE
BSP WAGE INCREASES. BECAUSE
DSPS COMPENSATION SHOULD NOT BE
TETHERED AROUND MINIMUM WAGE
BASED RATE THEY'RE NOT DOING IT
THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF WORK
YOU'RE GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND-
AND BEING PAID AT A RATE THAT
DOES NOT REFLECT THE IMPORTANT
WORK THEY'RE DOING- I ALSO ONE
ECHO THE SUPPORT OF CANCELING
SCHEDULED RATE CUTS I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THE SUPPORT- FROM NUMBERS
OUT TODAY. IT'S REALLY HARD ON
PROVIDERS TO MANAGE A BUDGET
AND CREATE A SUSTAINABLE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE WITH THESE TYPE
OF MECHANISMS IN PLACE SO AGAIN
IT'S JUST REFRESHING TO HEAR ON
THE COMMITTEES TODAY SO THANK
YOU FOR THE. TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT CALLER IS. MINE TO.
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO THREE
FIVE YOU MAY HAVE YOUR PHONE
MUTED. THERE WAS NO RESPONSE WE
WILL MOVE ON THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER ONE EIGHT THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JACKIE FOSTER I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
SERVING IN THE ULTRA CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL CENTER AND NORTH OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER. I'M AN
ECHO AROUND THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS THAT I WANT TO BE
VERY SPECIFIC AROUND THOSE LAST
OF MARCH TWELFTH WERE THE IN
PERSON SUPPORT I THINK THAT THE
WAGES THEY WERE PAID DURING
THAT TIME WERE OBVIOUSLY THEY
WERE LOW PRIOR. AND SEEN WHAT
THEY HAD DONE THEY WERE THE
BACKBONE OF THIS PANDEMIC
RESPONSE. THEY WERE THE PEOPLE
THAT SHOWED UP AND MAKE SURE
PEOPLE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES WERE PROTECTED
EDUCATED AND SUPPORTED
THROUGHOUT THIS TIME BUT
THEY'RE COMPETITIVE WAGES ARE
AT MINIMUM WAGE WE GAVE GREAT
GLORY TO THE GROCERY STORE
CLERK BUT OUR INVISIBLE
WORKFORCE ARE INVALUABLE
WORKFORCE WAS IGNORED. SO I
REALLY DO THINK THAT ONE IS A
PROFESSIONAL IS THE WORK FORCE
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT
PROFESSIONALLY IN A WORKFORCE
WITHOUT WAGES. IS KIND OF A
MUTE POINT BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A WORKFORCE CRISIS WE ARE
IN THE MOST EXTREME WORKFORCE
CRISIS I'VE EXPERIENCED IN MY
THIRTY YEARS IN THE SYSTEM. AND
PART OF THAT IS PART OF THE
WORK FORCE WAS ABLE TO BE
PROTECTED AT HOME AND PART OF
THE WORK FORCE CONTINUE TO WORK
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM
RECOGNIZED BYPUSHING YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT
CALLER TO ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS JUDY
MARC AND I AM THE PARENT OF A
SELF DETERMINATION PER CONTENT
AND PRESIDENTE DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED. I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS YOUR COMMENTS CENTER
EGGMAN ABOUT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM WHEN YOU
WENT AND KNOWLEDGE IDEA TO A
RESTAURANT THAT NO ONE IS GOING
TO- BUT IMAGINE THAT
RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN BOARDED
UP BY DUROC. AND THERE ARE HUGE
PHYSICAL BARRIERS PLACED ON THE
ROAD AT RESTAURANTS THE BALLOT
BASICALLY WHAT WE ARE FACING IN
ORDER TO MOVE INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. SO IN
FACT THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ON THE WAIT LIST TO GET
INTO THIS ABOUT THE TERMINATION
PROGRAM THE EMAIL WITHIN A
PROVIDING CREDIBLE FLEXIBILITY
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
WHAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
SO MANY CREATIVE THINGS IN IT
LIKE BECAUSE YOU TO SELF
DETERMINATION. ARE YOU GETTING
BETTER OUTCOME AND WE ALSO KNOW
IT REDUCES RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES. SO WE JUST HOPE
THAT YOU WILL REALLY I'M I'M
HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOU TO TELL
YOU ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST IN THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM AND
I'M- HAPPY TO REACH OUT TO YOUR
STAFF TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I CERTAINLY
DIDN'T MEAN TO OFFEND ANYBODY
WITH MY COMMENT BUT I LIKE THAT
YOU'RE CONTINUE TO USE THE
ANALOGY BECAUSE NOW MY QUESTION
IS GOING TO BE PLEASE DO
COMMUNICATE WITH MY STAFF. AND
NOT ON THE VALUE OF THE PROGRAM
I THINK WE'LL GET THAT BUT WE
BUT WHY AREN'T MORE PEOPLE AT
THE RESTAURANT WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS WHAT IS THE WAITING
LINE WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS
KEEPING. PEOPLE FROM GOING IN
THE DOOR TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE SERVICES THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
I'D LIKE TO KNOW. AND PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE STAFF. WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT CALLER. LAW TWO ONE
TWO PLEASE CALL. HI YES THANK
YOU- MADAM IN APPEAR CENTER AND
THE ONE THAT MY NAME CHRISTY
CAMERA I AM REGIONAL BOARD
MEMBER OKAY COMMITTEE MEMBER
FRANK P. DISABILITY COMMUNITY
OUT OF DIFFICULT IMPORTANTLY
MOTHER TO MY SON JOHNNY. THE
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD WHO
TWENTY THREE YEARS OLD A
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER
SITTING NEXT TO ME JOHNNY ABOUT
MENTAL CHALLENGES AND COMPLEX
HEALTH CARE NEEDS MANY PEOPLE
SPOKE TODAY ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY FOR REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS. HOWEVER NO ONE SPOKE
ABOUT THE ENORMOUS FISCAL
IMPACT ON OUR STATE EVERY
SINGLE DAY THAT GOES BY WHERE
CONSUMERS WITH SERIOUS MEDICAL
CONDITIONS LIKE MY FRIEND
JOHNNY ANOTHER WE WERE AT HIGH
RISK OF HOSPITALIZATION DYING
FROM COLON. IS NOT ONLY A
MATTER OF LIFE OR DEATH AND THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE RELATED TO
HEALTH EQUITY BUT IT IS A HUGE.
FISCAL CONCERN. JUSTIN TWENTY
TWO IN JAN TWO TWENTY ONE. AT
ARMS REACH CENTER NINE. DIED
AND HUNDRED FORTY ONE WERE
HOSPITALIZED. IT IS JUST ONE
REGIONAL CENTER AND YOU KNOW
THERE ARE TWENTY ONE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REDUCING AVOIDABLE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
UTILIZATION SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF WHAT OUR STATE IN
FISCAL- DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT IT IS A VERY SIMPLE
FIX FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO
CHANGE THE ROLLOUT DATE.
IMMEDIATELY WHILE I AM GRATEFUL
AGAIN IT IS NOT. ENOUGH TIME
BECAUSE EVERY TIME THAT GOES
BY- IT WILL BE MAY FIRST BEFORE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE GO
OFF THE MARCH FIFTEENTH STATE
WILL BE FULLY VACCINATED AND
STAY FROM ENDING UP IN THE
HOSPITAL. I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
BRING UP- OUR SELF
DETERMINATION- AS A LOCAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE PERSON
CENTER PLAN INDEPENDENT BILL.
THE VILLAGE EAGER TO BE
CONTINUED WHEN THE PROGRAM
ROLLED OUT IN JUNE. AND IF THE
BARRIERS CONTINUE TO EXIST I
WOULD ENCOURAGE. YOU TO LOOK AT
THE BILL MARK WEAVER HEPA
WAIVER AGENCIES UNDER UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND HOW THAT ROLL OUT
HAS BEEN VERY- STREAMLINING-
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
MAY NEED TO LOOK AT HERSELF
DETERMINATION- I ALSO WOULD ARE
ENCOURAGING TO GIVE GRANTS AND
FIND. YOURSELF BE TERMINATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS SO WE CAN GET
QUALITY CONTINUE TO GET QUALITY
SERVICES AND MORE MORE PURCHASE
AND- ARE INVOLVED. ALSO LAST
WEEK- I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
EXPAND PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES UNDER SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT I HOPE EVERYBODY
HERE. THERE ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
CODED STARTED MANY MANY
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES RIGHT
WHAT THE REGIONAL CENTER THE
REQUESTED PERKINS SENT DIRECTLY
SERVICES. HOWEVER THEY WERE NOT
GIVEN PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES THEY WERE GIVEN
SERVICES UNDER THE TRADITIONAL-
PROVIDERS UNDER THE TRADITIONAL
THIRTY. WHICH MEANS THAT THERE
IS A MANDATORY- MINIMUM WAGE OF
SIXTEEN DOLLARS AND TWENTY FIVE
CENTS. THAT WAS. INCORPORATED
INTO THE PARK INSPECTOR. ACTED
SERVICES ROLLOUT. THROUGH
TRADITIONAL. MEMBERS NOT MA'AM
MA'AM HAVE A LOT OF IN THE
QUEUE I NEED TO MOVE ON BUT
AGAIN. FEEL TO REACH OUT TO
DOCK PULLED- STEPS ME ON THIS
OF WE WOULD LIKE WE- YOUR INPUT
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TODAY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE
COLOR IS LIGHT TWO TWO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING YEP COME ON. THE NEW
YORK CONTRACT I AM A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT THREE CLASSICAL
PRESIDENT WHO CITY OF
WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA. I AM
OPTIMISTIC ENDING IN A COMMENT
I AM PREPARED SO PLEASE HAVE
PATIENCE WITH ME. I'M CALLING
TO PROVIDE FURTHER COMMENT ON I
DON'T WANT BUDGET SUMMARY AN
ITEM TO HOLD HER SPOT. I WOULD
LIKE TO. THANK JENNEKE HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT ON MY FAMILY. MY
BROTHER AND I ARE BOTH ARTISTIC
YOU AND CONSUMERS OF THE HARBOR
REGIONAL CENTER. HAVING ACCESS
TO MUCH NEEDED SERVICES DURING.
THAT IT IS CRITICAL. PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE ME I'M THAT FOR HAS
PROPOSED TO ADDRESS NEEDS IN MY
COMMUNITY. BUT I FEAR WILL NOT
BE ENOUGH WITH MANY FAMILIES
ARE DOING WITHOUT SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW ALSO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN IS
FINDING. IT TEN YEARS IN THE
FUTURE I ACCESS THE MOBILITY
OPERATIONS AND SUPPORT I WOULD
USUALLY BE AN ISSUE IN MY
COMMUNITY. ESPECIALLY A
REGIONAL CENTER MARKET OF COLOR.
I THE MAJOR. ISSUE AND VERY.
FOR MY BROTHER WELCOME DURING
MAKE IT INTO THE FUTURE PLEASE
DO NOT FORGET IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL
PLEASE. VERY GOOD ON THE TIME I
REALLY. THAT. CALLERS TO FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF BOTH THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THIS IS TOM SHE HERE
ON BEHALF OF MR LESS ROAD NO
RESIDENT LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
HE'S GOT A DAUGHTER OF HELP TO
THE NORTHERN LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL CENTER THAT'S ABOUT
STATE. WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN A PAGE
TWENTY SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA
THIS WOULD GIVE THE DDS
DIRECTOR THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE MORE DISCRETION ON
MANAGING OUT OF STATE CASES SO
THAT SHE CAN USE THEIR STUFF
MORE OF MORE EFFICIENTLY AND SO
THAT THE SERVICES CAN BE
DELIVERED- MORE EFFECTIVELY
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY
EIGHT. FOLKS RECEIVING SERVICES
UNDER THE LANHAM ACT UNDER OUT
OF STATE AND THIS WOULD HELP
ALL OF THEM IN OTHER CASES ARE
MANAGED WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THIS
AFTERNOON WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
YOUR STAFF THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND OUR NEXT CALLER IS
GOING TO BE LINE. TWO FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
HAVE YOUR PHONE YOU DID. THERE
WAS NO RESPONSE WE WILL MOVE
AROUND THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT
WILL BE OUR. NINE TWO SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. EIGHT I'M A PARENT
AND TWO YOUNG MEN WHO ARE WE
TALKING TO CONSUMERS. AND I
WORK FOR THE SEASON THE ONLY
FOCUS RESOURCE CENTER. SERVING
NORTH L. A. COUNTY. WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET I ALSO WANT
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OF THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
WITH THE FRC'S. MY AGENCIES
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED A
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
USING THE DISPARITY THIS
DISPARITIES TIMES. ONE THING WE
LEARNED IS THAT A LACK OF TRUST
GREATLY IMPACTED UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES. ONE OF THE TOOLS WE
USE TO BUILD TRUST WAS FREQUENT
CONNECTIONS WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
AS PEERS. PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM EXPERIENCED
INCREASED LEVELS OF TRUST AS
WELL AS IMPROVEMENT WITH THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF. THE OVERSEAS OF
THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
NETWORK ARE WELL POSITIONED TO
IMPLEMENT THE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM ACROSS THE
STATE. WE KNOW OUR PARENTS IN
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MANY
AGENCIES. WE KNOW HOW TO
COLLABORATE AND DO OUTREACH AND
WE ARE TRUSTED PROVIDERS
APPARENTLY PARENTS SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT
ISSUE WE ARE NEXT CALLER IS
GOING TO BE TWO FOUR NINE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HARKEN WE CREATED BY
STRICTER MARIE DENTURES THE DAY
PROGRAM IN MARIN COUNTY- AND
I'M CALLING VOICE- MY SUPPORT
FOR THE NEED. TO MODERNIZE-
IRAQ SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL HOPE
WAGE INCREASES TO BRING IN MORE
THAN ONE. WITH WHAT WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO DO- OKAY NEED TO
REFLECT A VALUE IN ASSESSING.
THE LIGHTS ARE NOT PARTICIPANTS.
HOW MANY OF YOU LOOKING FOR
HOMEWORK LOCAL BUILDINGS
NORDSTRAND. THAT NOT ONLY PUTS
THEM AT RISK AND- ACCOUNTABLE.
IT DOESN'T ONLY PUT THEM AT
RISK FOR PARKINSON'S ARRESTED
AROUND AS THEY MOVE FROM. ONE
VULNERABLE POPULATION TO
ANOTHER- THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE. NEXT IS
GOING TO BE. JUST A MOMENT TWO
SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU I'M DOCTOR SHOULDN'T GRIPS
WITH TRI COUNTIES REGIONAL
CENTER ON MD CLINICAL DIRECTOR
AND I'VE BEEN WITH TRI COUNTIES
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
IN MY OBSERVATION THAT DOES
SUCH INCRIMINATION DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN THAT THERE WILL BE
AT NO NEED FOR SERVICE
COORDINATOR MICROPORT INCREASE
FUNDS FOR ADDITIONAL SERVICE
COORDINATION. RECOGNIZE WAS A
PILOT SITE. I'M NOT IN MY MANY
FAMILIES WOULD HAVE GONE BACK
TO THE TRADITIONAL MODEL BECOME
WITH. SUCH A TERMINATION STYLE
DID NOT. SHIP THEM A BIT WAS
MUCH THEIR LIKING OR TO THEIR
ABILITY FOR SOME FAMILIES THEY
REALLY NEED. THAT TRAIN SERVICE
COORDINATOR. AND IT'S BEEN MY
OBSERVATION. ALSO LESSEN FIVE
YEARS IT'LL OF SKILLS. LEADS TO
A LACK OF DIRECT. WITH FAMILIES
WHICH LEADS TO A LACK OF. THE
NECESSARY COMMUNICATION WHICH
LEADS TO CREATING MEANINGFUL
IDPS WHICH AND BRING SERVICES
TO PERSON START. IF YOU
OVERSTRETCH CASELOADS THAT
LEADS TO A DECREASE IN
ADVOCACY. IN STATE ONLY TO
CONTRIBUTE IT WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO THE DISPARITY ISSUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NICE
COLOR PLEASE. AND OUR NEXT
CALLER IS GOING TO BE WHITE TWO
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. HELLO HELLO YES WE CAN- MY
NAME IS MERRY. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALAN PATON AND- I'M AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH- BY INCLUDE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS- I'M
CALLING. TO SUPPORT- I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE INCREASE
FUNDS FOR UP A CREEK FUNDING
FOR SERVICE COORDINATOR- I
ALSO- WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS. HI
MARK OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST. TO
VALUATE AND TREAT CLIENTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- NOT
ONLY FOR EARLY INTERVENTION BUT
ALSO WHEN THEY TRANSITION BACK
FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT-
ENACTED A REGIONAL CENTER-
THAT'S ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT CALLER IS
GOING TO BE. JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SEVEN ONE TWO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY THANK YOU HI AM I
AM I MODDED ALLOWED TO
WONDERFUL TRIPIT AND ALONG WITH
A VERY UNIQUE EFFICIENT INTO
HOSPITAL ONE FROM CP DOING
COLLECTING A SPECTRUM IN I AM
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THAT- WHEN
YOU RECORD- WRECKED THE
TERRORIST THAT. I'M YOU KNOW
DIRECT. I'VE BEEN. HELLO TIMES
AND I'M GOING TO DO A CALL AND
I THESE EACH HAVE. PREVIOUS
MEMBERS HERE TALK ABOUT IT IS
BEING RECORDED I KNOW THEY DO-
BUT HE WON INTENDED HOW BEING.
I'LL GIVE YOU MY DEAR INTO TO
TWENTY- YEAH ART AND- WE HAD A
CONCERT BROKE GOING FROM THIS
NOTHING. BUT THE DEBATE THAT
THE HOUSING MORE RUGGED IN THE-
ON DIRECT DIRECT INSTEAD OF.
THE WHY THE BAY IS STABLE
COMMUNITY DURING THE DAY TO
PICK TIME THE NIGHT CONDEMN
MAKE THE REGION UP DECLINE THAT
PALM IT KIND OF THE ABLE TO
WATCH. BUT THE DEFENDER THE
GRANT BUT I WAS GOING TO HE
SAID PROVIDING THEY HAVE ENTRY
INTO THEIR HOME WORKING
OVERTIME. THAT NUMBER. TO BRING
THAT HE HAD NO BEEN PAID FOR
OUR WOULD YOU WALK. FAMILIES NO
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
THANK SIMPLEMENTE WELL WHAT IN.
INDUSTRY WHICH WHAT OF MEDIUM
THE OF FROM. INTRIGUING PALM
BEACH. THE INTENDED DIRECT IT'S
NOT EVEN A UP ENTERED ARE JUST
FOR FARMING DOING VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. EACH MEMBER WHY
IT'S OPENING OVERTIME FOR THE
ONLY SERVICE PROVIDERS MY SON
HAD EIGHTEEN HOLDEN IN MANY OF
THE FAMILIES OKAY. MA'AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I ASK THAT
YOU EMAIL US WITH ANYMORE.
STATEMENT NEXT COLOR PLEASE. IN
OUR NEXT CALLER WILL BE MINE.
TWO SEVEN TWO PLEASE CONTACT.
TO SERVER TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY WANT TO A METER LINE IF
IT'S NEEDED. THERE WAS NO
RESPONSE WE WILL MOVE ON MADAM
CHAIR. AND IT WILL BE LINE ART
TWO SIX THREE ONE I WOULD AND I
WILL TELL COLORS IT IS NOW FIVE
TWENTY THREE WE ONLY HAVE THE
PHONE LINES UNTIL FIVE THIRTY.
SO PLEASE BE VERY CONSIDERATE
WITH YOUR TIME. AND THEY WILL
ASK EVERYBODY ELSE TO EMAIL
THEIR RESPONSE TO US OR CONTACT
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN TWO EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MADAM CHAIR THAT SITS ON CAP HE
WOULD MAKE YOU CAPTAIN THE
THIRTIETH TOMAHAWK OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION ON CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION CENTER IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND GETTING
YOUR COMMENTS WHICH TWENTY
STRONGLY SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE RELATED TO COMMUNITY
NAVIGATORS I WOULD ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT CHAT OR
EVEN PROVIDED THANK YOU. SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. OKAY WE MOVE. TO
LINE. JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE FOUR ZERO YOU
MIGHT HAVE YOUR PHONE MUTED.
THERE WAS NO RESPONSE I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER. AND
IT WILL BE ONLINE TWO SEVEN
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT TO
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI YES THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
AND FOR YOUR HEARING TODAY ON
THESE IMPORTANT MATTERS MY
NAME'S DONNA FEINGOLD ON THE-
DIRECTOR OF THE ADAPTIVE
LEARNING CENTER IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY BECAUSE THE TIME I JUST
WANT TO STATE CLEARLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL. FOUR INVESTMENT
NUMBER ONE TWO ONE THREE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES ARE
UNDERSTANDING HOW IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO GET RID OF THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE AND HOW
MUCH IT IS HURTING HURTING OUR
DOOR FOR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS AND WE NEED THE
SECURITY. TO KNOW THAT THE
FUNDS WILL BE IN PLACE.
EMPLOYMENT OUT FOR P. WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THEY
WORK- SO MANY OF THEM LOST
THEIR JOBS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THEY NEED TO WORK IMPORTANT
FOR THEIR SELF WORTH. YOU CAN
FINALLY OUR SUPPORT THE HOLDEN
BELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT
CALLER IS GOING TO BE LINE. R.
ONE SEVEN SEVEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN ONE SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE HAS
REALIGNED UNIT PLEASE ADVENTURE
FONG. THERE WAS NO RESPONSE
THERE WE WILL MOVE OUR. THEIR
COLOR IN THE QUEUE. HERE WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER CALLER IN THE
QUEUE YOU JUST A MOMENT. AND
IT'S TWO OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALLER PLEASE
PROCEED. WHAT WE CALL WE ARE
WILL. RECOMMENDED TO SUPPORT
MAY BE A PROBLEM. SO
DETERMINATION ARE DIRECTLY
PEOPLE MORE MINIMUM WAGE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN OUR NEXT
CALLER IS GOING TO BE. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT ARE PLESE GO AHEAD
TO SEVEN EIGHT ARE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
PERMANENTLY ON. OKAY AN ECONOMY
YES. YES ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR IT YES MY FUNNY FACTORY ON-
HERE AUTHORITY SPAWNING PEOPLE
PROBABLY CAN YOU CAN HAVE BEEN
A- FAR HE HANDLE ARE THAT THAT
MANY YEARS BACK. WHEN I BETTER
IN BANG BANG NEED IT AND THEN I
THEN I DATA WANT THEM IF THEY
THOUGHT IN IT BUT MY PROBLEM
SAID THANK YOU FOR MY BECAUSE
ENGLISH IS- WE UNDER. YOU JUST
FIND YOU VERY MUCH THANK CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. OKAY THIS
COLOR YOU THE FINAL. OKAY-
FINAL CALL WILL TWO FIVE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO FIVE THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS DORIAN TANAKA
I'M THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DIRECTORATE MARIN CENTURY I'M
ALSO A PARENT. NOTABLY HAVE
BEEN TRYING UNSUCCESSFULLY TO
GET INTO ABDUCTED TERMINATION
PROGRAM BUT HAS BEEN TOLD THERE
IS NO MORE ROOM AT THE TABLE TO
NOT RESTAURANTS- I WANTED TO.
STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
REMOVING THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
THE FUNDING FOR COMMEMORATION
CREE FAITH. THANK YOU DR PAN
AND EVERYONE WHO REMINDED US OF
THE FACT THAT THE RATE STUDY
POINTED OUT THAT THIS WAS BUT-
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF WHAT IS
ACTUALLY NEEDED IN TERMS OF
FINDING- AND FINELY- YOU. CAN
JUST SAY THAT. YOU KNOW IT. WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE LARGER
OF THE SPENDING SOMETHING THAT
IS FOR NEEDS THAT WE KNOW WILL
NOT ITSELF I WISH THE FANS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH EVERYBODY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
FINAL WORD- I WANT TO THANK.
EVERYBODY FOR WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY- AND AGAIN IF YOU IF YOU
DID NOT GET TO GET TO SAY AS
MUCH AS YOU'D LIKE OR YOU
DIDN'T GET TO. MAKE YOUR VOICE
HEARD TODAY- YOU CAN PLEASE
EMAIL THE COMMITTEE STAFF
DOCTOR NEED TO POKE- WE CAN
ALWAYS WELCOME TO CONTACT ME
FOR FURTHER INPUT AS WELL. BUT
I WANT TO THANK THE MODERATOR I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF WHO
WORKED ON ALL THIS- WANTING TO
DEPARTMENT FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THE L. A. O. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YOU
ARE ALL VERY VALUABLE TO THIS
PROCESS AND WE APPRECIATE YOU-
AND WITH THAT WE WILL. ADJOURN
THE MEETING.